♪
>> HELLO AND WELCOME TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE GETTING YOU READY FOR THE
A'S AND THE ANGELS FROM ANAHEIM.
LOOK AT THAT BEAUTIFUL BEACH
WEATHER OUT THERE IN SOCAL
TODAY.
WE'RE GETTING SET FOR COLE IRVIN
AGAINST JONATHAN DIAZ, MAKING
HIS MLB DEBUT FOR THE HALOS
HERE.
SHOHEI OHTANI WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ON THE BUMP, BUT HE ISN'T GOING
TO PITCH TONIGHT AND MAY NOT
PITCH FOR THE REST OF THE
SEASON.
HE IS IN THE LINEUP, THOUGH, AS
WE SEE THE PLAYERS WARMING UP IN
ANAHEIM.
LOOKS LIKE THIS IS THE WAY THE
A'S GET READY FOR THE GAME, A
LITTLE HACKY SACK.
YOU LIKE THAT?
LAUREN: I LOVE THAT.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO TO GET LOOSE.
HEIDI WE DO.
WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK PREGAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
TIME.
LAUREN GARDNER, HEIDI WATNEY
COMING TO YOU, GETTING SET FOR
THE A'S AND THE ANGELS.
REALLY IMPORTANT SERIES.
TELL US WHY.
LAUREN: HUGE SERIES.
AS OF JUNE 16, A'S WERE LOOKING
STRONG, ONE OF THE BEST TEAMS IN
ALL OF BASEBALL.
THEY REALLY SLID SINCE, 35-30
THERE LAST 65 GAMES.
YOU LOOK AT UP AND DOWN THEIR
LINEUP, THEY HAVE MADE GOOD
ACQUISITIONS AT THE DEADLINE.
THIS WAS A TEAM THAT MAYBE UPSET
HOUSTON, ENDED UP TAKING THAT
DIVISION.
NOT LOOKING GOOD.
THEIR PLAYOFF CHANCES ARE NOW
DOWN TO 4.4%, WITH ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST REMAINING SCHEDULES.
HEIDI: THEY DO HAVE ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST REMITTING SCHEDULES IN
BASEBALL, BUT ONLY THREE GAMES
OUT, AND THEY START WITH THE
SERIES TONIGHT AGAINST THE
HALOS.
BUT BOTH TEAMS WERE IN ACTION
YESTERDAY AND HERE IS HOW THOSE
GAMES WENT DOWN.
>> FOUR HITS, TWO HOME, FIVE
R.B.I.'S, AND FOUR RUNS SCORED
IN THIS SERIES.
>> OH.
>> LEFT CENTER FIELD, DEEP, NO
WAY.
GONE!
HE'S A MACHINE.
>> HE'S SALVY STRONG AND
CONTINUES TO DO IT.
>> HARRISON TO THIRD, CANHA TO
SECOND.
>> BASE HIT, LEFT FIELD.
ONE RUN SCORES.
CANHA COMING HOME, HE'S GOING TO
SCORE.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF POOR DEFENSIVE
PLAY BY THE ROYALS AND NOW IT'S
4-2.
>> HERE'S HARRISON.
THIS ONE DRIVEN, RIGHT CENTER.
OLIVARES BACK, AND IT'S OVER HIS
HEAD AND OFF THE WALL.
KEMP IS GOING TO COME INTO
SCORE.
HARRISON HAS A FOUR HIT GAME,
TWO MORE R.B.I.'S FOR JOSH
HARRISON, AND NOW IT'S 6-2.
>> SERGIO ROMO COMES OUT OF THE
A'S PEN, 1-1, 4.45 E.R.A.
>> OLSON'S GOT IT.
THAT WILL DO IT.
SO THE A'S NEEDED TO WIN THIS
SERIES AND THEY DO, AND NOW THEY
WILL HEAD TO ANAHEIM HOPEFULLY
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF MOMENTUM.
>> RAN HE FOR HAS BEEN --
RENGIFO HAS BEEN PICKING UP HIS
HITTING A LITTLE BIT.
>> OH, RENGIFO WITH A BIG SWING
AND A TWO RUN DINGER.
>> AN EARLY 2-0 LEAD.
>> AND THE ANGELS HAVE THE BASES
LOADED, AND JACK MAYFIELD WILL
BE THE NEXT BATTER.
>> MAYFIELD SENDS A BALL INTO
THE CORNER.
THAT'S A FAIR BALL.
STASSI SCORES EASILY.
WALSH WILL COME IN RIGHT BEHIND
HIM.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY IT WITH
WHEN HE FELT.
NO -- RENGIFO.
NO PLAY AT THE PLATE.
THE BALL GOT AWAY FROM COLLINS.
WOW!
STILL NOBODY OUT FOR JOSE ROJAS.
JOSE ROJAS WITH A DRIVE OUT TO
RIGHT.
THAT ONE'S GOING, TO GO AND WAY
OUT OF HERE!
7-0 ANGELS!
>> WELCOME BACK, JOSE ROJAS.
>> OHTANI IN FRONT OF THE
CHICAGO FANS THIS YEAR.
>> I'M GUESSING HE'S GOING TO
GET A CHANGEUP NOW AFTER TWO
FASTBALLS INSIDE.
>> HEY, DUDE.
THOSE ARE THREE BRUTAL MISSES.
THEY MIGHT RUN HIM.
WHAT'S THE DEAL HERE?
CHRIS CONROY'S COMING OUT.
THAT MIGHT BE IT.
THEY MIGHT RUN HIM HERE.
HE GONE!
>> TONY WILL WANT AN EXPLANATION
FOR SURE.
STARTING TO GET A LITTLE MORE
ANIMATED.
>> AND AWAY HE GOES, TONY LA
RUSSA EJECTED.
I THINK TONY'S ASKING, WHERE IS
THE WARNING?
THE CHANT IS "TONY."
HEIDI: SO THAT'S THE ACTION FROM
YESTERDAY FROM THESE TWO TEAMS.
RIGHT NOW, WE WELCOME SARAH
LANGS.
WELCOME, SARAH.
WE HAVE TO START OFF WITH A MAN
OF THE HOUR, SHOHEI OHTANI.
HE IS NOT ON THE MOUND TONIGHT
SO LET'S STICK TO HIS OFFENSE OF
PROWESS.
WHAT SETS HIM APART FROM THE
PACK IN THIS REGARD?
SARAH: MY FAVORITE THING ABOUT
SHOHEI OHTANI IS WHEN YOU
COMBINE HIS POWER AND HIS SPEED.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE LISTS TO
GENERATE, JUST ON STATCAST, IS
GUYS WHO ARE IN THE 90TH
PERCENTILE OR BETTER IN BOTH
HARD HIT RATE AND SPREAD SPEED.
I KNOW THAT -- SPRINT SPEED.
THESE ARE THE ULTIMATE POWER
SPEED COMBOS.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THESE
NAMES, SHOHEI OHTANI, TYLER
O'NEILL HOMERED FOR THE
CARDINALS.
WE'RE PUSHING FOR THAT
POSTSEASON STOP.
-- POSTSEASON SPOT.
MIKE TROUT AND BYRON BUXTON,
THESE ARE THE GUYS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE CRUSHING THE BALL
GOING TO BE CRUSHING THE BALL.
-- WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET INTO
THE PITCHING, UNFORTUNATELY WITH
HIM NOT GOING TONIGHT.
BUT THE FACT THAT HE DOES THAT
AND ALSO PITCHES IS
MIND-BOGGLING TO ME.
HEIDI: THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD LIST
THERE.
MATT OLSON HAS BEEN THE LEAGUE'S
LEADING POWER SOURCE.
SARAH: HE HAS MADE INCREDIBLE
IMPROVEMENTS THIS SEASON.
IT'S BEEN REALLY COOL TO SEE
HIM.
I WAS IN A MANAGERS MEETING WITH
BOB A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
WE WERE DOING AN A'S GAME AND HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW HE SET OUT
AND SAID, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M NOT GOING TO STRIKEOUT
ANYMORE.
WE SEE SO MANY STRIKEOUTS IN THE
GAME THESE DAYS, AND THE FACT
THAT A PLAYER CAN DECIDE IN THE
OFF-SEASON I'M NOT GOING TO
STRIKEOUT ANYMORE AND THEN DO IT
IS REALLY INCREDIBLE.
HE HAS A 15.5 POINT DROP OFF IN
HIS STRIKEOUT RATE THIS YEAR,
WHICH IS THE HIGHEST IN THE
MAJORS.
AND THIS IS THE MAIN REASON WHY.
HE'S NOT SWINGING AND MISSING
NEARLY AS MUCH.
ONLY GREGORY POLANCO HAS HAD A
LARGER DROP-OFF IN WHIFF RATE.
THAT'S SWINGS AND MISSES.
HE'S MAKING A TON MORE CONTACT.
THAT'S GOING TO LEAD TO A LOT
FEWER STRIKEOUTS.
IT'S BEEN GREAT TO SEE FOR HIM.
HE'S GOTTEN SOME CONVERSATION,
THAT THIRD-PLACE M.V.P.
CONVERSATION, AND HE ABSOLUTELY
DESERVES IT, AND IT'S REALLY
GREAT TO SEE THAT HE'S DONE
THAT.
AND I THINK STRIKING OUT LESS
HAS HELPED HIM BECAUSE HE WAS
ONE OF THESE GUYS WHO WOULD HIT
CLOSE TO 40 HOME RUNS STRIKEOUT
CLOSE TO 200 TIMES.
THE FACT THAT HE HAS CUT THAT
DOWN A LOT PUTS HIM IN A LOT
BETTER LIKE IN THAT NATIONAL
CONVERSATION.
HEIDI: THAT'S PRETTY REMARKABLE.
I'M JUST NOT GOING TO STRIKEOUT
AND ACTUALLY DO IT IS AMAZING.
HOW ABOUT DAVID FLETCHER AND HIS
HIGH CONTACT RATE?
SARAH: HE IS SUCH A FUN PLAYER
TO WATCH.
WHEN WE DID OUR TOP 10 RIGHT
NOW'S ENTERING THE 2020 SEASON,
HE WAS PLAYING THIRD BASE.
I HAD HIM ON MY LIST.
BRIAN KENNY ASKED ME TO DEFEND
THAT ONE.
HAVE YOU SEEN THIS GUY?
ALL HE DOES IS MAKE CONTACT.
THIS IS THE LOWEST WHIFF RATE
THIS SEASON, THE INVERSE OF
CONTACT RATE.
HE HAS BY FAR THE LOWEST WHIFF
RATE.
THAT IS A VERY HEFTY DEFENSE --
DIFFERENCE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU COMPARE TO
NUMBER TWO AND NUMBER THREE ON
THE LIST.
WHEN HE SWINGS, HE IS GOING TO
MAKE CONTACT.
AND IT'S ALL OVER THE ZONE AND
OUT OF THE ZONE.
HE HAS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
PITCHES EVER HIT FOR AN
EXTRA-BASE HIT.
IT WAS A DOUBLE LAST YEAR.
SINCE WE HAD PITCHED TRACK,
WHICH GOES BACK TO 2008.
THE THING HE DOESN'T DO IS HIT
THE BALL VERY HARD.
BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER AS LONG AS
YOU'RE MAKING THAT CONTACT AND
GETTING ON BASE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A BARREL THIS
YEAR, BATTED BALLS WITH THE
OPTIMAL CONVERSATION OF LAUNCH
ANGLE AND EXIT VELOCITY.
HE COULD END UP WITH THE MOST
BATTED BALLS THE SEASON WITHOUT
A BARREL, BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER
BECAUSE HE MAKES SO MUCH
CONTACT.
HEIDI: PUT THE BALL IN PLATE.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
MATT CHAPMAN IS ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT, A DEFENSIVE
STANDOUT FOR THE A'S.
HOW BIG A PRIORITY HAS THAT BEEN
THIS SEASON?
SARAH: THIS IS WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
MATT CHAPMAN.
I KNOW HE'S NOT HAVING A GREAT
YEAR AT THE PLATE, AND AFTER
BREAKING THROUGH AND HITTING
PRETTY WELL LAST YEAR, IT'S BEEN
A LITTLE DISAPPOINTING TO SEE
THAT HIS OFFENSE HAS TAKEN A
STEP BACK.
IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER WHEN
HE'S ABLE TO HELP THE TEAM IN
RUN PREVENTION WITH HIS DEFENSE.
HE HAS BY FAR THE MOST OUTS
ABOVE AVERAGE AMONGST FIRST
BASEMAN'S THIS SEASON.
YOU LOOK AT DEFENSIVE RUNS
SAVED, YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
SIMILAR LIST.
I LIKE OUTS ABOVE AVERAGE
BECAUSE IT ACCOUNTS FOR SPEED OF
THE RUNNER, WHO HE'S MAKING A
PLAY ON, AND I THINK THAT GIVES
YOU EVEN MORE OF A PICTURE OF
WHAT MAKES HIM SO GOOD.
IT'S REALLY FUN.
WE DID A GAME THAT INCLUDED BOTH
HIM AND MANNY MACHADO A COUPLE
WEEKS BACK OVER AT MLB NETWORK,
AND WE WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE SO DIFFERENT BECAUSE
MANNY MACHADO PLAYS IN
RIGHT-FIELD HALF THE TIME THESE
DAYS.
BUT WHAT MAKES CHAPMAN SO GOOD
IS HE COVERS THAT ACTUAL THIRD
BASEMAN RANGE INCREDIBLY WELL.
WITH OUTS ABOVE AVERAGE, WE CAN
TELL YOU HE PLAYS REALLY WELL
WHEN HE'S STANDING IN THAT
SHORTSTOP POSITION IN THE SHIFT,
WHICH IS PART OF WHAT MAKES YOU
A REALLY GOOD DEFENDER THESE
DAYS.
HEIDI: THAT'S PRETTY SPECIAL.
HE IS BACK IN THE LINEUP AFTER
MISSING THE LAST FOUR GAMES.
FINALLY, WE'VE GOT TO TALK ABOUT
STARLING MARTE, A HUGE
ACQUISITION FOR OAKLAND.
HE IS BATTING A HEFTY .343 SINCE
DURING THE A'S, BUT HE IS
INELIGIBLE TO WHEN THE BATTING
TITLE.
SARAH: YES, SO HE IS HITTING
.343 SINCE DURING THE A'S, .321
FOR THE YEAR, WHICH IS THE
HIGHEST IN THE MAJORS.
BUT HE CAN'T WIN A BATTING TITLE
BECAUSE HE ISN'T GOING TO BE A
QUALIFIED PLAYER WITH EITHER THE
A.L. OR THE N.L.
HE HITS .305 WITH THE MULLINS
BEFORE HE WAS TRADED BUT DIDN'T
GET TO THE PLATE APPEARANCES TO
QUALIFY.
NOW HE'S IN THE 200S, BUT HE IS
NOT GOING TO GET TO 502 BEFORE
THE SEASON IS OVER.
WE ONLY HAVE TWO WEEKS LEFT.
HE IS GOING TO END UP IN AN
INTERESTING POSITION WHERE IF HE
CONTINUES TO LEAD, HE IS GOING
TO LEAD IN BATTING AVERAGE BUT
CANNOT WIN A BATTING TITLE.
WE'VE ONLY SEEN THIS HAPPEN ONCE
BEFORE IN THE MODERN ERA WERE A
PLAYER LEAD IN BATTING AVERAGE
BUT DID IT WIN A BATTING TITLE
-- DID IT WHEN A BATTING TITLE
-- DIDN'T WIN A BATTING TITLE.
IT WAS EDDIE MURRAY.
THE WILLIE MCGEE WAS TRADED FROM
THE CARDINALS TO THE A'S,. THE
A'S
ALSO INVOLVED AT THAT POINT , HE
WAS HITTING.335 FOR THE
CARDINALS.
HE HIT .274 WHEN HE GOT TO THE
A'S AND FINISHED AT .324 FOR THE
YEAR, WHICH IS LOWER THAN EDDIE
MURRAY.
BUT AT .335 AS AN N.L. PLAYER,
HE WON THE BATTING TITLE.
YOU CAN GOOGLE NEWSPAPER
ACCOUNTS ABOUT THIS.
IT'S OFFICIAL BUT IT'S PRETTY
CRAZY WE MIGHT SEE THIS HAPPEN
AGAIN IN ANOTHER WAY.
HEIDI: THAT IS CRAZY.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT.
THANK YOU, SARAH, GOOD HISTORY
THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
SARAH: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LAUREN: SARAH ALWAYS DRIVING
THAT KNOWLEDGE ON US.
TIME FOR THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK POLL.
WHO IS GOING TO WIN TONIGHT'S
MATCHUP?
WILL IT BE THE A'S OR THE
ANGELS?
THE A'S HAVE WON 12 OF 16
AGAINST THE ANGELS HEADING INTO
THE FINAL SERIES, COLE IRVIN
FACING JONATHAN DIAZ.
I DID NOT SAY THAT DIRECTLY --
CORRECTLY, MAKING HIS MLB DEBUT.
WE'RE GOING TO STEP ASIDE,
NUMBER 74 ABOUT TO MAKE HIS
DEBUT IN THE BIGS.
WELCOMEMORE TO COME AFTER THIS.
♪
>> AND THAT ONE'S HIT DEEP TO
LEFT FIELD, ON HIS BACK, AND
THAT BABY'S GONE!
FOURTH HOME RUN FOR CHAPMAN
AGAINST DALLAS KEUCHEL IN HIS
CAREER AND THE A'S LEAD, 1-0.
>> MARTIN'S GOING BACK, SHADING
HIS EYES, AT THE WALL.
HE LEAPS, AND THAT BABY IS GONE!
YAN GOMES GETS THE A'S ON THE
BOARD.
IT'S 4-1.
>> HE LINES ONE DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE FOR A BASE HIT.
ELVIS AROUND THIRD.
HE IS GOING TO SCORE.
THEY ARE GOING TO WAVE HIM,
COMES ALL THE WAY AROUND.
HE SCORES WITHOUT A THROW.
ON A DOUBLE DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD
LINE BY MATT OLSON, AND THE HAVE
BROKEN IT OPEN.
>> DEEP TO LEFT FIELD.
AND THAT BABY IS GONE!
SO, A BOOMING HOME RUN FOR MARTE
HERE IN THE BOTTOM OF THE FIRST
INNING.
DRIVEN TO RIGHT FIELD.
GARCIA'S GOING BACK, STILL GOING
BACK.
HE TURNS AROUND AND THAT BABY IS
GONE!
>> 33 FOR MATT OLSON, GIVES HIM
96 R.B.I.'S.
>> AND A MILESTONE.
>> 500 HIT.
>> THAT'S THE WAY TO DO IT.
♪
HEIDI: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW,
PRESENTED BY TIME.
-- CHIME.
♪
>> CAN YOU TEACH ME HOW TO
DOUGIE?
WHY ARE YOU FOLLOWING ME?
STOP IT.
I TRY THE OTHER DAY.
MY TOOTH FELL OUT.
I CAN'T FLOSS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS!
>> I TOLD YOU, I WAS FLOSSING
AND IT POPPED OUT.
I GLUED IT BACK IN.
WE'RE GOOD.
HEY, SO WHAT MAKES YOU THINK IT
WAS OK TO HAVE THE SAME HERE IS
ME AND STAN JUST LIKE ME?
WHAT DID YOU SAY ABOUT TONY THE
TIGER?
I THINK HE IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS
AND ACTUALLY GETS WORK DONE,
THOUGH.
YOU GOT IT, YOU GOT IT.
UNLIKE US PITCHERS.
I DON'T WANT IT.
GET OUT OF HERE.
IF I DON'T SLICK IT BACK LIKE
THIS, MY HAT WON'T STAY ON.
I'LL GO TO COVER FIRST AND IT
WILL GO BOING, BOING, BOING,
GONE.
IT WORKS GREAT FOR CERTAIN
PEOPLE.
I'M JUST NOT CERTAIN PEOPLE.
BECAUSE IF I TRY TO THINK AND I
TRIED TO PITCH, I'M DONE.
AREN'T THEY FASTER THAN THE WIDE
RECEIVER?
NOTE!
-- NOPE!
YOU'RE EITHER GOING TO DO GOOD
OR AIN'T GOING TO DO GOOD.
HEIDI: CERTAINLY A GUY WHO
DOESN'T NEED ANY INTRODUCTION,
ONE OF THE MORE ENTERTAINING
CHARACTERS IN THE GAME OF
BASEBALL, ANDREW CHAFIN.
WHAT'S UP?
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU HAD ZERO
ISSUES TRANSITIONING TO YOUR NEW
CLUB.
ANDREW: NAH, IT'S A PRETTY GREAT
GROUP OF GUYS WE GOT HERE.
PRETTY FUN ENVIRONMENT, GO OUT
AND HAVE A GOOD TIME AND
COMPETE.
LAUREN: SPEAKING OF COMPETING,
JUST THREE GAMES BACK OF THE
WILD-CARD SPOT.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE GOING FROM THE
CUBS TO NOW BEING WITH A
CONTENDER?
ANDREW: I TRY TO TAKE EVERYTHING
ONE GAME AT A TIME, ONE PITCH AT
A TIME.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW MANY GAMES
BACK OR HOW MANY GAMES AHEAD.
I REALLY DON'T CARE.
I GOT ONE JOB TO DO AT A TIME,
AND THAT'S TO GO AND GET HITTERS
OUT.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH ALL I WORRY
ABOUT.
LAUREN: SPEAKING OF FACING SOME
REALLY TALENTED HITTERS, SHOHEI
OHTANI.
WE'RE NOT SURE IF HE'LL BE IN
THE LINEUP TONIGHT, BUT WHAT IS
IT LIKE FACING HIM?
I KNOW YOU'VE FACED HIM TWICE.
ANDREW: I SEE HIM HITTING THE
BALL REAL FAR AWAY, SO I TRY NOT
TO DO THAT WHEN I'M OUT THERE.
I TREAT HIM JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
HITTER.
LAUREN: THAT SEEMS LIKE A REALLY
SIMPLE APPROACH.
WHAT HAPPENED LAST MONTH WHEN
YOU LOST YOUR TOOTH DURING AN
OUTING?
ANDREW: LET'S SEE, NO, IT WASN'T
DURING THE OUTING.
THAT HAPPENED LIKE FOUR YEARS
AGO, THE FIRST TIME THAT TOOTH,
I NEEDED A CROWN AND THE
TEMPORARY FELL OUT AGAINST THE
DODGERS.
RIGHT BEFORE THE GAME, I WAS
SITTING THERE, FLOSSING MY
TEETH, TRYING TO GET PRETTY.
AND POP, CAME OUT AGAIN.
THEY HAD TO GET THAT FIXED.
LAUREN: WE COVER A LOT OF HOCKEY
HERE AND I CAN DEFINITELY SEE
WHAT THAT MUST HAVE BEEN LIKE
FOR YOU.
YOU PLATE THROUGH.
YOU'RE AN ABSOLUTE GAMER, SO WE
RESPECT THAT.
LET'S CIRCLE BACK TO WHEN YOU
WERE IN ARIZONA.
YOU LIVED IN AND HARVEY.
WHAT WAS THE GENESIS -- AN
HARVEY.
WHAT WAS -- RV.
WHAT WAS THE GENESIS OF HAVING A
HOUSE ON WILL -- ON WHEELS?
ANDREW: I HATE RENTING.
A CAMPER WILL DO THE JOB.
LAUREN: I RESPECT THAT.
WHAT WAS THE MOST MEMORABLE PART
OF LIVING IN A CAMPER?
ANDREW: I GOT HOOKED UP WITH THE
GENTLEMAN WHO HAD AN ARABIAN
HORSE FARM IN SCOTTSDALE.
I WAS ABLE TO STAY ON THE FARM
AND KEEP MY HORSEBACK SO I COULD
GO OUT THE DOOR AND JUMP ON MY
HORSE AND RIDE AROUND.
LAUREN: THAT'S AWESOME.
I GREW UP RIDING HORSES.
WHAT KIND OF FORCES DO YOU HAVE?
ANDREW: QUARTER HORSES.
I ACTUALLY ENDED UP SELLING THEM
THIS YEAR.
WE'LL BE GETTING BACK TO THE
QUARTER HORSES ONCE MY GIRLS ARE
BIG ENOUGH TO START RIDING.
LAUREN: THAT'S COOL.
ARE THEY GOING TO BARREL RACE?
ANDREW: NO, THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO BARREL RACE.
LAUREN: I GREW UP DOING THAT.
IT'S VERY DANGEROUS.
IF YOU WATCH "YELLOWSTONE," DADS
ARE NOT GOING TO LET THEIR
DODGERS -- DAUGHTERS BARREL RACE
AT ALL.
WHO WORE IT BETTER, YOU OR
ROLLIE FINGERS?
ANDREW: ROLLIE FINGERS.
DUDE'S GOT MORE RESPECT THAN
I'LL EVER HAVE.
LAUREN: THE MOP OR THE MUSTACHE?
ANDREW: PROBABLY THE MOP JUST
BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER HAS THE
SAME HAIR AND I THINK IT'S
ADORABLE.
LAUREN: HOW OLD IS SHE?
ANDREW: A LITTLE OVER THREE NOW.
LAUREN: ESPECIALLY WITH THE
CARDINALS.
I'M A SUCKER FOR THAT.
LET'S CIRCLE BACK TO HARRY
POTTER FAN.
WHICH HOUSE DO YOU IDENTIFY
WITH?
ANDREW: I MEAN, PROBABLY CLICHÉ,
BUT PROBABLY GRYFFINDOR, I
SUPPOSE.
I LIKE HELPING PEOPLE.
I FIGURE I WOULD BE A FAIR FIT
THERE.
LAUREN: YOU WOULD BE A REAL FAIR
FIT, AND PLAY SOME QUIDDITCH.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
CAN YOU MAKE THE CASE FOR THE
OAKLAND A'S TO MAKE IT TO THE
POSTSEASON?
ANDREW: MAKE THE CASE?
I'M NOT EVEN SURE WHAT YOU MEAN.
I'M JUST WORRYING ABOUT
TONIGHT'S GAME AND WE'LL GO FROM
THERE.
IS THAT WHAT WE'RE ASKING?
TRY TO WIN THEM ALL.
LAUREN: WE WERE IN LOCKSTEP
THERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND HAVE
A GREAT GAME TONIGHT.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
ANDREW: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
♪
HEIDI: IT IS TIME NOW FOR THE
CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME IN ASHLEY
SANDERS.
YOU CAN CHECK OUT HER YOUTUBE
CHANNEL,_ASHLEY_SANDERS,
SHOWCASING DIAMOND DYNASTY IN
"MLB THE SHOW."
WELCOME, ASHLEY.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR CHANNEL AND
THE TYPE OF CONTENT PEOPLE CAN
EXPECT TO SEE.
ASHLEY: ABSOLUTELY, I'M DOING
WELL.
WE ARE ALL ABOUT MLB THE SHOW
FROM REAL BASEBALL TO VIRTUAL
REALITY BASEBALL.
WE BRING IN A LOW-KEY ATMOSPHERE
AND COMPETITIVE ATMOSPHERE
COVERING ALL THE BASES IN TERMS
OF WHAT CAN HAPPEN IN A
VIDEOGAME ATMOSPHERE, AND
RELATING THAT TO THE BASEBALL WE
SEE ON A DAY-TO-DAY BASIS.
HEIDI: OH, THAT'S AWESOME AND I
AM PARTIAL TO THAT BITTER GAME.
IT'S A PRETTY SWEET VIDEOGAME.
DO YOU THINK THAT THEY HAVE A
RUN IN THEM TO MAKE THE
POSTSEASON?
ASHLEY: HONESTLY, I THINK THAT
THEY DO, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THEY
STILL HAVE TWO SERIES AGAINST
HOUSTON.
THEY COULD TAKE OVER THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE WEST.
BUT WITH THAT WILD-CARD, THE A'S
HAPPENED TO GET HOT VERY LATE IN
THE SEASON.
WE SEE THAT HISTORICALLY AND I
WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF THEY
GET HOT AND TURN ON THE JETS AND
PUSH FOR THE SPOTS.
HEIDI: GREAT STUFF, ASHLEY.
IF THE A'S ARE GOING TO MAKE UP
ANY GROUND IN THE WILD-CARD
RACE, THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
KEEP SHOHEI OHTANI QUIET AT THE
PLATE.
IS HE YOUR FAVORITE FOR THE A.L.
M.V.P. AWARD?
OR WOULD YOU GO WITH VLADDY OR
SOMEONE ELSE?
ASHLEY: SHOHEI OHTANI IS
ABSOLUTELY THE FAVORITE.
I LIKE TO THINK OF HIM AS DOING
EVERYTHING THAT VLAD JR. IS
DOING, BUT ALSO PITCHING.
HAVING THAT DUALITY, SOMETHING
WE HAVE LITERALLY NOT SEEN SINCE
BABE RUTH, AND HE'S DOING IT
BETTER THAN BABE RUTH.
HE'S HANDS OUT MY FAVORITE TO
WIN THE M.V.P. FOR THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE.
HEIDI: HE IS FUN TO WATCH.
YOUR FAVORITE TEAM IS THE WHITE
SOX.
THEY ARE RUNNING AWAY WITH THE
A.L. CENTRAL.
WHICH TEAM POSES THE BIGGEST
THREAT TO THE WHITE SOX IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE?
ASHLEY: I WOULD SAY IT'S A TEAM
ON THE CUSP OF THE WILD-CARD,
WHICH IS THE NEW YORK YANKEES.
THE WHITE SOX DID NOT DO GOOD
AGAINST THEM IN THE REGULAR
SEASON, AND THE YANKEES ARE
BATTLING WITH THE BLUE JAYS FOR
THE WILD-CARD SPOT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE YANKEES
MISSED THE WILD-CARD, THOUGH
THERE'S STILL TIME LEFT IN THE
SEASON FOR THEM TO SNEAK IN AND
FACE THE WHITE SOX.
HEIDI: IF YOU WANT TO BE THE
BEST, YOU'VE GOT TO BE TO THE
BEST.
LAST QUESTION, I WANT TO KNOW
YOUR WORLD SERIES MATCHUP
PRODUCTION AND WHO YOU THINK IS
GOING TO WIN.
ASHLEY: I'M GOING TO BE A LITTLE
BIASED, BUT I OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO
ROOT FOR THE WHITE SOX FOR THAT
AMERICAN LEAGUE CONTENDING TEAM.
HOWEVER, I HAVE TO GO WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS.
THEY HAVE BEEN PEDDLED TO THE
METAL ALL THROUGHOUT THE SEASON,
SO I'M DEFINITELY SAYING THE
WHITE SOX AND GIANTS.
HOWEVER, OF COURSE, I HAVE TO
ROOT FOR THE WHITE SOX.
I HAVE THEM WINNING IN SIX GAMES
IN THE WORLD SERIES IF IT GOES
THAT FAR.
HEIDI: WHITE SOX IN 6, 2005 ALL
OVER AGAIN.
I GREW UP SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS
FAN, SO I WOULDN'T MIND SEEING
THAT SAN FRANCISCO -- WORLD
SERIES MATCHUP EITHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ASHLEY: YES, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LAUREN: AND ASHLEY, OF COURSE OF
FAN OF OUR OWN HEIDI, WHO IS A
STAR ON "MLB THE SHOW."
SECOND BASEMAN DAVID FLETCHER,
GETTING HIS STRETCH ON, READY
FOR THE FIRST OF A THREE-GAME
SET AT ANGEL STADIUM, A CHANCE
FOR THE A'S TO MAKE UP SOME
GROUND, BATTLING FOR THEIR
PLAYOFF LIVES.
MORE♪
>> SWINGS AND LINES A BASE HIT
OUT OF THE REACH OF CRONENWORTH.
THAT'S GOING TO SCORE ONE.
THAT'S GOING TO SCORE TWO.
AND JO ADELL BREAKS UP THE
NO-HITTER AND THE ANGELS HAVE A
2-0 LEAD.
>> RENGIFO, ON TOP OF PEPCO
PORCH!
SOLO SHOT, 3-0 HALOS.
>> HALO FANS LOVING THIS AT
PETCO PARK, LUIS RENGIFO.
>> DOWN TO RIGHT FIELD AND WELL
HIT,'AND THAT ONES GOING TO GO!
A PAIR OF TWO RUN IN THE SEVENTH
AND THE EIGHTH, AND HASN'T THIS
GOTTEN INTERESTING?
>> 2-0 TO RENGIFO.
SWINGS AT THAT ONE AND HITS IT
WELL, AND OUT OF HERE!
HOME RUN FOR WHEN HE FELT. --
RENGIFO.
THAT IS NUMBER FOUR ON THE
SEASON.
>> HERE IS OHTANI NOW.
3-2 FASTBALL LINED TO RIGHT AND
DEEP, AND GONE!
LIKE A BULLET, 44 IN THE BLINK
OF AN EYE!
>> THIRD HOME RUN FOR SHOHEI
OHTANI AS A STARTING PITCHER.
♪
HEIDI: AND WELCOME BACK TO THE
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME
SHOW, PRESENTED BY TIME. --
CHIME.
ALL RIGHT, IT IS TIME NOW FOR
THE PICKS TO CLICK, PRESENTED BY
FANDUEL SPORTSBOOK.
OUR FIRST PICK, OVER/UNDER NINE
TOTALS -- TOTAL RUNS IN
TONIGHT'S GAME.
LAUREN: NORMALLY, I WOULD BE
TEMPTED TO TAKE THE UNDER,
ESPECIALLY IF SHOWTIME WERE ON
THE MOUND, JHONATHAN DIAZ MAKING
HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT.
YOU CAN LOOK AT HIS MINOR LEAGUE
NUMBERS, BUT YOU ARE NOT FACING
MINOR LEAGUE LINEUPS, SO I'M
TAKING THE OVER ON THIS ONE.
CHECK THIS OUT.
THE A'S TEAM E.R.A. IN
SEPTEMBER, 6.69.
HEIDI: NOT IDEAL.
LAUREN: NOT IDEAL.
I'M TAKING THE OVER ON THIS ONE.
HEIDI: MY INCLINATION WAS TO
TAKE THE OVER.
I THINK THESE TWO TEAMS SCORE A
LOT OF RUNS.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY PREVENT A
BUT SEEING A ROOKIE ON THE
MOUND, THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT HIM YET, SO
SOMETIMES ROOKIES CAN COME OUT
AND JUST DEAL AND HAVE A GREAT
OUTING.
AND COLE IRVIN, HE IS PINCHING
IN FRONT PITCHED -- PITCHING IN
FRONT OF HIS HOMETOWN FAMILY AND
FRIENDS.
SO THAT MIGHT YIELD TO THE
UNDER.
I'LL TAKE THE UNDER SINCE YOU
TOOK THE OVER.
LAUREN: A LITTLE EXTRA JUICE.
CIRCLING BACK TO SHOWTIME,
BECAUSE ALL ROADS LEAD TO SHOHEI
OHTANI.
WILL SHOHEI OHTANI HIT A HOME
RUN TONIGHT?
+270.
HEIDI: NOT BAD, NOT BET.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH YES, HE IS
DUE.
I WOULD ALWAYS GO WITH YES,
SHOHEI OHTANI IS GOING TO HIT A
HOME RUN.
HE HAS HIT QUITE A FEW OF THEM
THIS SEASON.
BUT HE STRUGGLED A LITTLE BIT
LATELY.
HE'S ALSO 4-12 WITH TWO DOUBLES
AND A HOME RUN IN HIS CAREER
AGAINST COLE IRVIN.
SO YES, SHOHEI OHTANI IS GOING
DEEP.
LAUREN: HE HAS HIT SEVEN HOME
RUNS IN HIS LAST 41 GAMES, SINCE
THE ALL-STAR BREAK.
KUDOS FOR PUTTING HIMSELF OUT
THERE IN DENVER.
HE ENTERED HIMSELF IN THE HOME
RUN DERBY.
HE SAID HE WOULD DO IT.
HE SAID HE WOULD DO IT FOR THE
FANS.
I FEEL LIKE HE WAS SO SHARP ON
BOTH SIDES.
HE IS TO SOFTEN A LITTLE BIT.
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
YOU TOOK THE OVER.
I'LL TAKE THE UNDER.
HEIDI: ALL RIGHT.
WILL STARLING MARTE RECORD TWO
OR MORE HITS?
LAUREN: THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
SINCE THE ACQUISITION AT THE
TRADE DEADLINE, HE HAS BEEN ON
FIRE, ONE OF THE BEST HITTERS
NOT ONLY IN BASEBALL --
OBVIOUSLY IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE, AS WELL.
HE HAS HAD MULTI-HIT GAMES, A
CONVERSION RATE OF 43%.
SO IF I HAD MY DRUTHERS RIGHT
NOW, GOING UP AGAINST AN UNKNOWN
ON THE MOUND, I'M TAKING THE
OVER.
HEIDI: HE LEADS THE MLB AND HITS
WITH 61, SO I'M GOING WITH A
YES, AS WELL.
LG ASKED YOU A POLL QUESTION IN
THE SHOW.
WHO IS GOING TO WIN THIS GAME?
67% OF YOU ARE GOING WITH THE
A'S MAKING THAT PLAYOFF PUSH
AGAINST THE HALOS.
HALOS JUST CAME OFF A GOOD
SERIES WITH THE WHITE SOX.
HOW ABOUT SOME STARTING LINEUPS
FOR YOU?
ACTUALLY WE'RE GOING TO GET YOU
RIGHT OUT TO THE GAME HERE.
IT'S GOING TO BE SCOTT BRAUN,
TOM VERDUCCI, AND BRETT DOLAN ON
THE CALL AS THE A'S ARE GETTING
SET TO TAKE ON THE ANGELS IN
ANAHEIM.
LG, DO YOU AGREE WITH THE
POLL?
LAUREN: I AGREE.
I AM SURPRISED AT HOW CLOSE IT
WAS.
I KNOW THEY HAVE HAD TOUGH
BUT THE A'S HAVE OWNED
THE HEY HAAN THIS SEASON, SO A
LITTLE SURPRISED.
HEIDI:HEY , BUT THE A'SANGELSHAS
GAME
ALL RIGHT, ENJOY IT.
♪
>> HERE'S THE PITCH.
>> DRIVES IT DEEP!
>> WHAT A PLAY!
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
OH, MY!
♪
SCOTT: THESE BEACHES, THIS
WEATHER, WHAT'S NOT TO LIKE?
PLUS, THE MOST TALENTED BASEBALL
ON THE PLANET RESIDES HERE.
AND TONIGHT, THE ENTIRE WORLD IS
WATCHING.
THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE, PRESENTED BY
CHIME.
FRIDAY NIGHT AT ANGEL STADIUM IN
CALIFORNIA TO CRACK OPEN A
THREE-GAME SET.
AND THE BEST ACTION IN THE A.L.
POSTSEASON PICTURE IS IN THE
WILD-CARD WITH THE BLUE JAYS AND
THE RED SOX CURRENTLY HOLDING
THOSE PRECIOUS TWO SEATS ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF YOUR SCREEN.
YANKEES BARELY BEHIND, THEN
THERE'S OAKLAND AND SEATTLE.
THOSE CLUBS HAVE SERIOUS WORK TO
DO.
THE A'S NEED TO AT LEAST WIN
THIS SERIES, IF NOT SWEEP TO
STAY IN THIS CONVERSATION.
SCOTT BRAUN ALONG WITH TOM
VERDUCCI.
HELLO TO THE WORLD AUDIENCE.
SHOHEI OHTANI IS IN THE LINEUP.
HE'S THE D.H. AND HE CAN DO IT
ALL.
TOM: IT'S BEEN A GREAT YEAR IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THE GIANTS HAVE BEEN ON FIRE,
BUT SHOHEI OHTANI IS THE STORY.
ON THE MOUND, VERY FEW PITCHERS
AS TOUGH TO HIT AS SHOHEI
OHTANI.
IN THE BATTER'S BOX, HOW ABOUT
THIS?
74 EXTRA-BASE HITS IS SECOND IN
THE ENTIRE MAJOR LEAGUES.
THAT'S NOT ALL HE CAN DO.
THIS GUY'S GOT TREMENDOUS SPEED
ON THE BASES, 23 STOLEN BASES
THIS YEAR.
HE CAN DO IT ALL.
SHOHEI OHTANI ACTUALLY MADE THE
TIME MAGAZINE LIST OF THE 100
MOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD.
HE'S THAT GOOD.
AND NOT JUST THIS YEAR, FOLKS.
SHOHEI OHTANI HAS MORE HOME RUNS
AND MORE STRIKEOUTS THAN ANY
PLAYER THAT HAS WORN AN ANGELS
UNIFORM.
SO MANY SUPERLATIVES.
ANY GAME WITH SHOHEI OHTANI IS
MUST SEE TV.
SCOTT: STILL THE FRONT RUNNER
FOR M.V.P.
TOM: ABSOLUTELY.
SCOTT: JUST CHECKING.
THE OAKLAND A'S DON'T HAVE
OHTANI, BUT THEY HAVE THE MATT'S
ON THE CORNERS.
THIS TEAM, THOUGH, RIDING A WAVE
OF UP AND DOWNS.
IT STARTED REALLY SHINY.
DID WE SHOOT THIS TODAY?
OAKLAND WAS THE BEST TEAM IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE THROUGH JUNE 18,
44-27.
THEY HAVE BEEN SUB-.500 SINCE
THAT TIME PERIOD, FIVE GAMES
UNDER.
THE BULLPEN HAS HAD ITS
STRUGGLES LATELY.
WHEN THEY'RE PLAYING AGAINST
BETTER COMPETITION, IT'S NOT
WORKING OUT AND THEY HAVE NOT
MISSED THE POSTSEASON SINCE
2017.
THAT IS ON THE LINE AT THE
MOMENT.
WHAT DO THEY DO?
LET'S BRING IN REINFORCEMENTS TO
SAVE THE DAY.
THAT'S LEAD BY THE ELECTRIC
STARLING MARTE.
TOM: EVERYTHING YOU WANT IN A
TRADE DEADLINE PICKUP, A GUY
PLAYING WELL FOR MIAMI, PLAYING
EVEN BETTER FOR THE OAKLAND A'S.
ONE OF THE MOST DYNAMIC
OFFENSIVE PLAYERS IN THE GAME.
HE'S GOT MORE THAN 20 STOLEN
BASES IN EACH LEAGUE THIS YEAR.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT BEING DYNAMIC
ON THE BASES, GETTING ON BASE,
AND YOU SEE THAT A'S UNIFORM,
WHO DO YOU THINK OF?
YOU THINK OF RICKEY HENDERSON.
WELL, STARLING MARTE MIGHT BE
JOINING SELECT COMPANY, WHICH
INCLUDES RICKEY HENDERSON.
IN THE PAST 30 YEARS, THE ONLY
PLAYERS TO GET ON BASE 40% OF
THE TIME AND STEAL 50 BASES,
STARLING MARTE HAS A CHANCE TO
JOIN THE ELITE COMPANY, HASN'T
BEEN DONE IN TWO DECADES.
THAT'S HOW SPECIAL HE'S BEEN
THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: THEY REALLY NEEDED HIM IN
THE SECOND HALF OF THE YEAR.
THIS IS A COMPETITIVE RACE SO IT
IS THAT TIME OF YEAR, SCOREBOARD
WATCHING.
LET'S BRING IN BRETT DOLAN FOR
MORE ON THE OAKLAND A'S FINISH
LINE, BRETT.
BRETT: THANK YOU.
BACK ON WEDNESDAY, OAKLAND
OUTLASTED KANSAS CITY, 12-10.
THE NIGHT BEFORE, THEY BLEW A
SIX RUN LEAD.
BOB MELVIN TOOK OFF HIS HAT FOR
THE MEETING.
ALL BROWN HAIR, NO GRAY HAIRS.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HIS SECRET.
HE WOULD PROBABLY LIKE TO KNOW
HIS SECRET OF GETTING BETTER
PITCHING.
HIS TEAM, THEY HAVE THE WORST
EARNED RUN AVERAGE IN BASEBALL,
EVEN BEYOND BALTIMORE.
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO CHANGE
AS THEY GO DOWN THE STRETCH.
THEY HAVE BEEN IN A POSTSEASON
SPOT FOR THE BULK OF THE YEAR,
NO LONGER CHASING THAT WILD-CARD
BERTH.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS
AHEAD FOR OAKLAND.
AFTER THE SERIOUS, THEY WILL GO
HOME FOR FOUR GAMES AGAINST
SEATTLE, THEN THREE AGAINST
HOUSTON.
THEY WILL FACE THOSE SAME TWO
TEAMS ON THE ROAD.
THEY'LL HAVE TO PLAY BETTER, 4-8
THIS YEAR AGAINST SEATTLE, 4-9
AGAINST THE HOUSTON ASTROS.
THEY WILL HAVE TO PLAY BETTER
THIS ENTIRE MONTH TO MAKE THAT
PUSHED TO THE POSTSEASON AND THE
SECOND WILD-CARD BERTH.
BEAUTIFUL NIGHT FOR BASEBALL
HERE IN ANAHEIM, EVER YOUTUBE
GAME OF THE WEEK.
THE ANGELS, THE ATHLETICS, OUR
STARTING LINEUPS, OUR FIRST
PITCH ALL AHEAD COMING UP ON
YOUTUBE.
♪
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE A BASE
HIT, LEFT CENTER FIELD.
READ ALL THE WAY BY ELVIS
ANDRUS.
HE SCORES.
A'S GET A RUN.
IT'S 3-1.
KINER-FALEFA AGAIN HAS TO MOVE.
BACKHAND THROW TO FIRST, IT'S A
LITTLE OFF-LINE.
>> AND HERE IT IS TO MATT.
HE LINES IT DOWN FOR A BASE HIT.
THAT WILL SCORE MURPHY.
ELVIS AROUND THIRD, HE WILL
SCORE.
MARTE STREAKING TO THIRD.
COMES ALL THE WAY AROUND, HE
SCORES WITHOUT A THROW.
>> AND THAT ONE IS SMOKED TO
CENTER, AND THAT'S A BASE HIT.
TROTTING INTO SCORE IS MARTE AND
IT'S 8-5.
-- 8-4.
IT'S ONLY THE FOURTH INNING.
DRIVEN TO RIGHT FIELD.
GARCIA IS GOING BACK, STILL
GOING BACK.
HE TURNS AROUND AND THAT BABY IS
GONE!
>> 33 FOR MATT OLSON.
>> OLSON HITS ONE DEEP TO RIGHT
FIELD.
AND THAT BABY IS GONE!
>> YOU KNOW HOW THE STORY GOES,
FASTBALLS AND REAL ESTATE.
LOCATION, LOCATION, LOCATION,
AND MATT OLSON JUST PAYS
STRAIGHT CASH FOR A PAD OUT IN
RIGHT FIELD.
♪
SCOTT: BACK AT ANGEL STADIUM,
SCOTT BRAUN ALONG WITH TOM
VERDUCCI, AND THE GAME WE SHARE
ON OUR YOUTUBE CHANNEL ARE FREE
FOR EVERYONE, YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
OUR LATEST FEATURE PUTS THE
AUDIO IN YOUR HANDS AND WE HAVE
SOMETHING SPECIAL FOR YOU
TONIGHT.
WE'RE EXCITED TO BE PROVIDING
AUDIO WITH JAPANESE LANGUAGE
COMMENTARY AS AN OPTION FOR YOU
AS YOU TOGGLE TO HOME AUDIO AS
WE GET STARTED.
WE ARE UNDERWAY LIVE ON YOUTUBE
TO A GLOBAL AUDIENCE, AND THAT
IS JHONATHAN DIAZ ON THE MOUND,
MAKING HIS MLB DEBUT.
FIRST PITCH IS FOULED OFF BY
JOSH HARRISON, WHO HAS BEEN ON A
ROLL LATELY.
SWING AND A MISS, TOP OF THE
ZONE, SO WE ARE ALL LEARNING
JHONATHAN DIAZ TOGETHER.
TOM: THAT INCLUDES THE OAKLAND
A'S.
THEY FOUND OUT AT 10:00 IN THE
MORNING THAT DIAZ WAS PITCHING
AND WENT INTO SCRAMBLE MODE TO
FIND INFO ON THE LEFTY.
SCOTT: OOH.
AND THAT HIT HARRISON.
HE IS GOING TO SHUFFLE TO FIRST
BASE LIKE ONLY HE CAN.
A'S HAVE BEEN HIT BY A PITCH
MORE THIS SEASON THAN ANY OTHER
YEAR IN FRANCHISE HISTORY.
SO THEY'RE USED TO THIS.
TOM: AS ARE MOST TEAMS.
THE MOST DANGEROUS TIME IN
BASEBALL HISTORY TO BE A HITTER.
THE HBP RATE IS AT THE GREATEST
LEVEL.
SCOTT: LITTLE TOE TAP THERE.
IF ANYTHING, THAT SHOWS YOU I'M
GOOD, RIGHT?
WHEN YOU DO THAT HIGH STEP OVER
TO FIRST?
TOM: HE'S PLAYING SHORTSTOP
BECAUSE ELVIS ANDRUS IS NOT IN
THE LINEUP AFTER HE GOT HIT BY A
PITCH IN THE ANKLE AND KANSAS
CITY YESTERDAY.
SHOULD BE OK, JUST NOT IN THE
STARTING LINEUP TONIGHT.
SCOTT: NOW IT'S MARTE, FIRST
PITCH FOULED OFF.
THREE A'S WERE HIT BY A PITCH IN
YESTERDAY'S WIN.
SO DIAZ IS 25 YEARS OLD, GOING
UP AGAINST MARTE, WHO'S BEEN
STAND OUT IN THE SECOND HALF OF
THE YEAR.
MISSES LOW.
NOW, THERE WAS A SLIGHT CHANCE
THIS WOULD BE SHOHEI OHTANI.
ALEX COBB RETURN FROM THE I.L.
YESTERDAY AND GAVE HIS TEAM FIVE
SHUTOUT INNINGS.
I'D ACTUALLY JUST BEEN TOLD, A
TEXT, THAT HE SHOULD BE PITCHING
ON SUNDAY.
FRIEND ROGER LODGE, WHO DOES THE
PREGAME ON ANGELS RADIO.
THANK YOU, ROG.
MARTE CONNECTS, CENTER FIELD,
GETS UNDER IT.
BRANDON MARSH DOESN'T HAVE TO
MOVE.
AND HE MAKES THE GRAB.
ONE DOWN, AND. MATT OLSON IS
COMING UP
LET'S INTRODUCE YOU TO THE
VISITING STARTING NINE,
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
AFTER HARASSING, STARTING MARTE,
MATT OLSON.
MATT CHAPMAN IS BACK IN THE
LINEUP.
YAN GOMES, KHRIS DAVIS, AND TONY
KEMP TO RUN OUT THE STARTING
NINE.
TOM: YOU'RE GETTING THE CLIFF
NOTES VERSION.
OF DIAZ HE'S AROUND THE PLATE.
HE IS EMPHASIZING STRIKE
THROWER'S.
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF PICTURES
HE WANTS.
DIAZ HAS BEEN THAT IN HIS MINOR
LEAGUE CAREER, CAME UP IN THE
RED SOX ORGANIZATION.
HARRISON AND MARTE VERY QUICK TO
PULL THE TRIGGER RATHER THAN
WAITING TO SEE WHAT HE'S GOT,
SWING MODE RIGHT AWAY.
SCOTT: OLSON TOOK THE PITCH,
TAKES ANOTHER.
WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU'RE
PREPPING FOR A PITCHER THAT
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN IN A WORLD
THAT IS DOMINATED BY VIDEO AND
ADVANCED SCOUTING REPORTS?
TOM: YOU GO TO YOUTUBE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO, SCOTT.
REALLY.
SCOTT: THAT'S WHAT WE DID.
TOM: THERE'S A LOT OF MINOR
LEAGUE VIDEO THAT'S OUT THERE.
EVEN AS DOUBLE-A STARTS, HE ONLY
HAD THREE AT TRIPLE-A.
YOU GET A SENSE OF HOW HE
ATTACKS HITTERS.
MATT OLSON, HOW HE ATTACKS
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS.
LOOKS LIKE DIAZ IS MORE
EFFECTIVE AGAINST LEFT-HANDED
HITTERS, HAS A BIT OF A
CROSSFIRE SET UP IN HIS ARM
ACTION.
SCOTT: ANOTHER MISSED TO OLSON,
WHO HAS THE THIRD-BEST O.P.S. IN
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE THIS YEAR.
HE'S THE BEST PLAYER ON THE TEAM
IN 2021 FOR THE FULL SEASON.
AND HE WALKS.
TWO OF THE FIRST THREE A'S GET A
FREE PASS.
TOM: LET'S DIVE IN HERE ON DIAZ.
HIDE AND SEEK.
I LIKE THE WAY HE HIDES THE
BALL.
HIS ARM STAYS BEHIND HIM SO
HITTERS DON'T SEE THE BALL UNTIL
BASICALLY HE GETS TO RELEASE
POINT.
PLUS 10 DIFFERENTIAL, THAT
SHOULD BE HIS MILE PER HOUR
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE FASTBALL
AND THE CHANGEUP.
REALLY GOOD CHANGEUP, NOT A HIGH
VELOCITY FASTBALL.
FIRST IMPRESSION, YOUR FIRST
BIG-LEAGUE GAME, STARTING
AGAINST THE A'S.
IT'S ABOUT NOT JUST CONTROLLING
YOUR EMOTIONS, SCOOT, BECAUSE
THAT GETS A BAD RAP, BUT USING
YOUR EMOTIONS.
YOU SHOULD BE EXCITED OUT THERE.
CHANNEL THEM IN A POSITIVE
DIRECTION.
THERE'S A CHANGEUP AT 80.
SCOTT: SO NOW IT'S CANHA, A
CAREER-HIGH 80 RUNS SCORED,
ON-BASE 36% OF THE TIME.
AND THERE'S A STRIKE FROM DIAZ.
OAKLAND'S AT 79-67 ON THE YEAR,
ENTERING THE DAY THREE GAMES OUT
OF THE WILD-CARD.
BRETT WENT OVER THE SCHEDULE THE
REST OF THE WAY FOR THE A'S.
YOU LOOK AT THIS SERIES, LIKE I
SAID EARLIER, YOU PROBABLY NEED
TO WIN, IF NOT SWEET, BECAUSE
THE TEAMS -- SWEEP, BECAUSE THE
TEAMS AHEAD OF YOU NOT ONLY HAVE
AN ADVANTAGE, BUT THEY'RE REALLY
GOOD.
YOU ONLY HAVE TWO WEEKS TO GO.
TOM: I WOULD SAY 91.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET TO 91 WINS.
FOR THE OAKLAND A'S, THAT'S A
12-4 FINISH.
AND EVEN THEN, YOU'RE GOING TO
NEED SOME HELP BECAUSE OF THE
TEAMS AHEAD OF YOU.
SCOTT: SO YOU'RE SAYING 12-4,
AND IF YOU'RE THE A'S, YOU'RE
HOME FOR SEVEN, FOUR AGAINST
SEATTLE, THREE AGAINST HOUSTON,
BEST TEAM IN THE DIVISION, AND
THREE MORE AGAINST THE MARINERS.
12 MORE AGAINST THAT GROUP?
NOT EASY.
TOM: THAT'S WHY IT'S A CLICHÉ,
BUT YOU REALLY DO HAVE TO LOCK
IN ON THE GAME RIGHT IN FRONT OF
YOU.
THAT SHOULD BE EASY TO FOCUS IN
AND NOT LOOK AHEAD.
SCOTT: OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS
WEIGHING IN ON THE LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY SECTION.
END OF THE SEASON LOOKING LIKE A
LOT OF FUN.
TRUE.
WILD-CARDS, SPECIFICALLY.
THAT'S FOR THE PARTY'S AT.
TOM: I WANT TO SEE IF HE STARTS
THE RUNNER HERE.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE DIAZ HAS SWING
AND MISS STUFF.
THAT WOULD BE THE AGGRESSIVE
PLAY.
SCOTT: NOT MOVING.
BALL FOUR.
A LITTLE CHAT AFTER THREE OF THE
FIRST FOUR OAKLAND BATTER'S BOX.
TOM: GOOD TIME OUT HERE, AGAIN
ABOUT CONTROLLING THE EMOTIONS.
OK TO BE EXCITED, SHOULD BE, BUT
DON'T LET IT GET AWAY FROM YOU.
IF YOU'RE OAKLAND, HE IS NOT
GOING TO BEAT YOU WITH THE
FASTBALL.
SO IS GOING TO HAVE TO LAND
THOSE SECONDARY PITCHES, THE
SLIDER AND CHANGEUP, AND HAVE
OAKLAND HONOR THOSE PITCHES.
SCOTT: HE HAS THE ABILITY, PITCH
COUNT-WISE, TO GIVE THIS TEAM 5,
6 INNINGS.
HERE'S JOE MADDON, THIRD SEASON
IN CHARGE OF THE HALOS.
HE TOLD US THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
A BULLPEN GAME, BUT THIS IS A
STARTER WHO, IF THINGS FAREWELL,
COULD GIVE US A REGULAR NIGHT.
FIRST PITCHER SWING AND MISS
FROM PENDER, THINKING BIG.
TOM: I LIKE THE APPROACH BECAUSE
HE IS SITTING FIRST PITCH
FASTBALL, BUT DIAZ DID LAND THAT
CURVEBALL AND I THINK THE
BACKSWING MIGHT HAVE GOT A PIECE
OF SUZUKI THERE.
I BET THAT'LL MAKE AN IMPRESSION
FOR DIAZ TO LEND THAT FIRST
PITCH BREAKING BALL WITH THE
BASES LOADED.
SCOTT: HARRISON, OLSON, AND
CANHA ON BOARD.
AND PINDER HAS TWO STRIKES
AGAINST HIM.
CHAD'S 8 FOR HIS LAST 21.
THAT'S OVER A SEVEN-GAME SPAN.
HE HAS A MUCH BETTER BAT AGAINST
SOUTHPAWS.
HE'S FACING ONE NOW, LOOKING HIS
CHOPS.
STRIKE HIM OUT, DIAZ GETS THE
CHASE.
TOM: YOU KNOW EARLY ON, HE'S
COMING UP TO THE MINOR LEAGUE
SYSTEM, THE SLIDER WASN'T RATED
AS HEAVILY AS IT SHOULD.
THAT'S A CLASSIC TWO STRIKE,
BACK FOOT SLIDER THAT KEEPS
WORKING UNDER THE BARREL OF
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS BAT.
GREAT LOCATION.
SCOTT: THAT WAS WHAT STOOD OUT
TO ME WHEN I PEEKED OVER AT YOUR
COMPUTER SCREEN.
WHAT'S THIS GUY LOOK LIKE?
THE SLIDER HAS SERIOUS BITE TO
IT.
TOM: IT WORKS IN THE BIG LEAGUES
AS WELL AS DOUBLE-A WHEN YOU CAN
LAND IT ON THE BACK FOOT.
SCOTT: AND NONE OF THESE HITTERS
HAVE SEEN IT, MATT CHAPMAN BACK
IN THE LINEUP FIRST TIME SINCE
SATURDAY.
HE LEFT THAT GAME AFTER HE
FOULED A BALL OFF HIS LEFT SHIN.
APPARENTLY, THAT'S HAPPENED
QUITE A FEW TIMES THIS SEASON.
MANAGER BOB MELVIN SAID THERE
WERE A COUPLE OF SPOTS MAKING
HIS FOOT LOCK UP.
SO HE MISSED SUNDAY ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THURSDAY, AND NOW THEY
HAVE THEIR MAN BACK AT THIRD
BASE.
CHECKED.
AND HTAT'S A STRIKE.
IT'S 1-1.
BASES LOADED, ONE OUT.
NOW THERE'S TWO.
THERE HE GOES.
TOM: THAT'S A SWING.
THAT'S A GREAT PITCH LOCATION
FOR DIAZ BECAUSE THAT CAN OPEN
UP THE INSIDE OF THE PLATE FOR
THE SLIDER.
YOU KNOW, HE TRIED TO GO IN WITH
THAT, BUT BECAUSE SUZUKI HAD TO
REACH BACK OVER THE PLATE, HE
DIDN'T GET THE CALL.
IT'S ACTUALLY A GOOD PITCH, BUT
HE WANTS IT DOWN AND IN, SO HE
UNINTENTIONALLY BACK TOWARD IT
-- BACKDOORED IT.
SCOTT: THAT SWINGS THE COUNT IN
A BIG WAY.
I KNOW IT'S THE OPENING FRAME,
BUT PRESSURE A.B. FOR CHAPMAN,
NOW 3-1.
BASES LOADED, ONE OUT, FIGHTING
FOR A PLAYOFF SPOT, GOING UP
AGAINST ROOKIES, YOU NEED TO
CONVERT.
TOM: HIT BY TWO WALKS, MAJOR
LEAGUE DEBUT ON THE MOUND, IN
CONTROL ON THE COUNT.
JUST HAVE TO SIT ON FASTBALL
HERE, KEEP THE STRIKE ZONE
DISCIPLINED.
SCOTT: AND THERE IS A STRIKE TO
LOAD UP THE COUNT.
TOM: THAT'S A GOOD TAKE.
YOU''R NOT GOING TO -- YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO CHASE BECAUSE
YOU'RE SITTING FASTBALL.
IF YOU'RE MATT CHAPMAN, YOU'RE
JUST INTO STRIKE MODE -- IN TW
O STRIKE MODE.
SCOTT: PAYOFF WITH THE RUNNERS
MOVING, HE GOT HIM!
BRAVO TOP HALF OF THE FIRST FROM
JHONATHAN DIAZ, MAKING HIS MLB
DEBUT.
STRANDS THE BASES LOADED,
UNSCATHED.
AND WE'LL HEAD TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE INNING.
♪
>> PACKY NAUGHTON IS GOING TO
HAVE TO THROW STRIKES.
PACKY GOT HIM TO CHASE THAT TIME
AND THERE ARE TWO AWAY ON HIS
FIRST STRIKEOUT OF THE NIGHT.
>> THREW A FASTBALL IN ON THE
PITCH BEFORE, FOLLOWED WITH A
CHANGEUP IN.
>> GOT HIM WITH THE HEATER.
>> TRIPLED UP ON FASTBALLS IN.
SAID THE RIGHT THINGS.
>> GOT HIM WITH THE FASTBALL.
AND NOT AND INDEED IN AND OUT OF
TROUBLE, STRANDED A PAIR WITH A
COUPLE OF STRIKEOUTS.
SPENT SOME TIME IN OAKLAND.
LOOK AT PACKY OFF THE MOUND TO
FIELD HIS POSITION.
YEAH!
A CALLED STRIKE THREE TAKEN BY
KIM.
AND HE STRIKES OUT SNELL.
THAT'S FIVE FOR PACKY TONIGHT.
TATIS SENDS IT BACK UP THE
MIDDLE.
FLETCH IS RIGHT THERE BEHIND THE
BAG.
>> AND HE WILL THROW OUT TATIS
AND THE INNING IS OVER.
SO ANOTHER CLEAN INNING FOR
PACKY NAUGHTON, WHO HAS RETIRED
THE LAST SEVEN BATTERS IN A ROW.
>> PACKY NAUGHTON HAS BEEN GREAT
TONIGHT.
HIS NIGHT COMES TO A CLOSE AFTER
FIVE INNINGS, BUT WHAT A START
IN JUST HIS SECOND CAREER AS A
BIG LEAGUER DUTY.
♪
SCOTT: A LOT OF TRAFFIC IN THE
TOP OF THE FIRST, NO RUNS TO
SHOW FOR IT AND LET'S RUN
THROUGH THE ANGEL STARTING
LINEUP PRESENTED BY TIME --
CHIME.
THE ROOKIE BRANDON MARSH,
FLETCHER SECOND, THE BIG MAN
SHOHEI OHTANI, NOW THIRD IN
BASEBALL WITH HIS BOMBS.
PHIL GOSSELIN, JARED WALSH, KURT
SUZUKI CATCHING, LUIS RENGIFO,
JACK MAYFIELD HITTING EIGHTH,
AND JUAN LAGARES IN THE NINE
SPOT.
GOING UP AGAINST THE
LEFT-HANDER, COLE IRVIN.
I'LL SUM IT UP THIS WAY, STRIKE
THROWER.
TOM: WE LIKE THAT.
HE ATTACKS.
SPEAKING OF TRAFFIC, IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE ANGELS
TO GET TRAFFIC IN FRONT OF
OHTANI, OTHERWISE IRVIN, JUST
DON'T NEED TO THROW OHTANI
STRIKES.
SCOTT: THIS IS A MAN ON THE
MOUND THAT IS AROUND THE ZONE AS
MUCH AS ANYONE IN BASEBALL.
MARSHA SWINGS RIGHT AWAY AND
THAT IS THE GAME PLAN THAT I'VE
SEEN FROM OPPOSING LINEUPS
AGAINST COLE IRVIN, ESPECIALLY
LATELY.
YOU'LL GET EARLY STRIKES AND
TEAMS ARE POUNCING.
TOM: THAT'S NOT A BAD THING IF
YOU'RE A PITCHER.
YOU THROW A FIRST PITCH
CHANGEUP.
THROW IT A LITTLE BIT OFF THE
PLATE.
USE THAT AGAINST THEM.
SCOTT: TONIGHT'S ODDS COURTESY
OF FANDUEL.
OVER/UNDER AT NINE TOTAL RUNS IN
THIS GAME.
TOM: I LIKE THE OVER,
PERSONALLY, TO ME.
SCOTT: YOU THINK WE'RE GOING TO
GET SOME ACTION?
WE ALREADY DID IN FIRST.
TOM: NO RUNS BUT A LOT OF
TRAFFIC.
THE A'S HAVE BEEN SCORING RUNS
THIS WEEK.
THEIR PROBLEM HAS BEEN LATE IN
GAMES, HOLDING TEAMS DOWN WITH
THE BULLPEN.
SCOTT: WE'LL KEEP AN I ON THAT
NUMBER.
2-1 TO MARSH.
THAT'S A GOOD SPOT.
THAT'S WHAT BOB MELVIN WANTS TO
SEE.
CAN YOU THROW TOO MANY STRIKES?
JUST MOVE YOURSELF JUST A LITTLE
MORE OFF THE PLATE, WORK THAT
IT.
TOM: THAT'S RIGHT, DEPENDS WHERE
THEY ARE, RIGHT?
KEEP THEM OFF THE MIDDLE.
SCOTT: AND THERE'S A GROUND
BALL.
MATT OLSON IS A GREAT GLOVE OVER
AT FIRST, IRVIN COVERING THE BAG
IN TIME FOR THE FIRST OUT.
MARSH LOOKS LIKE HE'S LIMPING A
LITTLE BIT.
TOM: MAY HAVE GOTTEN SPIKED OVER
THERE.
ALWAYS TOUGH FOR A LEFT-HANDED
PITCHER TO GET OVER THERE
BECAUSE THE DELIVERY TAKES HIM
TO THE THIRD-BASE SIDE.
HE'S A STEP LATE GETTING THERE,
JUST GOT MARSH, WHO RUNS REALLY
WELL.
LOOK LIKE MAYBE JUST THE WAY HIS
FOOT HIT THE BAG.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT MATT
OLSON, STILL A PITCH IN THAT
STEP THERE.
SCOTT: AND HE GOES RIGHT TO THE
TUNNEL, SO WE'LL SEE IF BRANDON
MARSH COMES BACK OUT IN THE
SECOND.
OLSON'S A VACUUM OVER THERE AT
FIRST BASE.
HE'S A GOLD GLOVER.
THERE A STRIKE TO FLETCHER.
IN A PERFECT GUY TO HAVE ON A
NIGHT WHERE COLE IRVIN IS
PITCHING.
TOM: BALL SHOULD BE ON THE
GROUND A LOT TONIGHT, NO
QUESTION, NOT A HIGH STRIKEOUT
GUY.
SCOTT: HARD CONTACT FROM
FLETCHER FOUL, 5-9 LIFETIME
AGAINST THE A'S LEFTY, TWO WAL
KS, TWO DOUBLES.
IN A 3-44 FUNK, WHICH HE REALLY
DIDN'T EXPECT TO SEE REALLY AT
ANY POINT IN HIS CAREER BECAUSE
HE'S SO CONSISTENT WITH HIS
CONTACT.
TOM: IT'S A PRODUCT OF CHASING
TOO MUCH, ESPECIALLY WITH TWO
STRIKES.
LISTEN, HE CAN PUT THE BAT ON
THE BASEBALL ANYWHERE IT'S
THROWN IN OR OUT OF THE ZONE.
BUT I THINK HE GETS TOO
AGGRESSIVE SOMETIMES TRYING TO
PUT THE BALL IN PLAY.
IT IS HARD TO MAKE A LIVING ON
PITCHES OUT OF THE ZONE.
YOU CAN DO IT ONCE IN A WHILE,
BUT NOT CONSISTENTLY.
SCOTT: MAKES CONTACT, LITTLE
CHEAP SHOT, RIGHT FIELD, CLASSIC
DAVID FLETCHER.
ONE OUT BASE RUNNER FOR THE
ANGELS.
THAT'S WHAT HE DOES, OPPOSITE
FIELD, FINDS A SINGLE.
TOM: AND NOW THERE'S THE
TRAFFIC.
INSTEAD OF FACING OHTANI, TWO
OUTS, BASES EMPTY, NOW IRVIN HAS
TO BE A LITTLE MORE AGGRESSIVE,
CERTAINLY HAS TO BE CAREFUL.
BUT FORCES IRVIN TO CHALLENGE
HIM A BIT.
SCOTT: AND IRVIN IS IN OHTANI'S
BOOK.
HE HAS HOMERED OFF HIM, 4-12
CAREER, AND 44 HOME RUNS ON THE
SEASON, CREEPING CLOSER TO THE
100 R.B.I. MARK, AS WELL.
TAKES THE FIRST PITCH, AND I
KNOW IT'S A LEFTY ON LEFTY, BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF CRIME WHEN IT
COMES TO SHOHEI OHTANI FACING
SOUTHPAWS.
HE IS UNFAZED.
TOM: LEFTIES DON'T BOTHER HIM.
THE HIGH FASTBALLS DON'T BOTHER
HIM.
ACTUALLY A BETTER HIGHBALL
HITTER THAN LOW-BALL HITTER.
IRVIN USES HIS FASTBALL UP IN
THE ZONE.
SCOTT: FOULS OFF THE 1-0, AND
YOU CAN SEE THE TOP RIGHT
PORTION OF YOUR SCREEN, THE
SHIFT TRACKS.
TOM: TALK ABOUT STATCAST,
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD, CAN
BREAK IT DOWN FOR US IN TERMS OF
HEIGHT ON PITCHES IN THE ZONE,
TALKING ABOUT FASTBALLS.
OHTANI A MUCH BETTER SLUGGER,
MUCH BETTER ON THE BALL UP THAN
THE BALL DOWN.
THAT'S UNUSUAL IN TODAY'S GAME.
SCOTT: HARD CONTACT PAST
SECOND AND IT'S A BASE HIT FOR
OHTANI.
FLETCHER IS GOING TO MOVE TO
THIRD AND HE'S IN THERE.
THEY'RE ON THE CORNERS.
OHTANI'S IN BUSINESS.
TOM: FLETCHER HAD STOPPED AT
SECOND BASE, AND RESTARTED, AS
YOU MENTIONED, SCOTT, ON THE
BUBBLE.
THAT WAS ACE -- BOBBLE.
THAT WAS A SLIDER DOWN.
KEEP AN EYE ON FLETCHER HERE.
HE'S DROPPING ANCHOR ON SECOND.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE READS IT.
DON'T NEED A THIRD BASE COACH
FOR THAT.
THAT'S A BIG 90 FEET TO GET TO
THIRD BASE WITH LESS THAN TWO
OUTS.
SCOTT: THAT BRINGS US TO PHIL
GOSSELIN.
SINCE THE ALL-STAR BREAK, .244.
HE'S ACTUALLY HIT NUMBER THREE
IN THE ORDER AS MUCH AS ALMOST
ANYONE ON THIS TEAM.
HE'S IN THE CLEANUP SPOT
TONIGHT.
THAT'S TAKEN DOWNSTAIRS.
ONLY TROUT AND RENDON APPEARED
IN THE THREE SPOT MORE THAN HIM.
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE A COMEBACK
OR ENOUGH TIME FOR TROUT TO MAKE
HIS WAY BACK TO THE TEAM, AND
RENDON'S BEEN DOWN FOR THE YEAR
FOR A WHILE NOW.
THERE'S MIKE.
SO THE ANGELS THREATENING IN THE
FIRST.
GOSSELIN POPS ONE UP, IN ON THE
HANDS.
OLSON HAS IT.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE IN INNING
WHERE THERE'S A RUNNER ON THIRD,
LESS THAN TWO OUTS, FOR BOTH
SIDES, AND ZEROS?
DOESN'T HAPPEN TOO OFTEN.
IT IS JARED WALSH'S TURN.
HE'S HAD BIG SPLITS THIS YEAR.
MOST OF HIS DAMAGE AGAINST
RIGHT-HANDED PITCHING.
THAT JUST MISSED.
IT'S THE ANGELS ALL-STAR FIRST
BASEMAN, 27 HOME RUNS ON THE
YEAR.
THE ALBERT PUJOLS REPLACEMENT.
SECOND-HALF NUMBERS HAVE TIPPED
OFF.
-- DIPPED OFF.
TOM: A'S MADE SOME GOOD
ADJUSTMENTS THIS SEASON.
MUCH QUIETER AT THE PLATE THAN
HE WAS BEFORE THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: THERE IS A STRIKE.
HE HAD GOOD EXAMPLES TO FOLLOW,
SUPERSTARS TO WATCH IN HIS OWN
LINEUP TO SEE HOW SIMPLE THEY
COULD MAKE THINGS WITH THEIR
SWING.
HIS SWING WAS COMPLICATED BEFORE
IT CHANGED.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM: THAT WAS BEFORE HE EVEN GOT
THE BAT GOING.
HE WOULD BE PUMPING THE BAT,
FEET MOVING.
SCOTT: AND HIT WEAKLY TO SECOND.
GOBBLED UP AND PUT AWAY.
KEMP TO OLSON.
BOTH SIDES CANNOT CAPITALIZE.
SCORE THROUGH -- SCORELESS
THROUGH ONE.
♪
>> FOUR HITS, TWO HOME RUNS,
FOUR RUNS SCORED IN THIS SERIES.
LEFT CENTER FIELD, DEEP.
NO WAY.
>> COME ON!
HE IS A MACHINE.
>> HE'S SALVY STRONG AND
CONTINUES TO DO IT.
>> HARRISON AT THIRD, CANHA
SECOND, LOWERY AT FIRST BASE.
>> ONE RUN SCORES.
CANHA WILL SCORE.
THE A'S COME THROUGH BIG-TIME,
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF POOR
DEFENSIVE PLAY BY THE ROYALS.
NOW IT'S 4-2.
>> HERE IS HARRIS AND.
-- HERE IS HARRISON.
KEMP WILL SCORE.
HARRISON HAS A FOUR HIT GAME.
TWO MORE R.B.I.'S FOR JOSH
HARRISON.
NOW IT'S 6-2.
>> SERGIO ROMO COMES OUT OF THE
A'S PEN.
A 4.45 E.R.A.
>> OLSON HAS GOT IT.
THAT WILL DO IT.
THE A'S NEEDED TO WIN THIS
SERIES, AND THEY DO.
NOW THEY WILL HEAD TO ANAHEIM
WITH MOMENTUM.
♪
SCOTT: 7, 8, AND NINE COMING UP
FOR THE A'S AND THE SECOND.
FIRST, SHOHEI OHTANI AND VLADDY
JR. HAVE BEEN TWO OF THE
BIG-LEAGUE'S FINEST.
THE GUY ON THE LEFT ALSO
PITCHES.
THESE ARE YOUR SUPPOSED TWO TOP
CANDIDATES FOR A.L. M.V.P.
VLADDY JR. WENT DEEP AGAIN, SO
HE'S AT 46 HOME RUNS ON THE
SEASON.
OHTANI HAD 44.
WE WILL BRING IN OUR FIRST POLL
QUESTION.
WE ARE KEEPING IT SIMPLE, SHOHEI
OR VLADDY JR., WHO IS YOUR A.L.
M.V.P.?
TOM: SORRY SALVY WITH 45 HOME
RUNS, BUT THOSE ARE YOUR TOP TWO
.
SCOTT: AND YOUR CHOICE IS?
TOM: I HAVE TO GO WITH OHTANI.
IT'S SO HARD TO COMPARE HIM TO
ANYBODY BECAUSE OF THE DYNAMIC
OF BEING A TWO-WAY PLAYER.
TAKE ALL THE PITCHERS IN
BASEBALL AND ALL THE PITCHES
THEY THROW AND HIS SPLITTER IS
THE HARDEST PITCH TO HIT. IN
BASEBALL
THAT IS AMAZING IN AND OF
ITSELF.
44 HOME RUNS, 23 STOLEN BASES.
SCOTT: ROLLER, LEFT SIDE.
LONG THROW IS CAUGHT BY A WASH
-- BY WALSH.
A TOUGH GO TO GET GOMES ON THE
INFIELD AND KNOCK.
A LEAD BASE RUNNER FOR OAKLAND.
TOM: YOU SEE HOW DEEP HE IS AT
LEFT FIELD.
THIS IS A THROW YOU ARE ALMOST
BETTER OFF BOUNCING.
HE'S TRYING TO GET A LOT ON IT,
I GET IT.
YOU SEE IT SAIL, YOU ARE BETTER
HAVING THE LONG HOP ON SUCH A
LONG THROW.
IT DOES GET THERE A BIT QUICKER,
TENDS TO BE MORE ACCURATE.
SCOTT: GOMES IS ON FOR CHRIS
DAVIS.
THAT MISSES WIDE.
LET'S KEEP THE OHTANI AND B.P.
DECISION GOING.
TOM: 44 HOMERS AND 23 STOLEN
BASES, ONLY FOUR GUYS IN
AMERICAN LEAGUE HISTORY HAVE
DONE THAT.
WE ARE LOOKING AT SOMEONE YOU
CAN'T COMPARE TO ANYBODY ELSE,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO VLAD.
VOTERS TEND TO BE INFLUENCED A
LITTLE BIT OF A RECENCY BIAS.
YOU HAVE A TEAM IN THE PLAYOFF
HUNT LIKE TORONTO.
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING TRAFFIC IN
FRONT OF OHTANI.
HE DOES NOT HAVE A LOT OF HELP
IN THE LINEUP.
MARCUS SEMIEN M.V.P. NUMBERS, BO
BICHETTE, IT'S JUST AS DEEP AS
THE MARIANA TRENCH, THAT LINEUP.
IT IS HARD TO COMPARE THE TWO,
YOU HAVE TO ULTIMATELY, AS A
VOTER BUT WE ARE LOOKING AT
SOMETHING WE HAVE NOT SEEN IN
OUR LIFETIMES WITH OHTANI.
SCOTT: YOU ARE SAYING IT IS
UNLIKE ANYTHING WE ARE SEEING IN
BASEBALL'S LONG, HISTORIC MARK
IN SOCIETY.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN A PLAYER LIKE
THIS CONTRIBUTE ON THE MOUND AND
AT THE PLATE.
IT'S 3-1 TO DAVIS.
IT'S NOT JUST THAT HE IS DOING
IT, HE IS A TOP FIVE HEADER, IF
NOT TOP THREE, MAY BE A TOP 10
-- HITTER, IF NOT TOP THREE, MAY
BE A TOP 10 PITCHER.
TOM: AND YOU ARE STRIKING OUT 10
BATTERS PER NINE INNINGS.
YOU LEAD YOUR TEAM IN INNINGS
PITCHED.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S A PART-TIME
PITCHER.
SCOTT: A STRIKE TO DAVIS.
SO, CASE CLOSED?
ARE WE GOOD FOR NOW?
TOM: I WILL TELL YOU THIS,
SCOTT, IT'S A LOT CLOSER THAN I
WAS A MONTH AGO.
PITCHERS HAVE STOPPED PITCHING
TO SHOHEI.
VLAD KEEPS GETTING HOTTER DOWN
THE STRETCH.
SCOTT: HERE'S GOMES AFTER THE
LEADOFF INFIELD HIT.
THAT IS BALL FOUR TO CHRIS
DAVIS.
-- KHRIS DAVIS.
TOM: TRIED TO GO BACK TO THAT
3-2 BACK FOOT SLIDER.
JUST DID NOT LAND THAT ONE.
HERE HE IS IN TROUBLE AGAIN.
SCOTT: THIRD WALK, ALSO A HIT BY
PITCH.
NUMBER NINE HITTER, TONY KEMP.
HE'S BEEN ONE OF THE BEST IN THE
NINE SPOT THIS SEASON IN
BASEBALL.
TOM: HE WILL MAKE YOU THROW A
LOT OF PITCHES.
SCOTT: PULLS BACK ON THE BUNT.
TOM: DID YOU SAY BUNT, SCOTT?
IS THAT ALLOWED BY THE OAKLAND
A'S IN THE SECOND INNING?
WOW.
SCOTT: YESTERDAY TONY KEMP TRIED
TO BUNT HIT, SLIDE INTO FIRST,
AND HE WAS OUT.
TOM: BUT SCOTT, THIS IS A FULL
ON SACRIFICE.
YOU DON'T SEE THIS EARLY ON IN A
BIG-LEAGUE GAME.
SWINGING THERE.
NOT CLOSE.
SCOTT: WAS THAT A TEASE ON THE
FIRST PITCH FOR US?
TOM: JARED WALSH CAME IN A MAYBE
STEP MORE FOR THE SECOND PITCH.
RIGHT NOW IN THE COUNT IN HIS
FAVOR I'M LETTING TONY KEMP
SWING THE BAT.
I TRUST HIM TO NOT EXPAND WITH
THE COUNT IN HIS FAVOR.
WE HAVE A BIG INNING IN ORDER
RIGHT HERE.
IT IS A LITTLE EARLY TO GIVE UP
AND OUT.
I'M TRUSTING TONY KEMP, CONTROLS
THE STRIKE ZONE, TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE A GOOD AT-BAT HERE.
SCOTT: HAD A GREEN LIGHT AFTER
THE WALK AND TWO MISSES.
THAT WOULD HAVE MISSED.
TOM: AGAIN WE HAVE SEEN DIAZ A
COUPLE TIMES IN SO-CALLED
FASTBALL COUNTS THOROUGH
SECONDARY PITCHES.
THE CHANGEUP THERE.
KEMP SITTING ON FASTBALL. INNER
HALF
-- FASTBALL INNER HALF.
FOULED IT OFF.
SCOTT: HE'S ABOUT 50% BALLS AND
STRIKES SO FAR TONIGHT, AS HE IS
ABOUT TO MAKE HIS 38TH TOSS
ALREADY.
WE ARE IN THE SECOND.
GOMES AND DAVIS ARE ON.
2-1 TO KEMP.
MAKE IT 3-1.
TOM: HE CAME INTO THIS GAME WITH
A REPUTATION IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES AS BEING A BETTER STRIKE
THROWER THAN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
SO FAR.
SCOTT: THAT WAS ACTUALLY THE
FIRST PITCH THAT LANDED IN THE
ZONE OF THIS AT-BAT.
TOM: BEHIND ON THE COUNT THROUGH
THE CHANGEUP, LEFT ON LEFT
CHANGEUP.
THESE ARE THE THINGS THE OAKLAND
A'S ARE FIGURING OUT ON THE FLY.
HE HAS SHOWN MORE CONFIDENCE IN
HIS SECONDARY PITCHES WHERE HE
NEEDS TO THROW A STRIKE THAN HIS
FASTBALL.
SCOTT: MISSED.
ANOTHER WALK.
FOURTH BASE ON BALL FOR OAKLAND
TONIGHT, PLUS THE HIT BY PITCH
AND AN INFIELD SINGLE.
TOM: THEY HAD THIS AS A
CHANGEUP.
THAT IS A LITTLE HARD AS A
I THINK THAT WAS A DEAD FISH
FASTBALL HE THREW AT 87.
SCOTT: SO COULD THAT BE A
SINKER?
TOM: YOU WILL SEE THIS WITH
PITCHERS WHO ADD AND SUBTRACT
OFF THEIR FASTBALLS.
THAT IS WHERE HIS FASTBALL
NORMALLY IS, 89, 90.
BUT EVER SINCE HARRISON GOT HIT
BY A PITCH TO START THIS GAME,
DIAZ HAS BEEN PITCHING OUT OF
THE STRETCH.
SCOTT: IT WILL BE TOUGH TO GET
OUT OF THIS ONE.
HE DID IT IN THE FIRST, LEFT THE
BASES LOADED, BUT NOBODY DOWN.
HARRISON POPS IT UP.
THAT WILL GO BEHIND THE SCREEN.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS A
BIG-LEAGUE NICKNAME YET, BUT HE
ESCAPES THIS ONE HE IS THE
MAGICIAN, RIGHT?
[LAUGHTER]
TOM: I USED TO SAY HOUDINI, BUT
YOUNG PLAYERS HAVE NO IDEA WHO
HARRY HOUDINI WAS.
SCOTT: AGAIN, THAT IS WHAT
YOUTUBE IS FOR.
TOM: THAT'S RIGHT.
YOUTUBE HARRY HOUDINI.
SCOTT: GO FOR IT.
HARRISON IS COMING OFF A BIG
SERIES AGAINST K.C.
AND THAT IS A GROUND BALL
THROUGH THE INFIELD, AND HE'S
OFF TO A GREAT START AGAIN.
JOSH HARRISON WITH THE R.B.I.
KNOCK.
IT'S 1-0 OAKLAND.
EVERYBODY MOVES UP ONE STATION.
TOM: STAYS RED HOT.
GOT A SINKER FROM DIAZ.
WATCH HIS HIPS HERE.
JOSH IS SO GOOD ON TURNING ON
THE BASEBALL.
HE OPENS THOSE HIPS SO QUICKLY.
IT'S SO HARD TO JAM HIM.
AT 89, YOU ARE CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO GET IN HIS KITCHEN.
RED HOT.
SCOTT: THE LAST FOUR GAMES FOR
JOSH HE HAS HE RUNS BATTED IN.
IT'S GOMES SCORING, DAVIS TO
THIRD, KEMP ON SECOND, AND MARTE
WILL FOLLOW HARRIS AND.
STILL NOBODY OUT IN THE SECOND.
TOM: THIS IS THE 11TH BATTER.
SUZUKI WENT OUT ONCE.
PITCHING COACH WENT OUT TWICE.
YOU ONLY GET FIVE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: MAYBE WE SHOULD DO THE
OVER/UNDER THERE.
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER FIVE?
I THINK YOU GET TOSSED FROM THE
GAME IF YOU TRY IT.
TOM: THAT IS THE RULE.
I THINK THE UMPIRE WILL
LITERALLY TACKLE YOU BEFORE YOU
GET TO THE MOUND SO IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
SCOTT: HERE IS STARLING.
FIRST PITCH WHIFF.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME SWING AND
MISS FROM DIAZ, JUST NOT
CONSISTENTLY AROUND THE ZONE,
PUTTING HIMSELF IN SOME TOUGH
SPOTS.
MARTE FLEW OUT TO CENTER FIRST
TIME AROUND.
TOM: THE SWINGS AND MISSES HAVE
ALL BEEN ON SLIDER AND THE
CHANGEUP.
HE JUST DOES NOT HAVE A FASTBALL
THAT HITTERS HAVE TO GUARD
AGAINST.
HE'S NOT GOING TO BEAT YOU WITH
A FASTBALL.
SCOTT: THIS LOOKS LIKE IT COULD
TURN INTO A BULLPEN GAME FOR THE
ANGELS TONIGHT.
THERE IS ALREADY ACTION GOING ON
IN THE PEN.
TOM: ONE THING YOU WORRY ABOUT
WITH YOUNG PITCHERS  ISTHEIR
PITCH -- IS THEIR PITCH IN A
PARTICULAR INNING.
YOU DON'T WANT THEM GETTING MORE
THAN 30.
SCOTT: MARTE TO CENTER.
MARSH HAS IT.
EVERYONE WILL HOLD UP.
TOM: THAT IS A GOOD HOLD WITH
NOBODY OUT.
A GOOD LOOK AT MARSH BEING ABLE
TO -- THE BALL IS IN FRONT OF
HIM, GET BEHIND SO HE'S GOT
SOMETHING ON IT.
THAT DECISION IS MADE BEFORE THE
BALL IS EVEN THROWN.
OUTFIELDER COMING IN LIKE THAT,
NOBODY OUT, THAT IS A RED LIGHT.
MAYBE WITH ONE OUT YOU CAN TRY
IT.
SCOTT: WISE DECISION BY CHRIS
DAVIS.
OLSON WITH THE BAGS FULL OF A'S.
JOE MADDON TOLD US BEFORE THE
GAME, GOLD GLOVE POTENTIAL OUT
THERE.
I'M NOT JUST SAYING IT BECAUSE
IT IS ONE OF MY GUYS, HE MEANT
IT.
TOM: HAS DIAZ HIT 90?
BRANDON MARSH HAS.
SCOTT: THAT IS A GOOD POINT.
TOM: ONCE AGAIN HE HAS PITCHED
THE ENTIRE GAME SO FAR WITH
TRAFFIC AROUND HIM.
HE HAS DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB TO
KEEP IT AT ONE.
OLSON DOES NOT HIT TOO MANY
GROUND BALLS.
SCOTT: BIG CUT AND A MISS.
THE ANGELS FIRST BASE CAN HIT 90
PLUS, JARED WALSH.
DID A LITTLE BIT OF TWO-WAY
ACTION.
HERE IS THE ARSENAL FOR DIAZ.
TOM: 13 FASTBALLS SO FAR OUT
OF THESE 49 PITCHES.
SCOTT: OLSON CONNECTS DEEP
CENTER.
MARSH GIVING IT A LOOK, AND HE'S
GOT IT.
THIS TIME IT IS GOOD ENOUGH TO
SCORE A RUN.
IN COMES DAVIS.
ALSO TAGGING UP HIS CAMP.
-- TAGGING UP IS KEMP.
OLSON CONTINUES TO ADD TO HIS
SEASON HE HAS HIT TRIPLE DIGITS
WITH RUNS BATTED IN.
SCOTT: I THINK DIAZ WILL TAKE
THAT BASED ON WHERE THAT
CURVEBALL WAS.
OLSON HIT TO THE DEEPEST PART OF
THE FIELD.
AND THAT IS ALL FOR YOUNG
JONATHAN DIAZ.
SCOTT: KYLE TYLER WILL TAKE
OVER.
TWO RUNS ACROSS FROM OAKLAND IN
THE SECOND.
DIAZ REMOVED, AND IT IS A
BULLPEN GAME FOR JOE MADDON IN
THE ANGELS, TRYING TO GET ONE
MORE OUT.
THE A'S PUTTING THE PRESSURE IN
THE SECOND.
-- PUTTING ON PRESSURE IN THE
SECOND.
>> IT TELLS THE FAMILY THEY ARE
NOT ALONE, THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
IN YOUR OWN COMMUNITY, EVEN THE
PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL GAME, THAT
CARES ABOUT YOU.
>> IT'S GREAT TO SEE THE WHOLE
ORGANIZATION OUT HERE, TO GIVE
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY GIVES US
-- THE COMMUNITY THAT GIVES US
SO MUCH THROUGHOUT THE YEAR IS
GREAT.
>> SOME OF THE FOLKS THAT WE GET
A CHANCE TO IDOLIZE ON THE FIELD
ARE THINKING ABOUT US THE WAY WE
ARE THINKING ABOUT THEM.
>> I LOVE WITH THE OAKLAND A'S
ARE DOING.
THEY ARE SURROUNDING THESE
FAMILIES WITH LOVE AND CARE.
FOR SOME OF THESE KIDS, THEY
MADE THEIR YEAR.
>> FOR US TO PUT OUR ARMS AROUND
THE A'S FAN BASE AND SAY WE LOVE
YOU, WE WANT YOU TO BE PART OF
THE TEAM AND WHAT WE ARE TRYING
TO DO IN OAKLAND, THE ENTIRE BAY
AREA.
>> THAT WAS A NICE EXPERIENCE.
IT WAS REALLY COOL.
♪
SCOTT: LET'S RUN THROUGH THIS.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING THE GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE, YOU
HAVE YOUR CHOICE OF LISTENING
EXPERIENCE PLAYER IT --
EXPERIENCE.
CLICK THE GEAR ICON, YOU HAVE,
PRIMARY HOME AND AWAY RADIO
CALLS.
TONIGHT IS A SPECIAL EDITION.
IF YOU SELECT HOME, YOU WILL
HAVE JAPANESE BROADCASTING THAT
WE MIGHT HEAR FROM AT SOME
POINT.
HELLO TO OUR FRIENDS.
ALL AUDIO IS SEAMLESSLY
INTEGRATED ON ALL OF YOUR
DEVICES.
DON'T MISS THE SPECIAL FEATURE
TONIGHT ON YOUTUBE.
HELLO TO EVERYONE WATCHING
OVERSEAS IN JAPAN AND ACROSS THE
GLOBE.
SHOHEI OHTANI IN THE ANGELS DOWN
2-0.
-- AND THEY DOWN 2-0.
-- AND THE ANGELS DOWN 2-0.
TWO ON FOR OAKLAND AND TWO IN IN
THE SECOND.
TOM: I LIKE THE MOVES.
ANGELS WERE HOPING TO GET SOME
LENGTH OUT OF DIAZ, BUT WHEN YOU
ARE OUT OF THE STRETCH
THAT MUCH AND THROWING THAT MANY
PITCHES IN AN INNING, YOU DON'T
WANT TO EXTEND A YOUNG PITCHER
LIKE THAT.
HE WAS NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
LENGTH AT THIS POINT IN THE GAME
ANYWAY.
NEVER LET A GAME GET OUT OF
HAND.
THAT IS WHAT JOE MADDON IS
TRYING TO DO RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT: HE'LL SWITCH IT UP WITH A
RIGHT-HANDER.
HE HIT CANHA.
THAT HAPPENS A LOT FOR THE A'S
CLEANUP MAN.
TOM: WELL, I WILL SAY THIS, 24
TIMES, LEADS THE LEAGUE HIT BY A
PITCH.
16 OF THEM WERE ON THE ELBOW
GUARD.
THAT ONE HE REALLY COULD NOT GET
OUT OF THE WAY.
THAT WAS A TWO-SEAMER TRACKING
IN.
CHALK THAT UP TO NUMBER 17 ON
THE ELBOW GUARD.
I HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THAT.
BALLS WHERE YOU CAN GET OUT OF
THE WAY, HITTERS DON'T MOVE
BECAUSE THEY ARE WEARING A PIECE
OF ARMOR.
TO ME THAT SHOULD NOT BE HIT BY
PITCH WHEN YOU ARE HIT ON THE
GEAR.
TO BE CLEAR, I'M NOT BLAMING
CANHA.
HITTERS GET HIT MORE THAN BEFORE
IN THE GAME HISTORY.
YOU NEED PROTECTION.
I'M SAYING BASEBALL SHOULD MAKE
AN ISSUE THAT HITTERS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TRY TO GET OUT OF THE
WAY OF PITCHES.
AND ARMOR EMBOLDENS THEM TO STAY
IN AND GET HIT.
IT IS PART OF HIS GAME.
AGAIN, I'M NOT BLAMING HIM.
IF I WERE A PITCHER, I WOULD NOT
LIKE IT.
THE GUYS NOT GOING TO MOVE
WEARING ARMOR.
-- GUY IS NOT GOING TO MOVE
SCOTT: WE USED TO SAY THAT IS 24
BRUISES, BUT THAT IS NOT ALWAYS.
THE CASE NOW
TYLER IS HAVING TROUBLE FINDING
THE ZONE.
THIS IS. HIS FOURTH APPEARANCE
OF THE YEAR
WE SAW HIM ON TUESDAY IN
CHICAGO, MATCHING UP AGAINST THE
WHITE SOX, GAVE THE ANGELS THREE
SCORELESS, NO STRIKEOUTS, A HIT
AND A WALK.
THERE IT IS DOWN THE PIPE.
A 20TH ROUND PICK OUT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF OKLAHOMA IN 2018.
TOM: HIS GO TO PITCH IS THAT
CUTTER YOU SAW RIGHT THERE.
CUTTER'S WORK AWAY FROM
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS.
THE TWO-SEAMER WILL WORK IN
TOWARDS HIM, PRETTY MUCH THE
BULK OF WHAT HE'S GOING TO
THROW.
SCOTT: FROM 3-0 TO 3-2.
TOM: THIS IS ANOTHER PITCH WHERE
THE A'S CAN BREAK THIS GAME OPEN
EARLY.
SCOTT: THEY ARE LOADED UP FOR
PINER, WHO STRUCK OUT IN THE
FIRST.
-- PINDER, WHO STRUCK OUT IN THE
LAGARES HAS THE THIRD OUT.
DEFINITELY COULD HAVE BEEN
UGLIER FOR THE ANGELS PITCHING.
TWO RUNS IN FOR OAKLAND.
THEY STRAND THE BASES YET AGAIN,
MID TWO.
>> RAN HE FOR HAS BEEN PICKING
UP -- RENGIFO HAS BEEN PICKING
UP HIS HITTING A LITTLE BIT.
>> RENGIFO WITH A TWO RUN
DINGER.
>> LEWIS GIVING THE HALOS AN
EARLY LEAD.
--LUIS RENGIFO GIVING THE HALOS
AN EARLY LEAD.
>> FAIR BALL.
STASSI SCORES EASILY.
THEY WILL TRY IT WITH RENGIFO.
NO PLAY AT THE PLATE.
A BASES CORNERING DOUBLE.
THE BALL GOT AWAY FROM COLLINS.
>> ONE LAST RIDE FOR OHTANI IN
FRONT OF CHICAGO FANS THIS YEAR.
>> HEY, DUDE.
THOSE ARE THREE BRUTAL MISSES.
THEY MIGHT RUN HIM.
WHAT IS THE DEAL HERE?
THAT MIGHT BE IT.
>> A NUMBER OF THE WHITE SOX.
>> HE GONE!
>> TONY WILL WANT AN
EXPLANATION.
HE STARTING TO GET MORE
ANIMATED.
>> AWAY HE GOES.
TONY LA RUSSA EJECTED.
I THINK TONY IS ASKING WHERE IS
THE WARNING.
THE CHANT  IS TONY.
TOM: EVERYTHING WORKS OFF THAT
FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL.
OCCASIONALLY A CURVE DROPS INTO
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS.
HERE IS OUR CHIME BREAKDOWN ON
COLE IRVIN.
IT IS A HOME GAME FOR HIM.
DOES HE PITCH FOR OAKLAND?
HE GREW UP 10 MILES AWAY FROM
HERE.
HE WAS ON THE GROUNDS CREW AT
ANGEL STADIUM.
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO BARTOLO
COLON TO FIND SOMEONE WITH A
QUALIFIED NUMBER OF INNINGS FOR
THE OAKLAND A'S WHO HAD SUCH A
LOW WALK RATE.
HE IS A STRIKE THROWER AND
98.2 EFFICIENCY.
-- 98.2% EFFICIENCY.
SCOTT: SUZUKI CLOCK'S ONE DEEP
LEFT FIELD.
IT IS ON ITS WAY AND IT IS GONE.
THE ANGELS ARE ON THE BOARD.
A SOLO SHOT FOR KURT SUZUKI TO
LIGHTED UP.
-- TO LIGHT IT UP.
TOM: MY EFFICIENCY NOTE WAS
ABOUT HIS FASTBALL.
AND KURT SUZUKI SAID I DON'T
BELIEVE IN THAT KIND OF MATH.
AS YOU CAN SEE, HE DOESN'T THROW
HARD, BUT BECAUSE HE HAS TRUE
BACKSPIN, TRUE NORTH-SOUTH ON
HIS FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL, THAT IS
HOW EFFICIENT THE SPIN IS, BUT
IT WORKS BETTER HIGHER IN THE
ZONE.
SUZUKI SQUARED THIS ONE UP.
HE WILL GET POPS -- POP UPS
AND SWINGS AND MISSES.
SCOTT: A+ SWING.
TOM: THAT BALL WAS HAMMERED.
EXIT VELOCITY 102.1.
SCOTT: THAT IS PULLED TO SHORT.
IT EATS UP HARRISON.
RENGIFO IS ON.
TOM: PLAYING DEFENSE, WE ALWAYS
LOOK AT THE HANDS, BUT IT IS THE
FOOTWORK.
HARRISON PLAYED HIMSELF INTO A
BAD HOP.
WAS UNSURE WHETHER TO GET THE
SHORTER HOP.
YOU SEE HIM GO BACK.
HE PLAYED HIMSELF INTO A WORSE
HOP.
THAT TO ME IS THE DIFFERENCE.
HE SHOULD HAVE CONTINUED TO GO
IN.
HE KNEW IT RIGHT THERE.
I THINK ABOUT GREAT DEFENDERS, I
THINK OF GREAT FOOTWORK.
CAL RIPKEN IS THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF A GUY YOU WOULD NOT
SAY WAS SPECTACULAR, BUT HE KNEW
WHERE AND WHEN TO GET THE HOP.
SCOTT: HARRISON HAD BEEN PLAYING
THIRD FOR MOST OF THE WEEK, AS
CHAPMAN WAS OUT, NOW MOVES TO
SHORT.
TOM: HE IS A GOOD DEFENDER NO
MATTER WHERE YOU PUT HIM.
THAT IS AN ANOMALY, THAT PLAY.
YOU TRUST HIM IN ANY INFIELD
POSITION.
SCOTT: 1-0 TO JACK MAYFIELD.
THAT SPOT WAS HELD DOWN BY
MARCUS SEMIEN FOR YEARS.
HE IS ON FIRE WITH TORONTO AND
ABOUT TO ENTER ANOTHER FREE
AGENT YEAR, WHERE TEAMS WILL
PROBABLY BE CALLING MORE SO THAN
A YEAR AGO.
TOM: AT EITHER POSITION, SECOND
BASE OR SHORTSTOP.
SCOTT: SEMIEN'S BIRTHDAY TODAY,
TOO.
THE A'S TOOK 2-3 FROM KANSAS
CITY ENTERING TODAY.
HARRISON WAS THEIR BEST PLAYER
IN THAT SET.
MAYFIELD HAS A BASE HIT.
HERE GOES RENGIFO TO THIRD
EASILY.
SECOND INNING IN A ROW, ANGELS
HAVE THEM ON THE CORNERS.
TOM: ONE THING THE ANGELS DO
REALLY WELL I THINK IS RUN THE
BASES.
YOU SAW THAT SERIES IN CHICAGO,
A LOT OF INFIELD HITS, BEATING
PLAYS AT FIRST BASE BY GETTING
DOWN THE LINE.
MAYFIELD PUNCHES THE OTHER WAY.
THE RUN ON RENGIFO DOES NOT NEED
A THIRD BASE COACH.
HE KNOWS AS SLOWLY AS THE BALL
WAS HIT, I'M GONE.
ONE QUICK LOOK.
GET THERE EASILY.
SCOTT: NOBODY DOWN IN THE
SECOND.
AND A CHANCE FOR LAGARES.
HE IS JUST 1-9 AGAINST IRVINE.
-- IRVIN.
TOM: RUNNERS, HOW OFTEN DO THEY
USE THE THIRD BASE COACH?
THE BALL ALL THE WAY IN THE
INFIELD CORNER, YOU MIGHT NEED
HIM, BUT THE INSTINCTUAL RUNNERS
DON'T NEED THE THIRD BASE COACH
ON THOSE HITS.
SCOTT: BUNT.
IT IS DOWN.
IRVIN FUMBLES IT.
HERE COMES RENGIFO.
WE ARE TIED AT 2-2.
NOWADAYS THAT WILL SHOCK
EVERYONE, AND THAT CREATES A
FUMBLE.
TOM: GOT THE PICTURE OFF THE
MOUND.
IRVIN TRIED TO HURRY.
GOOD READ AT THIRD BASE BY
RENGIFO.
THIS IS JUST PERFECTLY EXECUTED.
WE SAW THE FALL START FROM
MAYFIELD TO FIRST BASE.
THAT IS DESIGNED TO HOLD THE
FIRST BASEMAN MATT OLSON AT THE
BAG TO KEEP HIM FROM CHARGING.
THAT WAS A PERFECTLY EXECUTED
PLAY BY THE BATTER AND BOTH BASE
RUNNERS.
SCOTT: WE ARE BACK TO THE TOP OF
THE ORDER IN BRANDON MARSH.
ANOTHER BUNT.
CHAPMAN.
GOT HIM.
BOTH RUNNERS MOVE UP.
BACK TO BACK -- I WILL WHISPER
IT -- BUNTS.
TOM: IS IT LEGAL?
[LAUGHTER]
IT IS FUN, ISN'T IT?
DEREK JETER WAS THE BEST I EVER
SAW AT THIS.
IN THIS SITUATION, YOU HAVE THE
BIG BOYS BEHIND YOU, MOVE THE
RUNNERS-UP, BUT YOU ARE NOT
GIVING YOURSELF UP TOTALLY.
YOU ARE MARSH, THERE IS A CHANCE
YOU CAN BEAT THAT OUT.
HAVE TO MOVE THEM UP.
JETER GOT A LOT OF HITS THAT
WAY.
THE WORST THING THAT CAN HAPPEN,
YOU JUST SAW, MOVE THE
RUNNERS-UP.
-- THE RUNNERS UP.
SCOTT: SETS UP THINGS NICELY FOR
FLETCHER WITH OHTANI ON DECK.
FLETCHER FIRST PITCH SWINGING.
THE ANGELS WILL GRAB THE LEAD.
MAYFIELD AND LAGARES, COME ON
DOWN.
IT'S 4-2.
DAVID FLETCHER DRIVES IN TWO
WITH THE BASE HIT.
TOM: SMALL BALL RULES!
YOU GOT TO LOVE IT.
EXECUTION ON THE HIGHEST ORDER.
FLETCHER, WHO IS A TERRIFIC,
HIGHBALL HEADER  -- IS A
TERRIFIC HIGHBALL HITTER, WANTS
SOMETHING UP THERE ANYWAY.
LAGARES HAD A GOOD READ ON THIS
FROM SECOND BASE, SCORED EASILY.
LAGARES WILL TAKE ONE LOOK.
IT'S IN.
HE WILL SCORE EASILY.
SCOTT: OLD-SCHOOL BASEBALL FANS
ARE GOING NUTS RIGHT NOW.
TWO SAC BUNTS.
TOM: OHTANI IS A GREAT BUNTER,
BY THE WAY.
HE CAN DO EVERYTHING, BUT HE'S
NOT BUNTING HERE.
WE WILL NOT SEE A THIRD STRAIGHT
BUNT.
SCOTT: ARE YOU SURE?
TOM: YES.
SCOTT: ONE OUT, FLETCHER ON.
JUST MISSED.
TOM: SINCE JULY, OHTANI HAS SEEN
57% OF THE PITCHES OUT OF THE
STRIKE ZONE.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE
IN BASEBALL.
SCOTT: SIMILAR SPOT FROM IRVIN,
GOES OFFSPEED.
TOM: SO HIS CHALLENGE IS TO
ACCEPT WALKS.
THIS GUY IS SUCH AN AGGRESSIVE
HEADER, HE CAN SQUARE UP PITCHES
OUTSIDE OF THE ZONE OR ON THE
BLACK LIKE THE LAST ONE, BUT
HE'S GOT A LITTLE TOO AGGRESSIVE
OUTSIDE OF THE ZONE IN THESE
LAST TWO MONTHS, UNDERSTANDABLY.
SCOTT: I THINK OF BRYCE HARPER
SEVERAL YEARS BACK, WHERE HE WAS
A FORCE.
EVENTUALLY EVERYONE SAID, YOU
KNOW WHAT, LET'S DEAL WITH
EVERYONE ELSE.
THAT WAS LED BY JOE MADDON AND
THE CUBS.
THEY GAVE HIM NOTHING.
TOM: BRYCE HARPER IS SECOND IN
MOST PITCHES OUT OF THE ZONE,
BUT HE DOES TAKE HIS WALKS.
SCOTT: LAYS OFF THAT ONE UP.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE ALL OF HIS
FRIENDS BACK NEXT YEAR.
SEE MORE PITCHES HOPEFULLY IN
THE ZONE.
TROUT, RENDON, UPTON.
TWO DOWN.
THAT IS MATT CHAPMAN ALL ALONE
ON THE LEFT SIDE.
WHEN YOU SAY CHASING OUTSIDE OF
THE ZONE, IT DOESN'T ALWAYS MEAN
STRIKEOUT, IT MEANS IT'S NOT
ALWAYS OPTIMAL CONTACT.
TOM: EXACTLY.
THAT IS A GOOD PITCH BY IRVIN.
YOU ARE IN PROTECT MODE.
BUT THERE IS AN OLD SAYING, WHEN
YOU ARE WALKING, YOU ARE
HITTING.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
WELL, IT MEANS YOU ARE NOT
SWINGING AT BALLS OUT OF THE
ZONE.
THAT IS THE SIGN OF A GOOD
HITTER.
WITHOUT A LOT OF PROTECTION IN
THIS LINEUP, OHTANI IS TRYING TO
PUT OF THE SAME NUMBERS HE HAD
IN THE FIRST HALF OF THE SEASON,
SLUGGING 700.
IT WAS HARD IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO
MAINTAIN THAT.
RIGHT NOW I THINK HE'S CHASING
NUMBERS A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: GOSSELIN ON ONE HOP GOES
TO HARRISON.
THAT WILL DO IT.
THE ANGELS PUT UP FOUR.
KURT SUZUKI WITH A BIG BLESSED,
DAVID FLETCHER KNOCKS IN TWO.
THERE WAS SOME SMALL BALL AS
WELL.
KURT GOT THE SCORING
STARTED.
ANGELS 4, A'S 2.
AN ACTION-PACKED FIRST TWO
INNINGS IN ANAHEIM.
♪
>> AND THAT ONE IS HIT DEEP TO
LEFT FIELD.
VAUGHN IS BACK.
THAT BABY IS GONE.
FOURTH HOME RUN FOR CHAPMAN
AGAINST DALLAS KEUCHEL IN HIS
CAREER.
AN EASY 1-0.
>> THAT IS HIT TO LEFT FIELD.
>> HE LEAPS.
AND THAT BABY IS GONE.
YAN GOMES GETS THE A'S ON THE
BOARD.
IT'S 4-2.
>> MATT LINES ONE DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE FOR A BASE HIT.
GOING TO SCORE MURPHY.
ELVIS WILL SCORE.
MARTE, THEY WILL WAVE HIM.
HE SCORES WITHOUT A THROW.
A DOUBLED ON THE LEFT FIELD LINE
BY MATT OLSON.
THE A'S HAVE BROKEN IT OPEN.
>> DEEP TO LEFT FIELD.
AND THAT BABY IS GONE.
>> A HOME RUN FOR MARTE IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE FIRST INNING.
>> DRIVEN TO RIGHT FIELD, GARCIA
GOING BACK.
HE'S NEAR THE WALL.
THAT BABY IS GONE.
>> 33 FOR MATT OLSON, GIVES HIM
96 R.B.I.'S.
>> AND A MILESTONE.
>> 500TH HIT.
>> THAT IS THE WAY TO DO IT.
♪
SCOTT: IT IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK A LIVE ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
GORGEOUS IN ANAHEIM, CALIFORNIA.
LET'S FINISH THIS.
IT WAS NOT CLOSE.
YOUR A.L. M.V.P. ACCORDING TO
EVERYONE WATCHING ON YOUTUBE IS
STILL SHOW A OHTANI.
TOM: THAT IS ABOUT WHERE I
THOUGHT IT WOULD FALL.
SCOTT: I THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE 90%
TO 10%.
WE KNOW WHO IS WATCHING, ANGELS
FANS CHIMING IN.
1-1.
ANOTHER INNING OF WORK FROM KYLE
TYLER.
WE HAVE HEARD IN THE PAST WEEK
OR SO A LITTLE MORE CHATTER, I
THINK, AT LEAST FROM PEOPLE I
FOLLOW IN THE BASEBALL WORLD,
THAT THIS IS MORE OF A RACE THAN
YOU THINK.
CHAPMAN FINDS A HIT.
THERE ARE SOME WORDS FROM OUR
YOUTUBE CREATOR FRIENDS.
OHTANI IS DOING SOMETHING THAT
MAY NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
VLAD WILL WIN ONE IN THE FUTURE.
WELL SAID.
TOM: BUT OHTANI MIGHT DO IT NEXT
YEAR, TOO.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT NO ONE ELSE WILL DO IT.
SCOTT: SHOHEI HAS TIME LEFT.
27 YEARS OLD.
THIS IS THE FIRST SEASON WHERE
OHTANI REALLY PUT IT ALL
TOGETHER AS A PITCHER AND A
HITTER.
YAN GOMES LAUNCHES ONE IN THE
DIRT.
CHAPMAN WITH A LEADOFF HIT.
A'S DOWN BY TWO.
THE ANGELS YOUTUBE CHANNEL SAID
THE POLL RESULTS ARE
SATISFACTORY TO US.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN WATCHING THIS
TEAM ON A DAILY BASIS, YOU KNOW
IT IS ONE OF THOSE PLAYERS WEAR
EVERY TIME HE IS ON THE MOUND OR
AT THE PLATE, YOU ARE GLUED TO
THE SCREEN.
YOU PUT OUT A FANTASTIC ARTICLE
IN SPORTS ILLUSTRATED.
I LIKED THE BODY COMP.
YOU TRY AND DO PLAYER COMPS,BUTO
WHO HIS BODY RESEMBLES AS AN
ATHLETE.
WE WILL GIVE YOU THAT AFTER THIS
PITCH TO GOMES.
JUST FOUL.
TOM: JUST MISSED.
SCOTT: WHO DOES HE LOOK LIKE?
TOM: IN TERMS OF THE WAY HIS
BODY MOVES -- LET'S SEE HOW FAR
THIS BALL WAS FOULED.
HOW ABOUT MICHAEL PHELPS?
BROAD SHOULDERS, THIN WAIST,
LONG LEVERS, AND HYPER MOBILE.
THAT IS WHAT OHTANI IS.
INCREDIBLY FLEXIBLE.
HE CAN DO THINGS WITH HIS
SHOULDER BLADES AND ARMS THAT
LOOKS LIKE IT WOULD HURT FOR A
NORMAL PERSON TO DO.
HE WAS A COMPETITIVE SWIMMER
GROWING UP.
I THINK HIS ABILITY TO BE SO
FLEXIBLE ON THE MOUND -- YOU
HAVE SEEN SOME OF HIS SLIDERS.
-- SOME OF HIS SLIDES ON THE
FIELD THIS YEAR HAVE BEEN
MATRIX-LIKE.
WHEN YOU WATCH OHTANI, YOU WON'T
SEE HIM ON THE MOUND IN THE NEXT
COUPLE DAYS, BUT WHEN HE
FINISHES THROWING UP PITCH, HIS
RIGHT HAND WILL CONTINUE SO FAR
ACROSS HIS BODY, HE WILL
ACTUALLY HAD HIMSELF IN THE LEFT
OBLIQUE, TOWARDS HIS BACK.
THAT IS CALLED DECELERATION.
PICTURES WITH GOOD DECELERATION,
LIKE A MARIANO RIVERA, THAT IS
THE WAY YOUR BODY MOVES, IT'S
NATURAL.
IT IS HARD TO TEACH.
IT IS LIKE YOUR BRAKE SYSTEM.
GUYS WITHOUT LONG DECELERATION
ARE PUTTING A TON OF FORCE AND
ENERGY ON THEIR SHOULDER.
OHTANI HAS THIS BEAUTIFUL, FLUID
MOTION.
BESIDES BEING REALLY GOOD, HE IS
REALLY EFFICIENT.
SCOTT: IF YOU ARE A LITTLE
LEAGUER, DON'T JUST WATCH SHOHEI
OHTANI AT THE PLATE, WATCH THE
MECHANICS AT THE MOUND.
TOM: THAT IS WHAT THE PITCHING
COACH TOLD ME.
HE HAS A 13-YEAR-OLD SON.
COPY THOSE MECHANICS.
HE SAID HIS MECHANICS ARE
BEAUTIFUL.
HE THROWS PRETTY.
I LIKE THAT LINE.
I USED TO SAY THAT ABOUT DWIGHT
GOODEN.
THE WAY HIS BODY MOVED THROUGH
THE SPACE REMINDED ME OF THOSE
CLIFF DIVERS IN ELKO POCO.
-- IN ACULPULCO.
OHTANI HAS THAT SAME KIND OF
FLUIDITY.
SCOTT: SWEET SWING?
SWEET DELIVERY.
AND HE DOES IT WITH A SMILE.
THAT IS UP THE MIDDLE.
CHAPMAN GOING TO THIRD.
NO THROW.
ANDT HE A'S -- AND THE A'S WILL
PUT THEM ON FIRST AND THIRD.
KHRIS DAVIS IS ON BASE FOR THE
SECOND TIME TONIGHT.
TOM: OHTANI IS ON THE COVER OF
SPORTS ILLUSTRATED THIS WEEK.
GREAT BASE RUNNING RIGHT HERE.
NO HESITATION BY CHAPMAN,
PUTTING PRESSURE ON MARSH AT
CENTER FIELD.
GETS THERE EASILY.
OHTANI IS ON THE COVER, AND HE'S
ON THE COVER TWICE.
HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY DO THAT?
TWO DIFFERENT COVERS, SAME
PLAYER.
TWO DIFFERENT DISCIPLINES,
RIGHT?
YOU ARE PUTTING TOGETHER A COVER
FOR OHTANI, DO YOU CHOOSE HIM AS
A PITCHER OR HITTER?
SCOTT: I CAN'T DECIDE.
TOM: EXACTLY, SO YOU DO BOTH.
SCOTT: THAT HIT TONY KEMP.
TOM: I GUESS SOMEHOW IT DIDN'T.
SCOTT: DID IT NOT?
TOM: SOMEHOW IT MISSED HIM.
HIT THE GROUND.
HIT SUZUKI, BUT IT DID NOT HIT
KEMP.
SCOTT: FOOLED ME.
FOULED OFF.
TOM: THERE YOU GO.
CHOOSE YOUR COVER.
DO YOU WANT SHOHEI THE HITTER?
YOU GOT HIM.
OR SHOHEI THE PITCHER.
YOU'VE GOT THAT TOO.
JUST BUY THEM BOTH.
SCOTT: ANYTHING SHOHEI OHTANI
RELATED IS THE HOTTEST ITEM IN
BASEBALL THESE DAYS.
THAT IS WHY, IF YOU ARE AN
EDITOR, YOU CAN'T DECIDE.
LET'S DO TWO COVERS.
TOM: IT IS HARD TO DECIDE WHICH
DISCIPLINE HE'S GOOD AT, BUT I
THINK HE IS GOOD AT BOTH BECAUSE
HE DOES BOTH.
IMAGINE IF HE DEVOTED HIMSELF TO
PITCHING, HE WOULD BE JACOB
DEGROM.
THIS IS WHAT HE CAME TO THE
STATES TO DO.
THIS IS HIS PASSION.
THE LINE I USED IN MY STORY IS,
WOULD YOU TELL SPRINGSTEEN TO
CHOOSE EITHER SONGWRITING OR
SINGING?
NO, THAT IS PART OF THEIR JOY.
OHTANI IS SO GOOD BECAUSE HE
ENJOYS DOING BOTH.
SCOTT: THERE IS A STRIKE TO
KEMP.
THAT WILL BE A FULL COUNT.
TOM: SUZUKI, NICE JOB OF
BRINGING IT BACK IN THE ZONE.
SCOTT: KEMP WALKED IN THE
SECOND.
HE WAS LEFT AT THIRD.
DAVIS AND CHAPMAN ARE ON.
A'S DOWN TWO.
PAYOFF.
THAT IS BALL FOUR.
LET'S KEEP IT UP WITH SHOHEI.
BRETT: YOU MENTIONED TIME
MAGAZINE AD SHOHEI IN THE 100
MOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE OF 2021.
HE WAS IN THE ICONS CATEGORY,
WHICH INCLUDES PRINCE HARRY AND
MEGAN MARKEL.
HE IS THE SECOND BASEBALL PLAYER
TO BE SELECTED ON THAT LIST.
IF YOU COLLECT OHTANI MAGAZINE
COVERS OR ARTICLES, I GUESS YOU
HAVE TO SET ASIDE A FEW EXTRA
DOLLARS THIS MONTH.
SCOTT: WELL SAID.
I DID COLLECT.
I WILL HAVE TO GRAB SOME COPIES.
TOM: OUT OF HOW MANY, SIX
ATHLETES ON THAT LIST.
ANOTHER MOUND VISIT, BY THE WAY.
I BELIEVE THIS IS AT-BAT NUMBER
SIX WITH THE BASES LOADED FOR
THE A'S?
WE ARE ONLY IN THE THIRD INNING.
SCOTT: THEY HAVE DONE IT IN EACH
FRAME.
THE FIRST AND THE SECOND ENDED
WITH THE BASES LOADED FOR
OAKLAND.
NOW IN THE THIRD, JOSH HARRISON.
THERE IS YOUR COUNT.
ONE REMAINING.
YOU CAN WATCH EVERY GAME IN A
SPORT THAT HAS 15 TONIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE SEEN ONE
WHERE THERE IS ONE LEFT IN THE
THIRD INNING.
HARRISON CONNECTS.
LAGARES IS GOING TO MAKE THE
CATCH.
CHAPMAN ON THE RUN.
HE IS IN THERE.
OH, AND A BAD THROW OVER FROM
THE MOUND WILL ENABLE THE A'S TO
STAY ALIVE.
KHRIS DAVIS WAS CAUGHT BETWEEN
SECOND AND THIRD, BUT TYLER
COULD NOT THROW HIM OUT.
THAT IS WALSH COMING OVER FROM
FIRST.
A'S GET A RUN, MAKE IT 4-3.
TOM: DAVIS IS MOVING UP TO
INFLUENCE THE CUTOFF.
HE WANTS WALSH TO CUT OFF THIS
BALL.
I THINK THE RUN WOULD'VE SCORED
ANYWAY, BUT WATCH WALSH.
HE DID NOT HAVE A GRIP ON IT.
DEFINITELY HAD DAVIS IN HIS
INSIGHTS IN THE ORDER AT THIRD
BASE, BUT LOST THE GRIP ON THE
TRANSFER.
SCOTT: A SLOPPY START.
THE A'S HAVE THREE ERRORS.
THAT IS A STRIKE TO STARLING
MARTE.
THAT TIES THE SEASON HIGH FOR
OAKLAND.
THEY ENTER THE GAME WITH A
SECOND FEWEST ERRORS IN
BASEBALL.
THAT IS NOT AN ERROR ON THE
ANGELS, BUT IT IS A MIS-PLAY.
IT KEEPS THE INNING ALIVE FOR
MARTE.
A BALL AND A STRIKE.
TOM: THAT IS THE KEY.
YEAH, IT IS NOT AN ERROR, BUT
YOU FORCE YOUR PITCHER TO
CONTINUE TO EXECUTE PITCHES WITH
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION WHEN
YOU SHOULD BE BACK TO THE
DUGOUT.
SCOTT: FOR YEARS, STARLING MARTE
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE HITTERS IN BASEBALL
-- AGGRESSIVE HITTERS IN
BASEBALL.
HE IS STILL AGGRESSIVE, BUT
TAKING SOME WALKS.
TOM: SELECTIVELY AGGRESSIVE.
SCOTT: CHOP SHOT TO THIRD FOR
MAYFIELD.
MARTE IS A DONE DEAL, AND SO ARE
THE A'S.
THEY GRAB A RUN IN THE THIRD.
SAC FLY FROM JOSH HARRISON.
4-3, MID THREE.
♪
>> SWINGS AND LINES A BASE HIT
OUT OF THE REACH OF CRONENWORTH.
THAT WILL SCORE ONE.
THAT WILL SCORE TWO.
JO ADELL BREAKS THE NO-HITTER.
ANGELS HAVE A 2-0 LEAD.
>> RENGIFO, SOLO SHOT.
3-0 HALOS.
>> HALO FANS LOVING THIS AT
PETCO PARK.
LUIS RENGIFO.
>> ADELL TO RIGHT FIELD AND WELL
HIT.
THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
A PAIR OF TWO RUN HOMERS IN THE
SEVENTH AND THE EIGHTH.
HASN'T THIS GOTTEN INTERESTING?
>> 2-0 TO RENGIFO.
SWINGS AT THAT ONE.
HE HITS IT WELL.
AND OUT OF HERE.
HOME RUN FOR RENGIFO, NUMBER
FOUR ON THE SEASON.
YOU ARE GOING TO WANT THAT
BASEBALL.
HIT THAT ONE OUT QUICKLY.
>> OHTANI NOW.
3-2 FASTBALL LINED TO RIGHT. AND
DEEP
AND GONE.
LIKE A BULLET, 44 IN THE BLINK
OF AN EYE.
>> HOME RUN FOR SHOHEI OHTANI.
>> AS A STARTING PITCHER.
SCOTT: JUST A REMINDER FOR OUR
YOUTUBE VIEWERS, BY CLICKING THE
GEAR ICON IN YOUR PLAYER AND
CHOOSE AUDIO TRACK, YOU HAVE THE
OPTION TO LISTEN TO THE ROAD
RADIO CALL OR THE JAPANESE
LANGUAGE COMMENTARY.
THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR YOU RIGHT
NOW.
WE ARE DOING THAT FOR THE FIRST
TIME TONIGHT IN THE JAPANESE
LANGUAGE COMMENTARY.
THE ANGELS GO IN THE SECOND,
EIGHT BATTERS, THREE HITS.
HOLD ON.
LET ME FIX MY GLASSES.
TWO SAC BUNTS AND TWO A'S
ERRORS.
TOM: A LITTLE BIT OF EVERYTHING.
SCOTT: NOW JARED WALSH, KURT
SUZUKI, AND LUIS RENGIFO DUE UP
IN THE THIRD.
TOM: THAT IS THE FASTBALL I'M
TALKING ABOUT WHEN I TALKED
ABOUT SPIN EFFICIENCY.
IT DOESN'T SPIN FAST.
VERY LOW SPIN.
YOU SAW THE VELO AT 89.
THE AVERAGE IS 93 FOR AN AVERAGE
FOUR-SEAMER.
HE HAS A WAY OF THROWING IT SO
IT'S GOT ACTIVE SPIN.
IF YOU THROW A FOUR-SEAM
FASTBALL, YOU WANT YOUR HAND
DIRECTLY BEHIND THE BASEBALL AND
SPIN IT NORTH POLE TO THE SOUTH
POLE, WITHOUT WOBBLE.
THAT IS ANOTHER ONE HE BEAT
WALSH ON.
HIS IS AT 98.7% SPIN EFFICIENCY.
HERE IS THE LOWEST.
FOUR-SEAMERS GENERALLY, YOU WANT
TO FIGHT GRAVITY.
YOU WANT THAT SUCKER TO SPIN AS
FAST AS IT CAN SO IT STAYS ABOVE
THE HITTER'S BARREL.
HE DOES NOT HAVE THAT, BUT IT IS
TRUE BACKSPIN, SO IT WORKS MUCH
BETTER HIGH IN THE ZONE THAN
LOW. TRIED TO DO IT RIGHT THERE
AND MISSED.
SCOTT: LEADOFF WALK FOR WALSH.
TOM: TYLER MAHLE OF THE REDS HAS
THE MOST EFFICIENT FOUR-SEAM
FASTBALL.
99.7% SPIN EFFICIENCY.
DOESN'T GUARANTEE THAT YOU GET
PEOPLE OUT.
KURT SUZUKI PROVED THAT HIS LAST
TIME UP.
HIT ONE OF THOSE NORTH-SOUTH
PASSED BALLS OUT WEST.
-- FASTBALLS OUT WEST.
SCOTT: HAMMERED IT TO LEFT.
HIS FIFTH OF THE YEAR.
AND THIS TIME HE IS WORKING WITH
A RUNNER ON.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
KURT SUZUKI.
389 FEET.
SOME GOOD LICK TO IT.
HIGH-FIVES ALL AROUND.
THAT WAS THE SPARK TO START THE
SECOND.
HE IS UP AGAIN IN THE THIRD.
THAT ONE IS ON A HOP.
THEY GET THE OUT AT SECOND.
SUPER EASY ON THE6-4-3 DOUBLE
PLAY.
THERE WAS A CHANCE FOR A MOMENT
IT WOULD GO INTO HARRISON'S
GLOVE ON THE FLY, BUT YOU DON'T
WANT THAT.
NICE SHORT HOP.
TOM: ESPECIALLY WITH THE CATCHER
RUNNING.
AN EASY SHORT HOP PICK.
AND THE LEADOFF RUNNER ERASED.
THE LEADOFF RUNNER HAS BEEN ON
IN FIVE OF THE SIX TURNS FOR THE
SE TEAMS SO FAR.
SCOTT: CHIME DEFENSIVE ALIGNMENT
FOR OAKLAND.
RENGIFO TAKES A STRIKE ON THE
OUTSIDE CORNER.
THIS IS A STRONG TEAM ON
DEFENSE.
COLE IRVIN PICKING UP THE PACE A
LITTLE BIT RIGHT NOW.
I LIKE IT.
TOM: I'M SURE THE INFIELDERS
APPRECIATE IT TOO.
A LOT OF TRAFFIC TONIGHT.
THAT WILL SLOW A PITCHER DOWN, A
ND RIGHTFULLY SO.
BUT THIS IS THE BEST GROOVE WE
HAVE SEEN HIM IN SO FAR EARLY IN
THIS GAME.
SCOTT: HE PITCHES AT A DECENT
PACE IN GENERAL, BUT HE'S PICKED
IT UP.
EVERY INNING HAS HAD A SLOWER
PACE TO IT TO START TODAY.
OF COURSE, THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF TRAFFIC.
SEVEN RUNS ALREADY.
THAT OVER/UNDER IS LOOKING
PRETTY CLEAR AT NINE.
WEAK.
MATT CHAPMAN CHARGING.
BAREHANDED.
HE GOT HIM.
OLSON WITH THE PICK.
SIDE RETIRED.
TOM: THAT IS AN AMAZING PLAY.
AND YES, HE IS OUT.
THAT IS SO DIFFICULT.
MATT CHAPMAN PULLED IT OFF.
THIS BALL IS STILL MOVING FAST
AND HE BAREHANDS IT CLEANLY.
HIS BUDDY HAS HIM COVERED ON THE
OTHER SIDE WITH THE PICK.
BEAUTIFUL.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> AND THAT ONE'S GOING TO GO!
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> OH, MY!
>> STRIKE THREE!
>> THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
>> TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: THREE, FOUR, FIVE COMING
THROUGH FOR OAKLAND IN THE
FOURTH.
I LOVE THIS QUESTION.
HOW BIG OF A CONTRACT WOULD YOU
OFFER OHTANI IF HE WAS A FREE
AGENT AFTER THIS SEASON?
THREE OPTIONS.
MY PERSONAL FAVORITE, BLANK
CHECK.
FIRST PITCH UP HIGH TO MATT
OLSON.
TOM: I LOVE IT.
SCOTT: OHTANI IS A FASCINATING
STORY BECAUSE IF HE WAITED TO
COME TO MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL
UNTIL AFTER THE 2019 SEASON, HE
COULD HAVE RECEIVED AN OPEN
MARKET OF DOLLARS.
TOM: HAS TRUE VALUE AS AN
INTERNATIONAL FREE AGENT.
BUT THERE WAS A CAP ON WHAT HE
COULD BE PAID AND THE BEAUTY OF
OHTANI IS HE DIDN'T CARE.
IT WAS HIS DREAM TO COME OVER
HERE AND PLAY, NOT TO MAXIMIZE
HIS MONETARY LEVERAGE.
GOT TO RESPECT THAT.
SCOTT: LOVES THE GAME.
2-1 TO OLSON.
TOM: YOU'RE GOING BLANK CHECK?
SCOTT: YEAH, I THINK THAT MEANS
400 PLUS.
TOM: THAT IS HIS VALUE, OVER
400, NO DOUBT.
SCOTT: IT IS.
BEST PLAYER IN THE SPORT.
FACE OF THE SPORT AT THE MOMENT
TOM: JUST WORK OFF THE CONTRACTS
SIGNED BY TATIS JR., FRANCISCO
LINDOR, TROUT.
I THINK HE'S GOT MORE VALUE
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE DOES WITH
PITCHING AND HITTING AND HE'S
THE BIGGEST DRAW IN THE GAME, AS
WELL.
SCOTT: OLSON IN THE AIR, AS
USUAL.
ONE AWAY.
LET'S STACK IT UP.
MAYBE BEFORE YOU MAKE YOUR
DECISION.
TOM: LET'S DO OUR HOMEWORK.
SCOTT: BRYCE HARPER -- BETTS,
365 FOR 12.
THE GREAT MIKE TROUT, 426 OVER
12 AND I THINK OHTANI WOULD
SMASH ALL OF THOSE.
SO WHAT'S THE NUMBER?
HALF A BILL?
ANGELS FANS, DEEP BREATH.
THIS IS JUST FOR FUN.
TOM: IN A COUPLE OF YEARS,
THOUGH, THAT DAY IS COMING.
STRIKE ON THE CORNER TO CANHA.
TOM: THAT'S WHY I THINK YOU'LL
SEE THE ANGELS REINVEST IN THIS
TEAM, SCOTT.
THERE'S NO REBUILDING WHEN YOU
HAVE OHTANI AND TROUT ON YOUR
TEAM.
IT'S ALWAYS WIN-NOW.
SCOTT: BOTH IN THEIR PRIME.
SO I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE A
MAJOR PLAYER IN THE FREE AGENT
MARKET THIS WINTER.
THEY DID THAT A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, ANTHONY RENDON, BIG-MONEY
SIGNING.
RENDON HAS BEEN MISSING MOST OF
THE SEASON AND OHTANI IS KIND OF
LONELY IN THE LINEUP.
BUT HELP IS ON THE WAY NEXT YEAR
WHEN THE SUPERSTARS GET HEALTHY.
HE ACTUALLY NEEDS HELP IN HIS
ROTATION.
LEFT SIDE, RENGIFO.
TWO GONE FOR PINDER.
LET'S GO DOWN TO BRETT.
BRETT: SHOHEI'S HOME TOWN HAS A
POPULATION OF 100,000 IN JAKE
PEAVY, OSHU CITY.
THEY HAVE A CHEER SQUAD AND ON
THE 17TH OF EVERY MONTH, LIKE
TODAY, IS OHTANI DAY.
THAT'S THE CITY COUNCIL, THEY
WEAR THEIR ANGELS GEAR EVEN WHEN
THEY VOTE.
THERE WAS EVEN A REP
REPLICD
THEY HAVE IN TOWN.
A LOT OF THE GAMES HAPPEN IN THE
MORNING WHEN PEOPLE ARE WORKING.
AT CITY HALL, THEY HAVE A
MONITOR FOR PEOPLE TO WATCH.
SCOTT, YOU LIKE TO SAY WE HAVE A
WORLDWIDE AUDIENCE AND THAT'S
TRUE.
SCOTT: HAPPY SEPTEMBER 17.
TOM: GREAT REPORT.
THERE'S THE RICE FIELD.
THERE'S THE GOLDEN HAND.
A FACSIMILE OF OHTANI'S HAND.
SCOTT: PINDER TO CENTER.
MARSH BACKING UP.
TOM: REMINDS ME OF LINCOLN,
NEBRASKA, EVERYBODY IS WEARING
RED.
SCOTT: GOOD MORNING TO EVERYONE
WATCHING IN JAPAN.
>> MY DAD WAS A CAR SALESMAN SO
HE HAD THAT PERSONALITY.
>> HIS FATHER PASSED AWAY IN
2013 BUT NOT BEFORE PASSING ON
HIS LOVE FOR BEING A GOOFBALL.
WALSH IS THE LIFE OF THE PARTY,
IN PART BECAUSE HE WASN'T SURE
HE'D EVER BE INVITED.
HE WAS A 39TH-ROUND DRAFT PICK
WHO MADE IT TO THE MAJORS AS A
TWO-WAY PLAYER AND HAS A BIG
LEAGUE E.R.A. OF 1.80.
>> I HAVE LIKE NINE WALKS PER
NINE SO THAT WAS PROBABLY GOING
TO COME BACK TO REALITY AT SOME
POINT.
>> FOR WALSH, BASEBALL WAS
ALWAYS THE DREAM AND THOUGH HE
MAY HAVE HAD DOUBTS, HE'S NOT
SURE HIS DAD EVER DID.
>> NOT IN AN ARROGANT WAY BUT HE
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE SAID, YEAH,
I KNEW IT ALL ALONG.
HE WAS MORE CONFIDENT IN ME I
THINK THAN I WAS.
SCOTT: WE'RE IN THE HOME FOURTH.
ANGELS UP A RUN.
72 WINS, 74 LOSSES ON THE
SEASON.
THEY ACTUALLY JUST TOOK THE LAST
TWO IN A SERIES AGAINST THE
WHITE SOX, THE BEST TEAM IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE CENTRAL.
NOW THEY'RE TRYING TO PLAY
SPOILER AGAINST AN OAKLAND A'S
TEAM THAT'S IN A FIGHT FOR A
WILD CARD.
A'S ENTERING THE NIGHT THREE
GAMES BACK OF THE WILD CARD
SEAT.
WE START WITH JACK MAYFIELD.
IT'S IN TIGHT.
MAYFIELD WITH A BASE HIT IN THE
SECOND.
HE EVENTUALLY SCORED.
MORE FROM COLE IRVIN.
ONLY HAD 51 PITCHES.
THE A'S WOULD LOVE SOME LENGTH.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN USED QUITE
A BIT LATELY.
WE'RE ALSO COMING OFF A
SHORTENED SEASON AND THERE ARE
SOME PITCHERS WEARING DOWN.
PULLED LEFT SIDE FOUL.
TOM: BUT HIS HOME, RIGHT HERE,
ANGELS STADIUM.
COULD YOU IMAGINE, IN HIGH
SCHOOL, HE WAS WORKING ON THE
GROUNDS CREW FOR THE ANGELS.
RAKING THE FIELD BETWEEN
INNINGS.
TWO SUMMERS HE DID THAT JOB AND
NOW HE'S PITCHING IN ANGELS
STADIUM 10 MILES FROM WHERE HE
GREW UP.
SCOTT: WHEN HE WAS WORKING, HIS
SEAT WAS BEHIND CENTER FIELD
BACK AT THE WALL THERE.
TOM: BEAUTIFUL BACKDROP.
SCOTT: AND IT WAS ALL WORK UNTIL
IT WAS TIME FOR HIM TO WORK THE
FIELD EVERY FEW INNINGS.
AND THAT IS LIFTED TO LEFT.
WHO'S GOT IT?
NOBODY.
JACK MAYFIELD WITH A LEADOFF
DOUBLE THAT WAS IN THE AIR
FOREVER.
TOM: COVERED AS IF HE WERE A
LEFT-HANDED PULL HITTER.
THERE'S CANHA.
HE HAD A LONG RUN SHADED TOWARDS
LEFT CENTER FIELD.
YOU SEE WHERE THE DEFENSE IS
THERE.
PLAYING IN LIKE A LEFT-HANDED
HITTER.
AS LONG AS THAT BALL WAS UP
THERE, NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR CANHA
TO COVER ALL THAT GROUND.
SCOTT: SIX SECONDS IN THE AIR.
TOM: THAT'S A GOOD NFL PUNT.
REALLY GOOD HANG TIME.
SCOTT: THERE ARE NOT MANY SPOTS
YOU CAN FIND ON A BIG LEAGUE
FIELD WHERE THE BASEBALL IS IN
THE AIR FOR SIX SECONDS AND IT
TURNS INTO A HIT.
USUALLY THAT MEANS IT'S MAYBE
OVER THE WALL.
TOM: I'M TOLD THAT'S A 3% HIT
PROBABILITY, BALL IN THE AIR FOR
SIX SECONDS.
SCOTT: CHANCE FOR JUAN LAGARES
TO CAPITALIZE.
0-2.
LAGARES IS RUNG UP.
TOM: HE CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
I DON'T BLAME HIM.
SCOTT: THAT'S A HEAD SHAKIER.
FIRST PUNCH-OUT OF THE NIGHT FOR
COLE IRVIN.
TOM: HAVEN'T SEEN MANY FASTBALLS
IN FOR RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS FROM
IRVIN.
THAT WAS ONE.
GIVE CREDIT TO YAN GOMES.
WHO SAYS THE WAY YOU CATCH THE
BALL DOESN'T MATTER?
IT SURE DOES.
SCOTT: FRAMING 101.
TOP OF THE LINEUP, IT'S MARSH.
TOM: I ALWAYS THOUGHT THE KEY TO
FRAMING IS MOVING THE HAND AS
YOU'RE CATCHING THE BALL INTO
THE ZONE AND NOT A LOT.
YOU SEE A LOT OF CATCHERS WHO
WILL CATCH AND THEN PULL THE
BALL IN.
IT IS A SUBTLE ART, SOFT HANDS.
JOB NUMBER ONE, MAKE SURE THE
STRIKES ARE KEPT STRIKES.
JOB NUMBER TWO, TRY TO STEAL A
FEW.
YAN GOMES STOLE THAT ONE.
SCOTT: WHEN YOU'RE LEARNING THE
TOOLS OF IGNORANCE, THE CATCHING
POSITION, YOU DON'T EXPECT TO
HEAR THE WORD "ART," BUT THAT'S
WHAT YOU NEED BEHIND THE PLATE.
TOM: I'D LIKE TO MEET THE GUY
WHO CAME UP WITH THAT PHRASE,
"TOOLS OF IGNORANCE."
ONE OF THE SMARTEST GUYS ON THE
FIELD, ESPECIALLY IN TODAY'S
GAME.
WITH WHAT WE ASK OF CATCHERS, TO
BREAK DOWN ALL THE OTHER HITTERS
ON THE TEAM, CALL THE GAME BACK
THERE, WORK THE UMPIRES --
THAT'S AN ART IN AND OF ITSELF.
AND BY THE WAY, TAKE CARE OF THE
OFFENSIVE GAME.
SCOTT: IF YOU'RE FEELING
ATHLETIC, YOU'RE IN GREAT SHAPE.
TRY SQUATTING AND WATCHING THIS
ENTIRE GAME, THEN GET UP, TELL
ME HOW YOUR KNEES FEEL.
DO THAT 100 TIMES A YEAR.
MARSH TO LEFT, CANHA WINDS IT
UP.
TWO DOWN IN THE FOURTH.
THAT'S WHY WHAT SALVADOR PEREZ
IS DOING THIS SEASON IS
INCREDIBLE, GETTING BETTER AS
THE SEASON GOES ON.
MANY CATCHERS WEAR DOWN
OFFENSIVELY OVER THE COURSE OF A
162-GAME CAMPAIGN.
TOM: HAD A YEAR OFF IN 2019.
SCOTT: TOMMY JOHN SURGERY.
TOM: GIVE YOUR CATCHER A
VACATION YEAR EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE AND THEY'RE ALL GOOD.
SCOTT: TWO SINGLES FOR DAVID
FLETCHER.
ONE TURNED INTO TWO R.B.I.'S.
HE LOVES A'S PITCHING THIS YEAR.
NICE PITCH FROM IRVIN, WORKING
THE CORNERS.
TOM: YOU'RE FLETCHER, YOU KNOW
WHO'S BEHIND YOU.
OHTANI IS ON DECK.
FIRST BASE IS OPEN.
THERE'S TWO OUTS.
COLE IRVIN IS COMING AFTER YOU.
LINEUP CONSTRUCTION MATTERS A
LOT, FOLKS.
BOTH WHO'S IN FRONT AND WHO'S
BEHIND.
SCOTT: THAT'S 0-2.
ALTHOUGH DAVID FLETCHER IS A MAN
WHO CAN HANDLE THE BAT WITH TWO
STRIKES IN HIS CAREER.
THERE'S HIS LINE AGAINST THE A'S
THIS YEAR.
SUCH A DIFFERENT LOOK FROM TWO
TO THREE.
LOWEST EXIT VELOCITY OFF THE
BAT, DAVID FLETCHER.
OH, AND THEN OHTANI ON DECK.
HE COULD NOT GET HIM.
THE BALLS HAVE GONE TOWARDS THE
FEET TONIGHT.
TOM: YEAH, LOTS.
WE MENTIONED FLETCHER IS
HYPERAGGRESSION BUT HE'S NOT
GOING TO CHASE THAT ONE.
YOU MENTIONED HIS LOW EXIT VELO.
REMINDS ME A LITTLE BIT OF JETER
AND ICHIRO.
THOSE GUYS GOT SO MANY HITS BY
HITTING THE BALL WEAKLY, JUST
PUTTING IT IN PLAY.
THAT'S PART OF HIS GAME.
SCOTT: FLETCHER'S GUY GROWING UP
WAS DAVID ECKSTEIN.
TOM: 0-2, IN THE GLOVE.
SCOTT: AND THAT WILL DO IT.
FLETCHER DOWN ON STRIKES.
A'S DOWN A RUN AFTER FOUR.
♪
>> BOTTOM OF THE NINTH INNING AT
COORS FIELD IN DENVER AND WHAT
SO FAR HAS HAPPENED IS WHAT MOST
BASEBALL PEOPLE FELT COULD NOT
POSSIBLY HAPPEN, THAT ANYONE
COULD COME INTO THIS HAVEN FOR
HOME RUNS, NIGHTMARE ALLEY, AND
HOLD THE ROCKIES TO NO HITS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HIDEO NOMO
HAS DONE THREW EIGHT INNINGS.
FASTBALL HIT TO DESHIELDS.
ONE AWAY.
GROUND BALL TO DESHIELDS.
HE IS ONE OUT AWAY AND ALEX
BURKE IS STANDING IN NOMO'S WAY
OF A NO-HITTER.
HIDEO NOMO HAS DONE WHAT THEY
SAID COULD NOT BE DONE.
HE HAS NOT ONLY SHUT OUT THE
ROCKIES, HE HAS PITCHED A
NO-HITTER AND THANK GOODNESS
THEY SAW IT IN JAPAN!
>> WHAT?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THAT WAS DISGUSTING.
SCOTT: JOHN MANAEA IS MIC'D UP
FOR US ON YOUTUBE.
THAT'S MY DREAM.
I WISH AS THE PLAY-BY-PLAY MAN I
COULD DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT
WHEN I SEE A PLAY LIKE THAT.
"WHAT!
THAT WAS DISGUSTING!"
GO TO BREAK.
TOM: I'M JUST GLAD THAT THOSE
GUYS WHO GET TO WATCH MATT EVERY
DAY ARE STILL AMAZED.
DON'T TAKE THAT FOR GRANTED.
THAT WAS DISGUSTING.
SCOTT: HE LEADS OFF THE INNING.
TOP FIVE, A'S DOWN A RUN.
MATT CHAPMAN IS THE BEST IN THE
BIZ AT THE HOT CORNER.
FAIR TO SAY THAT?
TOM: YOU GOT NOLAN ARENADO WHO'S
RIGHT THERE WITH HIM.
I WILL SAY THIS.
MATT CHAPMAN REVOLUTIONIZED THE
THIRD BASE POSITION.
PLAYS THE DEEPEST THIRD BASE IN
BASEBALL AND THE GAME NOW HAS
BECOME A GAME, YOU CAN SEE WHERE
MAYFIELD IS PLAYING IN, THIRD
BASE, A GAME WHERE THIRD BASE IS
ABOUT RANGE, IT'S NOT A
STEP-AND-DIVE PLAY AND NUMBERS
SHOW, THAT THAT POSITION, SINCE
MATT CHAPMAN GOT TO THE BIG
LEAGUES, ON AVERAGE, HAS MOVED
ABOUT SIX OR SEVEN FEET DEEPER.
AS MATT WILL TELL YOU, IT'S ALL
ABOUT HOW DEEP YOU CAN PLAY
DEPENDING ON YOUR ARM STRENGTH.
OBVIOUSLY, THE BETTER ARM THAT
YOU HAVE, THE DEEPER YOU CAN
PLAY.
BUT HE'S ALSO GREAT AT COMING IN
ON TOP OF BALLS.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT,
TOO, IF YOU PLAY SO DEEP.
SCOTT: 2-2 TO CHAPMAN.
WHEN HE WAS DRAFTED, HIS FRIEND
MATT OLSON WAS HANGING OUT WITH
GUYS WATCHING THE DRAFT
INTERVIEW AND CHAPMAN SAID, "I'M
GOING TO CHANGE THE GAME ON
DEFENSE."
AND THEY WERE LIKE, CHILL.
LIKE YOU'RE SAYING, HE REALLY
HAS.
HE'S CHANGED THE POSITION.
TOM: IT'S STANDARD PROCEDURE
NOW.
I REALIZE THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
GUYS THAT ALSO PRESENT THE
THREAT OF A BUNT WHERE YOU CAN
PLAY THAT DEEP BUT EVERYWHERE
YOU LOOK AROUND BASEBALL, EVEN
GUYS WITH JUST AVERAGE ARMS,
THEY'RE PLAYING THE POSITION
MUCH DEEPER THAN THEY USED TO.
HE STARTED IT.
AND I THINK HE AND ARENADO ARE
THE TWO EXECUTING IT.
TAKES THE WALK RIGHT THERE.
REMINDS ME OF BILLY BEANE,
PRESIDENT OF THE A'S, WHO SAID
WHEN YOU PLAY THIRD BASE FOR
OAKLAND, IN THAT BALLPARK, WITH
ALL THAT FOUL TERRITORY, YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THE RANGE OF AN
OUTFIELDER, AS WELL, AND HE
DOES.
WE SAW HIM MAKE THE CATCH
EARLIER IN THE GAME, RUNNING
DOWN THE BALL IN LEFT CENTER
FIELD, PLAYING SHORTSTOP
ESSENTIALLY IN THE SHIFT OR LEFT
FIELD DOWN THE LINE.
THERE'S SO MUCH FOUL TERRITORY
THAT YOU NEED RANGE TO TRACK
DOWN POP-UPS AND I THINK IN
TERMS OF THAT, HE'S THE BEST IN
BASEBALL, RUNNING DOWN POP-UPS.
SCOTT: HE IS IN THE IDEAL
BALLPARK, YOU'RE RIGHT.
HE'S ON FOR YAN GOMES.
DOWN LOW FROM TYLER.
MORE FROM KYLE TYLER, IN RELIEF
FOR JHONATHAN DIAZ WHO MADE HIS
MLB DEBUT.
GOMES IS 1-2 WITH AN INFIELD
SINGLE IN THE SECOND.
AND HE'S GOING TO RIGHT.
LAGARES FOR OUT NUMBER ONE.
HERE COMES CHRIS DAVIS AND
S
DAVIS AND WE GO TO BRETT.
BRETT: DAVIS SAID HE WAS MORE
EXCITED FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
THAN FOR HIS MAJOR LEAGUE DEBUT.
MATT CHAPMAN CAMPAIGNED FOR HIS
RETURN, CALLED HIM UP AND SAID
GET YOUR REAR END OFF THE COUCH
AND HELP US.
HE HAD A COUPLE OF HOME RUNS IN
TEXAS.
AT ONE POINT IN TRIPLE-A HE
HOMERED IN SIX STRAIGHT GAMES SO
MAYBE THERE'S A LOT LEFT IN THE
TANK AND WHO SAYS YOU CAN'T GO
HOME AGAIN.
SCOTT: NOT ME.
KHRIS DAVIS LOVES OAKLAND AND
PLAYING FOR THE A'S AS MUCH AS
ANY PLAYER I'VE HEARD FROM.
LOOK AT THE LAST FOUR YEARS AS
PRODUCTION HAS TAILED OFF SINCE
LEADING THE LEAGUE IN HOMERS
WITH 48 IN 2018.
THAT IS A FOUL BALL.
TOM: WHEN HE CAME BACK TO THE
TEAM, THEY WERE ALL HAPPY TO SEE
HIM AGAIN.
HE'S A GREAT CLUBHOUSE
INFLUENCER AND I LIKE THE FACT
THAT HE CAN PINCH-HIT JED
LOWRIE.
KHRIS DAVIS IS COOL WITH IT AT
THIS POINT IN HIS CAREER.
SCOTT: HE'S AN EASY-GOING GUY IN
A GOOD WAY.
TOM: YOU CAN TELL BY THE WAY HE
STANDS IN THE BATTER'S BOX,
LOOKS LIKE HE'S WAITING FOR A
BUS.
QUIET AND RELAXED.
SCOTT: HE'S TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THE A'S ORGANIZATION
LETS HIM BE HIMSELF.
TOM: A TREMENDOUS FASTBALL
HITTER.
DON'T LET THE EASY LOOK IN THE
BOX FOOL YOU.
VERY FAST HANDS.
SCOTT: THAT WAS A UNIQUE DEAL
THAT BROUGHT ELVIS ANDRUS OVER
TO OAKLAND.
DAVIS, CUT BY THE RANGERS IN
JUNE.
ANDRUS HAS BEEN THE STARTING
SHORTSTOP FOR THE A'S FOR THE
ENTIRE SEASON.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO HEAD TO
THE SEATS AND IT DOES.
EIGHT ROWS BACK.
TO BE FAIR, KHRIS DAVIS IS
PRETTY CONSISTENT, STAYING ON
THE FIELD FOR YEARS AND THEN THE
HIP INJURY REALLY HELD HIM BACK
A COUPLE OF SEASONS AGO AND THEN
EVEN THIS YEAR, LATE IN SPRING
TRAINING, HE SUFFERED A GRADE
TWO LEFT QUAD STRAIN AND MISSED
THE BEGINNING OF THE SEASON.
THAT IS FAIR?
SINGLE IN THE SCORE BOOK.
KHRIS DAVIS HAS IT.
MAYBE FOULED OFF HIS FOOT?
TOM: I WANT TO KNOW THE EXIT
VELO ON THAT HIT.
SCOTT: THAT'S AS LIGHT AS IT
GETS.
TOM: PROBABLY IN THE 40'S, I
WOULD WANT TO SAY.
SCOTT: A WHISPER OFF THE BAT.
TOM: RIGHT OFF THE END OF THE
BAT, BREAKING BALL.
IT'S VERY RARE TO SEE A BASEBALL
STOPPED ON THE FIELD.
IT REALLY IS.
IT'S USUALLY NEVER GOOD FOR THE
DEFENSIVE TEAM.
THAT'S THE CASE RIGHT HERE.
THAT'S A KNOCK.
TO SEE A BASEBALL SITTING IDLE
ON A BASEBALL FIELD IN PLAY,
IT'S RARE, BUT IT JUST HAPPENED.
SCOTT: 53.5 MILES AN HOUR OFF
THE BAT.
KHRIS DAVIS IS ON, SO IS CHAPMAN
AND A NEW PITCHER IS COMING UP.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE ARE SO EXCITED
TO SEE THIS YOUNG MAN.
19 YEARS OLD.
>> LANDED IN L.A. AT, LIKE,
6:30, QUARTER TO 7:00, AND WE
TAKE A CAB TO ANAHEIM, AN HOUR
AWAY.
RUSH HOUR.
>> HERE HE IS, CENTER FIELDER
MIKE TROUT, HIS MAJOR LEAGUE
DEBUT TONIGHT.
>> WE HAD TRAFFIC TO GET TO
ANAHEIM.
WE DO NOT GET TO THE STADIUM
UNTIL THE SIXTH OR SEVENTH
INNING AND.
>> WE ARE RUNNING, RUNNING.
>> HERE'S THE KILLER.
MOM SAYS, MIKE, LEAVE US FOUR
TICKETS, WE'LL GET THERE.
HE DOESN'T LEAVE US TICKETS.
>> WE'LL BUY TICKETS, GIVE US A
TICKET SOMEWHERE.
>> WE FINALLY GET IN THE
STADIUM, IT'S THE TOP OF THE
EIGHTH INNING AND A BALL IS HIT
TO CENTER.
>> THIS ONE OUT TOWARD RIGHT
STRISMT AND WE JUST SAT DOWN.
>> MIKE TROUT GIVING CHASE.
LONG RUN BY TROUT.
HE RUNS IT DOWN!
OH, MAN!
WHAT A PLAY BY MIKE TROUT!
>> MIKE MADE THAT UNBELIEVABLE
CATCH OUT IN THE OUTFIELD.
>> HOLY SMOKES!
WHAT A CATCH BY THE KID.
TOM: ALL SEASON LONG WE'VE GIVEN
OUR VIEWERS THE POWER TO VOTE
WHICH STANDOUT PERFORMER WILL
RECEIVE THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME TROPHY.
STAY TUNED LATER IN THE GAME AS
WE'LL HAND OUT HARDWARE IN THE
POSTGAME SHOW AFTER THE END OF
THE GAME.
CAN'T WAIT FOR THAT.
I LOVE ACTUAL HARDWARE.
SCOTT: SO DO PLAYERS.
TOM: IT'S ONE THING TO GET AN
AWARD BUT WHEN THERE'S AN ACTUAL
TROPHY, DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE
5 YEARS OLD OR 25.
SCOTT: YOU ARE ON THE MONEY.
A LOT OF PLAYERS THAT HAVE
RECEIVED THAT TROPHY WITH THEIR
NAME ON IT, IT BREAKS UP THE
SEASON IN A POSITIVE WAY.
IT'S THIS DAY THAT'S SPECIAL AND
STANDS OUT.
TOM: THAT AND FREE T-SHIRTS
WHICH WAS THE KEY TO STARTING
THE NEW YORK CITY MARATHON.
GIVE AWAY FREE T-SHIRTS, I'M
THERE, SIGN ME UP.
SCOTT: THAT'S ALL IT
IT TAKE?
HOW MANY MILES IS THAT?
TOM: 26.2.
SCOTT: AND QUIJADA.
DOWN THE THIRD BASE LINE.
TOM: I WISH I COULD HIT MY
PITCHING WEDGE LIKE HE HIT THAT
BASE HIT.
SO QUIET OFF THE BAT.
SHOULD BE A CHALLENGE FASTBALL
RIGHT HERE.
IT WAS AND KEMP DIDN'T GET IT
HE'S A GUY, WHEN HE'S BEHIND IN
THE COUNT, HE'LL LOCK IN ON
THAT.
HE'LL LOCK IN ON THAT.
SCOTT: HIS THIRD BIG LEAGUE
SEASON.
HE'S 25 YEARS OLD.
MISSING DOWN.
QUIJADA POPPED UP ON WEDNESDAY,
GAVE THE TEAM TWO OUTS H.NOTHING
AGAINST HIM, STRIKEOUT AND A
WALK, A COUPLE OF DAYS BACK.
THAT'S A STRIKE.
FAVORABLE CALL FOR QUIJADA.
TOM: I THINK WE'D ALL LIKE TO
SEE THE PACE OF GAME PICK UP A
LITTLE BIT.
HOW ABOUT WE JUST START TONY
KEMP WITH A 3-2 COUNT?
HE'S GOING TO GET LET IT ANYWAY.
SCOTT: IN THE NINE SPOT.
IT'S LIKE A MARATHON IN THAT
IT'S THE TOP OF THE ORDER.
TOM: THIS IS NOT AN AREA WHERE
YOU CAN FLY QUICKLY TO GET TO
THE TOP.
YOU HAVE TO WORK THROUGH KEMP.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS.
AGAIN, THE A'S HAVE THE BAGS
FULL.
LET'S FINISH THIS OUT.
WHERE'S THE MONEY GOING FOR
SHOHEI?
$300 TO $400.
TOM: I'M SURPRISED.
SCOTT: YOUTUBE VIEWERS GETTING
STINGY ON US.
OPEN UP THE CHECKBOOKS.
TOM: HE CAN'T BELIEVE IT
HIMSELF.
WHAT?
SCOTT: HE'S LAUGHING.
I THINK IF THAT'S WHERE YOUR
HEAD IS AT MONEY-WISE, YOU'RE
NOT LANDING SHOHEI OHTANI IF
HE'S A FREE AGENT AFTER THIS
SEASON.
YOU NEED TO THINK BIGGER.
TOM: YET ANOTHER BASES-LOADED
AT-BAT.
WE HAVE TO FIND OUT WHAT THE
RECORD IS.
SCOTT: LEADOFF MAN JOSH
HARRISON.
TOM: HARD TO BELIEVE TO THIS
POINT OAKLAND IS STILL TRAILING
IN THIS GAME DECIDE ALL THE
RUNNERS ON BASE.
SCOTT: HEY, SNEAK THIS IN.
CREDIT TO MY FRIEND ON ANGELS
PREGAME ON THE RADIO.
SHOHEI OHTANI WILL START ON
SUNDAY.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT MELVIN
EARLIER AND WE SAID AT LEAST WE
MISSED TAKENY IN
OHTA.
TOM: GOOD TO KNOW BECAUSE JOE
MADDON TOLD US HE WOULD BE OK IF
OHTANI WAS SORE AND DIDN'T TAKE
THE MOUND AGAIN THIS YEAR BUT AS
HE TOLD US, THEY'RE TAKING THEIR
CUE'S FROM OHTANI AND I THINK HE
WANTS TO GET TO A 10TH WIN.
HE'S AT NINE NOW.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS IF HE FEELS
GOOD AND WANTS TO PITCH, YOU LET
HIM PITCH.
SCOTT: HARRISON STAYS ALIVE.
SUZUKI DIDN'T KEEP IT ALIVE.
GOT HIM IN THE GLOVE.
TOM: GOT HIM IN THE CHEST.
HE'S TAKEN A FEW HITS TODAY.
SCOTT: HE'S ADJUSTING HIS
FINGERS A BIT.
TOM: JOSH HAS THAT LONG SWING,
FOLLOWTHROUGH.
GOT HIM ON THE WRIST, FOREARM
AREA.
SCOTT: 1-2 TO HARRISON.
UP THE MIDDLE.
THE A'S WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO
ANYTHING WITH THE BASES LOADED
YET AGAIN.
RENGIFO HOOKING UP WITH
FLETCHER.
LOOK AT THE TURN.
OH, WOW.
TOM: WHAT A PIVOT BY FLETCHER.
BACK TO FIRST.
WHEELS AND FIRES.
♪
>> HANG ON TO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS OUTTA HERE!
>> DEEP TO RIGHT AND THAT BABY
IS GONE.
BROWN WALKS OFF THE RAYS!
>> TWO HITS WITH AN R.B.I.
>> THAT BABY IS GONE, LOWRIE HAS
WALKED IT OFF!
WHAT A WAY TO START THE SECOND
HALF.
>> MARTE, A CHANCE TO BE THE
HERO.
TWO ON, NOBODY OUT.
A'S TRYING TO WALK IT OFF.
MARTE DRIVES ONE TO LEFT.
DEEP LEFT AND THAT BABY IS GONE!
♪
>> COLE SWIRVING, IRVIN.
YOU HAVE A YOUTUBE CHANNEL
STARTING IN OCTOBER, IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: MANAEA MIC'D UP, COLE
IRVIN AND HIS YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
GET OVER THERE, I JUST
SUBSCRIBED.
SHOHEI OHTANI TO LEAD OFF THE
FRAME FOR THE ANGELS.
STILL UP A RUN, IN THE HOME
FIFTH.
IN THE AIR.
THAT ONIA HANGING
-- ONP
FOR A WHILE.
CANHA HAS OUT NUMBER ONE.
TOM: CONOF
CAN OF CORN.
SCOTT: THERE WAS AN EARTHQUAKE
REGISTERED 25 MILES FROM ANGELS
STADIUM.
IT WAS IN CARSON, CALIFORNIA.
I DIDN'T FEEL A THING.
YOU?
TOM: MAYBE THAT WAS SUZUKI'S
HOME RUN.
I FELT SOMETHING THEN.
NO, I DIDN'T, ACTUALLY.
THAT'S A PRETTY BIG NUMBER ON
THE RICHTER SCALE, NO?
I'M SURE A LOT OF PEOPLE FELT
IT.
WE JUST DIDN'T UP HERE, RIGHT?
SCOTT: APPARENTLY SIX, SEVEN,
EIGHT, THAT'S A BIG NUMBER.
TOM: BUT FOUR IS SOMETHING.
HOW MANY MILES AWAY?
SCOTT: 25-ISH.
NOT AN EXPERT ON THE TOPIC,
ADMITTEDLY.
2-1 TO GOSSELIN.
RIGHT SIDE.
PINDER.
THERE YOU GO.
THE JAPANESE LANGUAGE COMMENTARY
OF SHOHEI OHTANI'S LAST AT-BAT
SOUNDS LIKE THIS.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SCOTT: ISHIGURA, PLAY-BY-PLAY,
AN OPTION.
THIS IS WALSH.
HE'S 0-1 WITH A WALK.
WE MOSTLY WATCHING BASEBALL IN
THE EVENINGS.
SOME AFTERNOON GAMES, AS WELL,
OF COURSE.
BUT IN JAPAN, IT'S BREAKFAST AND
SHOHEI.
WALSH ON A FEW HOPS.
HARRISON TAKES CARE OF IT.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN IN THE
FIFTH.
COLE IRVIN.
>> THIS ONE IS OUTTA HERE!
>> TIANNA CRUSHES IT TO LEFT
FIELD.
THIS ONE IS GONE!
>> WOW!
>> MUST-SEE TV EVERY MINUTE OF
EVERY DAY, SHOHEI OHTANI!
>> OHTANI GOT IT, HE GOT IT!
NUMBER 40!
A FRANCHISE RECORD FOR
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS, 3-1, HALOS!
>> SEVEN INCREDIBLE INNINGS ON
THE MOUND AND HE SMASHES THE
BASEBALL A MILE!
>> SHOWER UP, START THE LIMO.
HERE WE GO.
>> DID HE GET IT?
DID HE GET IT?
HE DID!
WOW!
SHOHEI OHTANI FIRST PITCH HOME
RUN NUMBER 43!
IT IS SHO-TIME!
>> SHOHEI THE MONEY, THREE-RUN
SHOT.
♪
SCOTT: GRAB YOUR POPCORN, FOLKS.
WE HAVE "ANGELS IN THE OUTFIELD"
AND WE HAVE THE A'S AND THE
ANGELS, THINKING ABOUT OTHER
CLASSIC TITLES LIKE "MAJOR
LEAGUE" AND "FIELD OF DREAMS," A
TRUE CLASSIC.
OUR NEXT YOUTUBE POLL QUESTION
ASKS YOU WHICH IS YOUR FAVORITE
OF THE FOUR.
VOTE NOW.
EASY TO DO.
IT'S POSTED ON YOUR COMPUTER
SCREEN, MOBILE DEVICES, HOWEVER
YOU'RE WATCHING.
GET INVOLVED IN THE POLL
QUESTION.
TOM: VERY INTERESTING, A'S AND
ANGELS GOING UP AGAINST EACH
OTHER IN THE POLL QUESTION, IN
THE MOVIE BUSINESS.
I LIKE IT.
SCOTT: CUSTOMARY THAT WHOEVER IS
SITTING NEXT TO ME NEEDS TO
DECIDE QUICKLY.
FIRST PITCH TO STARLING MARTE.
WHAT'S YOUR CHOICE?
TOM: NOT AMONG THOSE CHOICES
WERE "BULL DURHAM."
SCOTT: WE'RE JUST GOING WITH THE
FOUR.
TOM: DID YOU COME UP WITH THE
FINAL FOUR?
SCOTT: I HELPED BUT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES.
"LEAGUE OF THEIR OWN,"
"SANDLOT."
WE'RE JUST PICKING FOUR.
TOM: AMONG THOSE FOUR, I WOULD
GOING "FIELD OF DREAMS" MAYBE
BECAUSE I GOT TO GO TO THE FIELD
IN IOWA FOR THE FIRST TIME.
THAT WAS A TREAT.
SCOTT: ONE OF THE BEST GAMES
YOU'VE SEEN?
TOM: THE BEST SETTING FOR A GAME
I'VE EVER BEEN IN FOR SURE.
SCOTT: MARTE DIDN'T GET MUCH OF
IT.
QUIJADA THROWS HIM OUT.
TOM: WHAT ABOUT YOU?
SCOTT: OUT OF THAT GROUPING?
TOM: WE'RE INFLUENCING THE VOTE.
SCOTT: BASED OFF OF WHAT WE JUST
EXPERIENCED, "FIELD OF DREAMS"
IS FRESH ON THE MIND.
THAT GAME WAS A MOVIE.
I THINK IT MAKES ME APPRECIATE
THE MOVIE MORE FROM AN AESTHETIC
VIEW.
SO I'LL DOUBLE DOWN WITH YOU.
SEE WHAT EVERYONE ELSE DOES.
THAT'S A BASE HIT.
MATT OLSON COMES THROUGH.
SPINNER THROUGH THE INFIELD.
ARE YOU PLAYING IT STRAIGHT-UP,
DOES THE SHORTSTOP HAVE A SHOT
AT THAT?
TOM: PROBABLY NOT.
HE HIT THAT ONE HARD.
LOVE THESE TWO GUYS AT FIRST
BASE.
OLSON AND WALSH ACTUALLY PLAYED
TOGETHER AS KIDS IN THE SUMMER
IN ATLANTA.
YEARS LATER THEY MAKE THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE ALL-STAR TEAM
TOGETHER.
THAT'S PRETTY COOL.
SCOTT: THAT'S AWESOME.
JARED WALSH, IN TERMS OF DRAFT
POSITION, WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT
LATER.
>> HALL-OF-FAMER, BIG-TIME
RECORD BREAKER, SURE.
BUT NEVER FORGET, RICKEY
HENDERSON WAS A TRAILBLAZER.
NOT SO MUCH FOR WHAT HE
ACCOMPLISHED BUT FOR WHAT HE
TAUGHT A WHOLE GENERATION ABOUT
REAL STYLE.
>> IT WAS IN 1979 WE BROKE IN.
I SAID, WHO IS THIS GUY, RIGHT?
>> HE BROUGHT A STYLE.
HE BROUGHT, THE WORD THEY USE
NOW IS SWAG.
>> SNATCHING THE BALL OUT OF THE
AIR.
>> HENDERSON HAS IT.
>> FLIPPING THE BAT.
>> RICKEY HENDERSON IS A FORCE.
>> LETTING THEM KNOW, I GOT YOU.
>> RICKEY HENDERSON IS FULL OF
SUBSTANCE.
>> THERE'S THE SUBSTANCE AND
HERE COMES THE STYLE.
>> RICKEY GOT AWAY WITH IT
BECAUSE IT WAS TRUE, IT WAS
GENUINE.
>> EVERYONE WAS SCARED TO DO IT.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HIT ME IN
THE HEAD BUT HE WAS OK WITH
THAT.
GROUND BALL GETS ME IN, 1-0,
BECAUSE YOU WERE UPSET BECAUSE I
FLIPPED MY BAT.
>> THE A'S HAVE DONE IT AGAIN.
>> HE WAS ALMOST LIKE A REBEL
BECAUSE HE WASN'T LIKE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE FIELD.
HE WAS RICKEY.
SCOTT: CHECK OUT THE OAKLAND A'S
YOUTUBE CHANNEL FOR A GLIMPSE
BEHIND THE SCENES, HIGHLIGHTS OF
THE GREEN AND GOLD.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF COMMISSIONER OF
BASEBALL AND MAY NOT BE
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM AND
ACCOUNTS AND DESCRIPTIONS OF THE
GAME MAY NOT BE DISSEMINATED
WITHOUT EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT.
BACK AT ANGELS STADIUM.
GORGEOUS ORANGE COUNTY.
NEXT UP, JOSE MARTE, SECOND EVER
BIG LEAGUE APPEARANCE.
FIRST ONE WAS ON THE 20TH OF
AUGUST.
HE WAS JUST CALLED BACK UP.
ON THE 20TH, TWO INNINGS, A HIT,
NO RUNS, FOUR K'S.
HE ENTERS THE GAME IN THE SIXTH.
HEAT, 98, FIRST PITCH TO MARK
CANHA.
TOM: YOU SAW THAT MOVEMENT, TOO.
THAT'S NOT A STRAIGHT 98.
GOOD LIFE ON THAT FASTBALL.
SCOTT: OLSON AT FIRST.
YOU SEE THAT BASEBALL BEHIND THE
UMPIRE.
TOM: I DO.
SHOULDN'T BE THERE, SCOTT.
SCOTT: NO.
THANK YOU.
TOM: HE HEARD YOU.
SCOTT: AM I THAT LOUD?
TOM: CAN YOU KEEP IT DOWN A
LITTLE BIT?
SCOTT: I TRY TO BLEND IN WITH
THE CROWD.
TOM: IN THE EARLY DAYS OF
BASEBALL, 19TH CENTURY,
OUTFIELDERS USED TO HIDE
BASEBALLS IN THE GRASS IN THE
OUTFIELD.
IF THE BALL WAS HIT OVER THEIR
HEAD, THEY WOULD PICK UP ONE
CLOSEST TO THEM AND THROW IT
BACK IN.
THEY WEREN'T EXACTLY PERFECTLY
GROOMED FIELDS BACK IN THE DAY.
YOU COULD HIDE A BASEBALL IN THE
GRASS.
SCOTT: THAT'S UNREAL.
THEY HAD TO HAVE COME
COMEA
RULE THAT IF YOU DO THAT,
THERE'S HALF A YEAR'S SUSPENSION
OR SOMETHING.
NOTHING GETS BY US THESE DAYS.
3-0.
THERE IT IS, 97.
MARK CANHA HAS BOUNCED BACK THIS
MONTH AFTER A DOWN AUGUST.
TOM: HE'S A GUY, YOU REALLY HAVE
TO ATTACK THE BREAKING STUFF.
HIS SPLITS BETWEEN FASTBALLS AND
SECONDARY PITCHES IS ENORMOUS.
EVEN THIS FASTBALL, 97, 98, NO
PROBLEM.
BUT THIS SHOULD BE A CHALLENGE
FASTBALL RIGHT HERE, SHOULD GET
A GOOD SWING ON IT.
I'M SURPRISED HE TOOK IT.
TO ME, THAT'S EXACTLY THE PITCH
YOU KEYHOLE IN THAT SPOT, 3-1,
FASTBALL PITCHER ON THE MOUND.
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
PROTECT MODE, HAVE TO COVER A
LARGER AREA.
STILL GOING TO GET A CHALLENGE
FASTBALL.
SCOTT: THIS IS ONE OF THE TOP
PITCHES PER PLATE APPEARANCES
BATTER.
TOM: THAT'S WHY.
SCOTT: MARK CANHA LOVES TO WORK
THE COUNT.
THE EIGHTH WALK OF THE GAME.
TOM: IT'S GREAT.
SEEING A LOT OF PITCHES ISN'T
THE BE-ALL, END-ALL, CERTAINLY
NOT IN TODAY'S GAME.
BACK TO THE YANKEES AND RED SOX
YEARS AGO, THE IDEAS WAS TO
DRIVE UP THE PITCH COUNT AND GET
THE STARTING PITCHER OUT OF THE
GAME.
THAT IS IRRELEVANT IN TODAY'S
GAME BECAUSE STARTING PITCHERS
DON'T LAST.
THEY AVERAGE WAY FEWER THAN 90
PITCHES AND THERE'S SO MANY GOOD
ARMS IN THE BULLPEN, THE REWARD
ISN'T THERE TO GET THE STARTING
PITCHER OUT OF THE GAME SO A
TEAM LIKE TORONTO IS SHOWING YOU
WHAT BEING AGGRESSIVE DOES IN
TODAY'S GAME.
A DIFFERENT GAME THAN A DECADE
AGO.
SCOTT: PITCHER HITTER, SETH
BROWN.
CHAPMAN AND CANHA LOVE TO WORK
AT-BATS.
TOM: WHICH IS GREAT, AGAIN, BUT
I LIKE MY GUY TO SWING 3-1,
FASTBALL DOWN THE MIDDLE WITH A
GUY ON BASE.
SCOTT: PULLS IT FOUL.
28 YEARS OLD.
LATE BLOOMER.
LOVES THE BREAKING BALL.
TOM: I'VE ALWAYS LIKED HIS
STROKE, SCOTT.
YOU SAW HIM IN FRONT OF THE
FASTBALL THERE BUT HE TURN
AROUND HEAT.
YOU MENTIONED, GOOD BREAKING
BALL HITTER.
HIS BARREL IS IN THE ZONE A LONG
TIME.
SCOTT: IT GETS AWAY AND BOTH
RUNNERS MOVE UP EASILY AND
THEY'RE IN SCORING POSITION.
OLSON AND CANHA, WITH ONE OUT IN
THE SIXTH.
TOM:THIS
THIS IS A MISTAKE B.
YOU GOT TO CATCH THIS BASEBALL.
JUST A LITTLE SLOW REACTING TO
IT.
OFF THE END -- I WOULD SCORE
THAT A PASS BALL.
SCOTT: IT IS.
TOM: YEAH.
THAT'S A GAME CHANGER.
ANGELS ARE GOING TO PLAY THE
INFIELD BACK.
SCOTT: CRUCIAL MOMENT IN THE
BALL GAME.
BROWN ON THE GROUND AND THIS
WILL BRING HOME THE RUNNER.
TOM: I'M SURPRISED THEY PLAYED
THE INFIELD BACK WITH NO OUTS.
WITH TWO RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION, ALL SET UP BY THAT
PASS BALL, BUT CONCEDING THE
TYING RUN ON A WEAKLY HIT GROUND
BALL THE OTHER WAY.
SCOTT: OLSON COMES IN.
HIGH TO CHAPMAN.
CANHA IS AT THIRD NOW.
SO THE A'S HAVE CAUGHT UP.
TWO-RUN SECOND FOR OAKLAND.
THEN FOUR FROM THE ANGELS IN THE
BOTTOM OF THAT INNING.
A'S ANSWERED BACK WITH A RUN IN
THE THIRD, NOW ONE MORE IN THE
SIXTH.
SUZUKI SAVES THE DAY THERE.
TOM: LOOKS TO ME LIKE SUZUKI'S
HAVING A TOUGH TIME TRACKING
MARTE'S PITCHES.
LAST COUPLE OF SLIDERS THERE,
LATE RESPONDING TO IT.
YOU SAW THE FASTBALL, LATE
RESPONDING TO THAT.
SCOTT: LIKE A POP QUIZ FOR HIM
TONIGHT, THOUGH, WORKING WITH
FRESH FACES.
TOM: WE TALK ABOUT HITTERS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT NEW
PITCHERS.
SAME HOLDS FOR THE CATCHER.
WHAT DOES HE LIKE TO THROW?
HOW DOES HIS BALL MOVE?
NOT EASY WITH A RUNNER ON THIRD
BASE.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE FOURTH ARM IN
THE GAME FOR THE ANGELS.
DIAZ MADE HIS DEBUT.
VERY DIFFERENT PITCHER FROM THE
MAN ON THE MOUND RIGHT NOW.
3-0 AND THAT'S PAST SUZUKI AND
THE A'S GRAB THE LEAD.
MARK CANHA SCORES, IT'S 5-4.
TOM: A'S HAVING A HARD TIME
TRACKING THE SLIDER OR THE
FASTBALL.
THAT'S A FASTBALL THAT RAN ARM
SIDE.
LUCKY HE DIDN'T BREAK HIS THUMB
TRYING TO CATCH THIS.
THAT'S JUST NOT BEING FAMILIAR
ENOUGH WITH THE PITCHER TO KNOW
HOW HIS BALL MOVES.
SCOTT: ANOTHER FASTBALL?
TOM: THOSE FASTBALLS SHOULD BE
CAUGHT BUT WHEN YOU MISS BADLY,
LOCATION WITH FASTBALLS, YOU
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME TO
REACT TO IT.
THAT SLIDER DOWN.
THIS HAS BEEN A TOUGH INNING FOR
A REALLY GOOD DEFENSIVE CATCHER.
SCOTT: TWO PASS ALSO ABOUT.
ALSO EIGHT WALKS FROM ANGELS
PITCHING TONIGHT.
TWO HIT BATTERS.
MAKE THAT NINE WALKS.
CHAPMAN MAKING IT NINE.
CHAPMAN'S WALKED TWICE TONIGHT.
ALSO A BASE HIT, ON FOR A THIRD
TIME.
GOMES IS 1-3.
TOM: BETWEEN THE -- WALKS, THE
HIT BATTERS AND PASS BALLS,
THAT'S A LOT OF FREE BASES AND
WE'RE ONLY IN THE SIXTH INNING.
TO ME, THE ANGELS ARE LUCKY THE
GAME IS JUST 5-4 AT THIS POINT.
SCOTT: RUNNERS ON THE MOVE AND
THE THROW IS IN THERE!
TOUGH INNING FOR KURT SUZUKI AND
THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO HEAD BACK
TO THE DUGOUT.
MATT CHAPMAN IS TOAST AT SECOND.
HE'S NOT MOVING.
TOM: IT LOOKS LIKE FLETCHER MADE
A TAG ON THE LEG OR FOOT OF
CHAPMAN BEFORE HE GOT TO THE
BAG.
THEY'RE GOING TO CHALLENGE IT.
THE BENEFIT OF THROWING THE BALL
TO THE FIRST BASE SIDE OF SECOND
IS SOMETIMES YOU GET THE TAG
BEFORE THE HAND GETS IN THERE.
THAT'S CLOSE.
MIGHT BE IN THERE.
THAT'S REALLY CLOSE, ON THE LEG,
GET HIM IN TIME.
THE ORIGINAL CALL IS OUT.
SO FAR I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING
TO OVERTURN IT.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO HOLD UP.
I DON'T SEE THAT AS CONCLUSIVE.
THE ANGELS ARE CONVINCED.
THEY SAW THE REPLAY ON THE
JUMBOTRON AND SAID, WE'RE DONE.
BUT THE CALL FROM NEW YORK IS
THE ONLY ONE THAT COUNTS.
SCOTT: I DON'T THINK IT'S
CONCLUSIVE TO OVERTURN.
YOU CAN MAKE A CASE HE GOT A
PIECE.
HE'S OUT.
THE ANGELS ARE CORRECT.
BUT THE A'S WIN THE INNING WITH
TWO RUNS TO SNATCH THE LEAD.
5-4 HEADING TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
SIXTH.
>> THAT BALL ALMOST ESCAPED THE
GLOVE OF CARLOS CORREA.
>> END OF THE GLOVE FOR THAT
SNOW CONE.
>> THIS WILL BE GREAT.
HE CAN DO IT.
>> I KNEW IT!
>> HE WAS SO CLOSE!
HE'S JUST SITTING RIGHT THERE.
>> FLY BALL HIT OUT TOWARDS
CENTER.
JACKIE BRADLEY JR. WILL MAKE THE
CATCH.
OH, HE TRIPPED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> LORENZO SAYING THANKS.
SAYING TO THE FANS IN THE
BLEACHERS, I'M GOOD.
THE KEGHEADS, I THINK THEY ARE.
>> CONEHEADS.
>> LOOKS GOOD ON YOU, THOUGH.
>> LOOKS GOOD ON YOU.
>> DID THEY ASK YOU TO SIGN
THAT?
>> WE'LL SIGN IT AND SEND IT
BACK.
SCOTT: CREATOR SPOTLIGHT TIME.
COLLEGE STUDENT ASHLEY SANDERS
WHO RUNS A TWITCH SCREAM
SHOWCASING DIAMOND DYNASTY IN-'.
SHE'S A COLLEGE STUDENT.
DOES THIS DURING OUR STUDY
BREAKS.
VERY WELCOMING AND ENTHUSIASTIC
TO HER SUBSCRIBERS.
HELLO, ASHLEY.
DROP US A LINE IN THE
COMMENTARY, WE WILL GIVE YOU A
REPLY BACK.
OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
OUR NEW RIGHT FIELDER FOR
OAKLAND, SETH BROWN, IN FOR CHAD
PINDER.
KURT SUZUKI WENT AROUND.
LABORIOUS INNING FOR KURT
SUZUKI.
NOW HE GETS A CHANCE, DOES HAVE
A HOME RUN IN HIS POCKET.
FOWLER.
TOM: HE'S HAVING FUN.
HE'S ALWAYS HAVING FUN.
SCOTT: GET HIM ON THE SHOW.
FOUL BALL.
[LAUGHTER]
A LOT OF FAMILIAR FACES ON THE
ANGELS.
TOM: I WAS THINKING THE SAME
THING.
SCOTT: TROUT, UPTON, FOWLER.
RENDON ISN'T HERE, I DON'T
THINK.
I HAVEN'T SEEN HIM.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY NOT ACTIVE AS
WELL.
A LOT OF TALENT NOT ON THE
ACTIVE ROSTER FOR THE ANGELS.
PAUL URBAN STRIKES OUT KURT
SUZUKI.
A NUMBER THREE ON THE DAY FOR
URBAN.
BRETT: LOOK WHAT I HAVE.
WHO WOULD EVER FORGET JOE
MADDON'S TRY NOT TO SUCK
T-SHIRTS WITH THE CUBS?
THIS IS THE OHTANI VERSION.
TO BE A GOOD PAUL PLAYER, TRY
NOT TO STOP.
IT'S PART OF JOE MADDON'S
RESPECT 90 FOUNDATION.
HE WAS EXPLAINING THIS TO JACK
-- 20 JAPANESE MEDIA MEMBERS
TODAY.
THEY WERE LOVING THE STORY.
BETWEEN THEIR PROMOTION AND ON
YOUTUBE, IF THIS DOESN'T FLY BY
THE $1 MILLION THAT THE CUBS
T-SHIRT MADE, I WOULD BE
STUNNED.
I HAVE A FEELING IN JAPAN AND
ELSEWHERE, THIS IS GOING TO BE A
HOT SELLER.
SCOTT: I AGREE.
THAT'S A GOOD LOOK.
THAT MAKES A TON OF SENSE.
TOM: PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW WHERE
THEY CAN GET THEM RIGHT NOW.
I'M SURE THEY SAW BRETT SHOW
THAT OFF AND WHO WOULDN'T WANT
ONE.
SCOTT: DID YOU GET YOURS?
TOM: DID YOU?
SCOTT: IT'S COOL.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE GET
HOOKED UP BEFORE WE LEAVE.
OTHERWISE, I WILL ORDER IT
ONLINE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A HOT ITEM.
JOE MADDON WAS WEARING IT WITH A
BIG SMILE EARLIER TODAY.
NICO WILL BE SMILING AFTER THAT.
NICE CONTACT.
ONE OUT.
BASE RUNNER FOR THE ANGELS IN
THE HOME SIX.
THE GAME HAS CHANGED.
3-0 COUNT.
DOWN A RUN.
AUTUMN THIRD OF THE ORDER.
THE LAST FASTBALL COUNT IN THE
GAME.
HE THOUGHT IS ON A HEATER
LATELY.
THREE HOMERS IN THE LAST SEVEN
GAMES ENTERING TODAY, INCLUDING
A LONG BALL YESTERDAY.
ALSO JACK MAYFIELD.
SINGLE, DOUBLE, WHAT'S NEXT?
FLIED OUT TO CENTER.
TOM: I'VE BEEN REALLY IMPRESSED
WITH ERVIN, THE WAY HIS STUFF
HAS GOTTEN SHARPER AS WE'VE
GOTTEN DEEPER INTO THE GAME.
THAT WAS A SLIDER RIGHT THERE.
THEY BOTH PLAYED UP AS WE HAVE
GOTTEN THROUGH THIS GAME.
AGAIN, MELVIN TALKED ABOUT IT.
WE ARE PLAYING A SEASON AFTER A
SHORT SEASON LAST YEAR BECAUSE
OF COVID.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S ONE WAY TO
LOOK AT IT.
YOU ARE WELL RESTED COMING OFF
OF THE SHORT YEAR, ARI -- OR YOU
ARE WELL TESTED WHEN IT COMES TO
STRENGTH.
HIS STUFF HAS HELD UP WELL.
THE PHILLIES THOUGHT HE WAS
GOING TO BE A POWER PITCHER.
HIS FASTBALL WAS PLAYING UP.
THEY WANTED HIM TO BE A FASTBALL
SLIDER GUY, MAY BE BULLPEN
PIECE.
HE'S GOT PLENTY OF PITCHES TO BE
AN EFFECTIVE STARTING PITCHER.
SCOTT: WITHOUT THE HIGH
VELOCITY.
TOM: BULLPEN GETTING READY
BEHIND HIM.
SCOTT: TRIVINO AND DIEKMAN, TWO
OF THEIR MOST TALENTED.
IT'S A BIG ONE TO OPEN UP THE
SERIES.
THE ANGELS HAVE DEFINITELY MADE
THEIR MISTAKES TONIGHT, GAVE
THEM SOME RUNS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO LOCK IT DOWN.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN GREAT UP
UNTIL THE LAST FEW WEEKS.
TOM: THE MESSAGE IS, THIS IS
YOUR LAST BATTER.
THE LEFT-HAND IS PROBABLY THE
SLOT FOR DIEKMAN.
THE PITCH COUNT AT 85.
HE WON'T GO THROUGH THE LINE UP
A FOURTH TIME.
SCOTT: FOR RUNS, ONLY ONE OF
THEM EARNED.
MORE SWING AND MISS.
TOM: THERE IS THAT SLIDER AGAIN.
HE DOES SOMETHING I'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE.
BETWEEN INNINGS, HE ONLY THROWS
THE FASTBALL.
THAT TELLS ME HE'S GOT
CONFIDENCE AND FEEL ON HIS
SECONDARY STUFF.
SCOTT: CHANGEUP, SLIDER SO FAR
TO THE GAR US.
RENGIFO IS ON.
ANOTHER CHANGEUP.
IS THERE A COMP?
IS IT A KYLE HENDRICKS TYPE IN
THAT CONTROL?
TOM: HE IS NOT HENDRICKS.
HENDRICKS WILL TWO SEAM YOU TO
DEATH.
THIS FASTBALL IS MORE OF THAT
TRUE FOUR-SEAMER UP.
THIS DID HAPPEN IN HIS LAST
START AGAINST TEXAS.
IT TURNED INTO OFFENSE BUT HE
PICKED UP STEAM TO GIVE THE TEAM
SEVEN INNINGS.
A COUPLE RUNS, A WALK.
HE STRUCK OUT EIGHT IN THAT ONE.
HIS STRIKEOUT RATE HAS GONE UP
THIS YEAR.
HE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW IF HE WAS
GOING TO MAKE THE TEAM.
CONSISTENT CONTRIBUTOR.
TOM: WE HAVEN'T SEEN HIM TOO
MANY TIMES TONIGHT DOUBLE UP ON
THAT FASTBALL.
I WOULD THINK THIS IS EITHER THE
SLIDER OR THE CHANGEUP.
SOMETHING SOFT HERE TO LAGARES.
SCOTT: IN ON THE HERONS.
HARRISON WILL HAVE TO SHOVEL IT
TO SECOND -- IN TIME.
TOM: THAT WAS CLOSE.
SCOTT: DOES RENGIFO THINK?
?
HE IS SAFE NO.
HOLD UP.
WAIT FOR IT.
WE ARE GOOD.
♪
KEMP WITH THE SQUEEZE.
RENT HE FELL IS OUT AT SECOND.
FIELDER'S CHOICE.
HARRISON, FIRST DOWN.
>> THIS WILL BE INTERESTING.
THIS IS THE PART WHERE I START
SINGING MIKED UP.
♪
>> GOT HIM.
GOT HIM.
THAT'S ONE.
YOU GOT ONE TONIGHT.
YOU LIKE THOSE SCRATCHES?
YOU DID SUCH A GOOD JOB.
WE WILL WIN TODAY BECAUSE YOU
DID SUCH A GOOD JOB OUT THERE.
I MISS MY DOG SO MUCH.
>> DO YOU THINK MY BEARD LOOKS
TO AMISH?
WOULD YOU GIVE UP EVERYTHING TO
BE AMISH?
>> RETURNING TO ON THIS ON TLC.
>> YES.
>> ROSIE HAS A TAN I'M A DOZEN
HE?
YOU HAVE THIS MAGNIFICENT TAN.
>> ON MY GOD, I FEEL FAT.
I'M JUST GOING TO SIT HERE.
IT'S UP.
WE WERE WATCHING TODAY BUT I GET
IT.
♪
>> WATCHING A BASEBALL GAME ON
YOUTUBE.
>> I CAN IMAGINE LIKE IT WOULD
BE LIKE.
>> YOU CAN SMELL THE GRASS, HERE
THE FANS.
YOU ARE JUST LIKE SEAN MANAEA.
IF YOU WANT TO BE LIKE SEAN
MANAEA, GET YOURSELF ON YOUTUBE
TV.
SCOTT: FIRST TAKE.
NAILED IT.
YOUR NEWEST COMMERCIAL, STARRING
SHAUNA SAW -- SEAN MANAEA AND
THE OAKLAND A'S.
TOM: HE IS A STAR.
SCOTT: I GOT A KICK OUT OF HIM
BEFORE THE GAME TONIGHT.
HE'S OUT IN THE OUTFIELD,
DOESN'T HAVE A HAT ON SO HE HAS
THE FLOW OUT.
BAREFOOT.
THROWING A FOOTBALL AROUND.
TOM: HACKY SACK AFTER THAT.
SCOTT: YEAH.
SO SOCAL.
TOM: CHILLING.
SCOTT: TO CENTER.
MARCH LOOKING BACK.
IT'S LONG.
LONG, LOUD FLY BALL.
OUT NUMBER ONE OFF OF THE YAN
GOMES.
JUST A REMINDER TO OUR VIEWERS.
YOU CAN CLICK THE GEAR ICON IN
YOUR PLAYER TO CHOOSE AUDIO
TRACKS.
YOU HAVE THE OPTION TO THE
JAPANESE LANGUAGE COMMENTARY.
IT'S AVAILABLE FOR YOU.
JED LOWRIE PINCH-HITTING IN
CHRIS DAVIS IS SPOT.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS.
IT'S HAPPENING.
THERE'S A STRIKE FROM LANCE.
TOM: ONE OF MY GREAT THRILLS WAS
IN 1994.
I WENT TO JAPAN FOR THEIR WORLD
SERIES.
WE HAVE NO WORLD SERIES HERE AND
94.
-- IN 94.
IT WAS SUCH A PLEASURE TO BE IN
THOSE BALLPARKS, THE WAY PEOPLE
WERE LOCKED INTO THE GAMES.
CONSTANT CHEERING.
THEY HAVE BANDS THERE.
DEDICATED SONGS, WE WOULD CALL
THEM WALK SONGS.
PEP SONGS FOR EACH PLAYER.
SCOTT: ONE MAN ON THE LEFT SIDE.
MAYFIELD MAKES IT HAPPEN.
TOM: NOBODY NEEDED THE MAKE
NOISE SIGN ON THE SCOREBOARD.
THEY WERE SO KNOWLEDGEABLE AND
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE GAME.
IT WAS JUST A GREAT ATMOSPHERE.
SCOTT: COLLEGE FOOTBALL?
TOM: LIKE THAT, YEAH.
SCOTT: LET'S FINISH THIS UP.
FAVORITE BASEBALL MOVIE WINNER.
OAKLAND A'S FANS GETTING IN
THERE.
TOM: I'M SURPRISED MONEYBALL
ONE.
SCOTT: FIELD OF DREAMS, ANGEL IN
THE OUTFIELD.
TOM: RECENCY BIAS.
RIGHT?
THAT'S THE ONE THAT WAS
RELEASED.
THE LATEST.
SCOTT: ARE ON -- YOUNGEST
AUDIENCE KNOWS MONEYBALL.
MAYBE NOT ANGELS IN THE
OUTFIELD.
IT WAS MID 90'S.
94.
MID 90'S.
94, THE YEAR THAT WOULD -- YOU
WERE IN JAPAN.
TOM: IS THAT WHEN THEY WENT TO
THE PAIR HE WINCO UNIFORMS?
SOMETIME AROUND THERE.
SCOTT: THEY ARE EMPTY FOR CAMP.
JUST MISSED.
SHOCKER.
TOM: IT'S A THREE BALL COUNT,
SCOTT.
SCOTT: SHOCKER.
THERE'S A STRIKE.
HE HAS WALKED THREE TIMES.
IT'S A MICROCOSM OF THE SEASON
FOR TONY KEMP.
ON BASE MACHINE, BOTTOM OF THE
ORDER.
TOM: HIS LAST TWO SEASONS WERE
THE BEST.
SCOTT: PULLS IT.
THE STOP AT FIRST AND THEY'VE
GOT HIM.
GOBBLE IT UP, GET IT DONE GERALD
WASH.
MEAN GLOVE WORK.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN TO END THE
SEVENTH.
THE EXTENSION.
LANCE IS THERE.
THAT'S NOT EASY TO DO.
♪
>> BOTTOM OF THE SEVENTH INNING.
THE ANGELS TRAILING AT 5-0.
>> RALLY MONKEY ON THE
SCOREBOARD.
>> THEY'VE HAD SO MANY RALLIES
THIS YEAR.
DO THEY HAVE ANOTHER ONE LEFT IN
THEM?
>> SWING AND A HIGH DRIVE.
DEEP TO RIGHT.
TO THE WALL AND IT'S GONE.
HOME RUN.
HE'S MADE IT A TWO RUN GAME.
THE ANGELS ARE BREATHING AND
RIGHT BACK INTO IT.
>> HERE'S THE SWING.
THE LONG DRIVE DEEP TO RIGHT.
I HOME RUN.
IT'S A ONE RUN GAME.
>> THE NEVER SAY DIE ANGELS
GIVING THEIR FANS A THRILL DOWN
THE STRETCH.
LEFT FIELD, IN THE GAP.
HERE COMES ANDERSON.
THE ANGELS TAKE THE LEAD.
>> WE ARE ONE STRIKE AWAY FROM A
GAME SEVEN.
>> THE PITCH, SWUNG ON AND
MISSED.
WHAT A BALLGAME.
>> THE ANAHEIM ANGELS ARE STILL
BREATHING.
WE ARE GOING TO GAME SEVEN,
INCREDIBLY.
♪
TOM: DON'T MISS A MINUTE OF
EXCLUSIVE ANGELS CONTENT.
HEAD TO THE YOUTUBE PAGE TO
WATCH EXCITING MOMENTS,
INTERVIEWS, AND MORE.
SUBSCRIBE TO THE CHANNEL TODAY.
LISTEN TO MLB'S PODCASTS TO GEAR
-- HERE THE LATEST INSIGHT AND
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEWS WITH
BASEBALL'S BIGGEST STARS.
ARE YOU SUBSCRIBED?
YES?
GOOD.
JAKE DIEKMAN, THE 34-YEAR-OLD
LEFT-HANDER IN THE GAME FOR
OAKLAND.
HE'S PITCHING IN HIS 10TH SEASON
, MID 90'S WITH THE FASTBALL.
GET YOU SOME SWING AND MISS.
TOM: IT'S NOT JUST THE VELOCITY,
IT'S THE ANGLE THAT HE GENERATES
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED HITTERS.
SCOTT: SEVEN STARTS WITH THE
ROOKIE BRANDON MARSH.
HE CAN HANDLE HEAT.
MARSH HIT A HOME RUN ON
WEDNESDAY OFF OF A 108 -- 100
POINT EIGHT MILE-PER-HOUR
FASTBALL FROM MICHAEL KOPECH.
ARTIST -- HARDEST PINCH-HIT FOR
A HOME RUN THIS YEAR.
THAT'S 95 FROM DIEKMAN.
TOM: HE'S A FASCINATING PLAYER.
HE'S GOT GREAT SKILLS.
SPEED.
JOE TALKED ABOUT HIM BEING GOLD
GLOVE CALIBER IN CENTER FIELD.
HE MIGHT HAVE MIKE TROUT PLAYING
A CORNER OUTFIELD NEXT YEAR.
THERE IS TOO MUCH SWING AND MISS
IN THIS GAME.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL FOR A YOUNG
PLAYER.
HE IMPROVES ON THAT, LOOK OUT.
THE SKILLS ARE THERE.
SCOTT: SAME HIGH SCHOOL AS JOEY
BART, THE CATCHER IN THE GIANTS
ORGANIZATION.
FORMER FIRST ROUNDER.
BATTLE OF THE BEARDS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
TOM: IT'S NO CONTEST IF YOU ARE
JUST GOING BY BEARDS.
IT DEPENDS WHAT YOUR POINT OF
JUDGMENT IS.
YEAH.
ARSON HAS THAT.
NEATNESS?
HE IS NOT GOING TO WIN THAT.
SCOTT: A LOT GOING ON THERE.
I'M DISTRACTED.
MARSH, HARD HIT.
THEY'VE GOT A MAN THERE.
IT'S HARRISON, THROWING OUT
MARSH.
THEY TALKED ABOUT FLETCHER, IT
REMINDS ME OF ICHIRO OR JETER.
DOESN'T HAVE TO HIT THE BALL
HARD.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HIS NOT SO
GREATEST HITS IN TERMS OF EXIT
VELOCITY.
HE PUTS THE BALL IN PLAY.
BY NO MEANS IS IT HARD A LOT OF
THE TIMES.
IN FACT, HIS AVERAGE EXIT
VELOCITY NOT IMPRESSIVE AT ALL.
HE PUTS IT IN PLAY, GETS OUT OF
THE BOX QUICKLY.
HE TURNS MORE MISS HIT BALLS
INTO ACTUAL HITS THAN ANYBODY IN
TODAY'S GAME.
TOM: THERE YOU GO.
NOT THE HARDEST.
HARRISON ON THE MOVE.
THE TAG APPLIED BY OLSON IS
THERE.
SCOTT: THERE YOU GO.
NOT THIS TIME.
TOM: THAT WASN'T TO HIT.
-- A HIT.
PULLS OLSON OFF OF THE BAG.
GOOD JOB BY THE FOR BASEMENT TO
GET OFF OF THE BAG.
AND THEN GET THE OUT.
SCOTT: HERE COMES THE BIG MAN.
OHTANI WITH TWO OUTS, NOBODY ON.
TOM: THIS IS THE ONE PART IN A
GAME WHERE THE HITTER,
ESPECIALLY SOMEONE LIKE OHTANI,
IS LOOKING TO HIT A HOME RUN.
TWO OUTS, BASES EMPTY, TOUGH
LEFTY ON THE MOUND.
BEFORE YOU GET TO TWO STRIKES,
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT AN AREA.
FOR OHTANI, IT IS FASTBALL UP.
HE CAN HIT THE BALL OUT.
SCOTT: THAT'S 96 ON THE CORNER.
TOM: GREAT PITCH BY DIEKMAN.
SCOTT: YOU ARE NOT PITCHING
AROUND HIM IN THIS SPOT?
GOSSELIN ON DECK.
TOM: IT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU WANT
TO DO.
YOU ARE PITCHING HIM RIGHT HERE,
STARTING TO COUNT AS IF IT IS
0-2.
YOU ARE NOT PITCHING AROUND HIM.
YOU ARE NOT GIVING IN.
AGAIN, RIGHT ON THE BLACK.
NOT MUCH HE CAN DO WITH THAT
PITCH.
THIS IS A CASE WHERE YOU ARE
DEFENDING THE HOME RUN.
IT SOUNDS ODD.
POWER HITTER, TWO OUTS, BASES
EMPTY.
KEEP THE BALL OUT OF THE MIDDLE
OF THE PLATE.
IN THIS CASE, NOT A FASTBALL UP.
SCOTT: HE'S AN EXTRA-BASE HIT
MONSTER AGAINST LEFT-HANDED
PITCHING.
TOM: IT'S REALLY IMPRESSIVE FOR
HOOKAH -- FOR A GUY WHO GETS HIS
IT'S A -- HIPS OPEN EARLY.
HE KEEPS HIS HANDS BACK.
HE KEEPS THE HANDS BACK SO THAT
THE HANDS DON'T FOLLOW THE HIPS.
THAT MEANS HE STAYS ON TIME,
STAYS BACK ON HIS BACKHAND SIDE.
SCOTT: THAT WAS THE ONE.
I'M SWEATING IF I'M BOB MELVIN.
TOM: I'M WITH YOU.
THAT'S A PITCHER CAN HANDLE.
I WOULD NOT THROW HIM BACK TO
BACK FASTBALLS.
HE SHOULD BE BACK TO THE SLIDER,
DOWN AND AWAY.
SCOTT: IF YOU WALK HIM, NO BIG
DEAL.
GOT HIM!
TOM: WOW.
PAINT.
SCOTT: WHAT A PITCH FROM
DIEKMAN.
CHALLENGING SHOHEI OHTANI AND
WINNING THE BATTLE.
PERFECTLY EXECUTED, RIGHT ON THE
BLACK WITH THE FASTBALL AT 97.
A LITTLE HELP FROM YAN GOMES.
>> IN SPRING TRAINING IN 1972,
RITCHIE SHOWS UP WITH A FULL
BEARD.
>> WE HAVE RULES, NO FACIAL HAIR
BUT REGGIE WORE A BEARD.
AS REGGIE IS WANT TO DO, HE
TELLS EVERY REPORTER INSIGHT, I
DON'T CARE IF THEY DON'T LIKE
IT.
>> NOW CHARLIE FIGURES, HE WILL
USE REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY ON
REGGIE.
HE CAME UP WITH THIS MUSTACHE
THING.
CHARLIE TOLD EVERYBODY, IF YOU
HAVE A MUSTACHE ON OPENING DAY,
YOU GET $300.
THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE AT --
LIKE A LOT TODAY.
WE FIGURED IF REGGIE SEES WHAT'S
HAPPENING, HE WILL SHAPE HIS
BEARD OFF.
THAT'S WHAT HE WANTED BUT IT
DIDN'T WORK.
>> TOOK ME FOUR MONTHS.
SOME OF THE GUYS TOLD ME NOT TO
CUT IT OFF.
>> I'VE HAD IT EVER SINCE.
I NEVER SHAVED IT OFF.
>> I LIKE IT, MY WIFE LIKES IT.
I ONLY GREW IT TO GET 300 BUCKS
OUT OF CHARLIE.
>> HE KEPT THE BEARD, WE KEPT
OUR MUSTACHES.
WE STARTED WINNING AND THAT
BECAME OUR TRADEMARK.
SCOTT:SCOTT: GOOGLE CLOUD IS
HELPING TO POWER STATCAST WITH
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF DATA POINTS,
TAKING YOU DEEPER INTO THE GAME
THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
ROBERTO CLEMENTE AWARD
RECOGNIZES ONE PLAYER WHO BEST
REPRESENTS THE GAME AND HAS
POSITIVE CONTRIBUTIONS IN AND
OFF THE FIELD.
YES.
NUMBER 17.
KNOW ALL ABOUT IT ON THE 17TH OF
SEPTEMBER.
ANGELS DOWN A RUN.
MORE FROM ANDREW LANCE.
JOSH HARRISON IS THE A'S LEADOFF
MAN TODAY.
HE WAS HIT BY A PITCH.
THE NEXT THREE A FEES, BASES
LOADED.
SINGLE, SAC FLY, DOUBLE PLAY.
TOM: FOR THE LEADOFF HITTER.
THAT'S MOST UNUSUAL.
SCOTT: WE'VE SEEN A LOT TONIGHT.
HARRISON WAS A GREAT PICKUP FOR
OAKLAND.
THEY WERE ACTIVE AROUND THE
TRADE DEADLINE.
YAN GOMES IS A BIG PART OF THE
CATCHING CONVERSATIONS NOW.
STARLING MARTE IS THE BEST
POSITION PLAYER ACQUIRED DURING
THE TRADE SEASON.
ANDREW CHAFIN OUT OF THE BULLPEN
HAS BEEN A BIG-TIME MEMBER.
HARRISON LOFTS ONE.
THERE'S GOSSELIN.
ONE AWAY.
SPEAKING OF STARLING MARTE.
BRETT: I THINK YOU MENTIONED
MARTE WILL FINISH IN THE TOP 10,
PROBABLY THE TOP FIVE IN BOTH
LEAGUES IN STOLEN BASINS.
THAT HAS NEVER HAPPENED IN ANY
OFFENSIVE CATEGORY.
HE'S LEADING THE MAJORS IN
BATTING AVERAGE AND STOLEN
BASES.
SHOULD HE FINISH THE YEAR
LEADING BOTH, HOW RARE WOULD
THAT BE?
HONUS WAGNER DID IT IN 1908.
TY COBB DID IT FOUR TIMES AND
THE LAST WAS 1917.
IT HAS BEEN MORE THAN A CENTURY
SINCE SOMEONE LEAD THE MAJORS IN
BATTING AVERAGE STOLEN BASES.
IF HE LEADS THE MAJORS IN
BATTING AVERAGE, WE COULD STILL
HAVE A TRIPLE CROWN WINNER IN
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE.
OHTANI ISN'T THE ONLY GUY DOING
CRAZY THINGS WITH NUMBERS THIS
SEASON.
SCOTT: THAT'S A GOOD CALL.
OHTANI IS GRABBING THE
HEADLINES.
BUT THERE IS SERIOUS WORK BEING
DONE BY PLAYERS LIKE THIS MAN.
THERE IT IS.
TOM: I LOVE TO SEE THE STOLEN
BASE TOTAL, CLOSE TO 50 OVERALL.
WOULD LOVE TO SEE MORE STOLEN
BASES BACK IN THE GAME.
IT'S EXCITING.
EVEN THE THREAT OF A STOLEN BASE
ADDS ENERGY TO AGAIN.
SCOTT: A'S FANS HAVE NOT SEEN
MANY SWIPES.
THAT WAS TO THE HELMET.
TOM: DID THAT BALL?
?
COME UP AND HIT HIM?
SCOTT: GOOD THAT HE CAN LAUGH
ABOUT IT.
IT BOUNCED UP AND HIT THEM IN
THE HELMET.
SCOTT: I THINK JUST THE HELMET
THOUGH.
TOM: STRANGE.
SCOTT: WEIRD SPOT FOR THE
BASEBALL TO GO.
TOM: GOOD THAT HE CAN LAUGH
ABOUT IT, THAT'S FOR SURE.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF WEIRD THINGS
TONIGHT.
SCOTT: IT'S FRIDAY THE 17TH.
TOM: OF COURSE.
SCOTT: THIS IS WHAT MAKES HIM
EXTRA SPECIAL.
CAUGHT FIVE TIMES.
50-50 CHANCE.
THAT'S GREAT.
YOU KNOW HE'S GOING HALF THE
TIME.
TOM: YOU GET OVER 80%, THAT'S
EXTORT MARY.
90% IS OVER -- OTHERWORLDLY.
SCOTT: HE WILL BE A FREE AGENT
AFTER THIS YEAR.
HE WAS TRADED THE LAST TWO
SEASONS.
YOU COULD MAKE A STRONG CASE
THAT HE'S THE BEST POSITION
PLAYER TRADED IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS.
TOM: THE DODGERS MIGHT OFFER UP
TREA TURNER BUT I'M WITH YOU IN
TERMS OF PRODUCTION.
SCOTT: TRUE.
TOM: HE WAS PLAYING VERY WELL
FOR THE MARLINS AND HE HAS
RAISED HIS GAME WITH OAKLAND.
SCOTT: A'S GM DAVID FORCE SAYS
THEY'VE BEEN TARGETING HIM FOR
WEEKS BACKS WHEN THEY MADE THE
MOVE.
STRIKES OUT.
HE'S EVEN MORE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
RAMON LAUREANO, WHO WAS A DO IT
ALL GUY IN THE OUTFIELD FOR THE
A'S, WAS SUSPENDED FOR
PERFORMANCE-ENHANCING DRUGS.
HE'S MISSING THE REST OF THE
SEASON AND THE PLAYOFFS.
THERE'S THE CUTTER FROM WHENCE.
BRETT: I ENJOYED THAT CHARLIE
FINLEY LITTLE NUGGET BETWEEN
INNINGS THERE.
THE MUSTACHE GANG IN THE OLD
DAYS.
IN SOME WAYS, THE LEGACY OF
CHARLIE FINLEY GOES ON WITH
THESE A'S.
YOU'VE SEEN THEM IN THEIR WHITE
SHOES.
THAT WAS A THING BACK IN THE
DAY.
HE STARTED IN 1967.
THE A'S GO OUT THERE, OPENING
DAY.
WHITE SHOES ON.
THE PITCHER THROWS THE FIRST
PITCH.
THAT'S GOING TO DROP.
SCOTT: HE FOUND ONE.
TOM: JIM NASH WAS THE PITCHER.
THE MANAGER FOR THE INDIANS
CALLS TIMEOUT, PROTESTS THE
GAME.
THAT GUY IS WEARING WHITE SHOES,
OUR HITTERS CAN'T SEE THE
BASEBALL.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S HOW REVOLUTIONARY IT WAS.
OF COURSE, EMILY SAID, WE'VE
ALREADY CLEARED IT, IT'S FINE.
IT'S NOT THE SHOES WHY YOUR
INDIANS CAN HIT.
CHARLIE WAS AHEAD OF HIS TIME
WITH THAT.
HE WENT TO THE GREEN AND GOLD IN
1963, EVERY UNIFORM WAS BLUE OR
RED.
THAT WAS REVOLUTIONARY.
HE ACTUALLY PUT THE WHITE SHOES
ON THE A'S LOGO.
REMEMBER THAT?
THE SWINGING A'S?
SCOTT: YES.
TOM: CHARLIE ACTUALLY HAD A DEAL
WITH THE SHOE COMPANY.
IT WAS PART OF RAISING SOME
MONEY FOR A TEAM THAT DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT.
THE WHITE SHOES HAVE LIVED ON.
KELLY GREEN.
WEDDING GOWN WHITE, FORT KNOX
GOLD.
WHITE SHOES.
YOU CAN TRACE IT ALL BACK TO
CHARLIE FINLEY.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
YOU KNOW, HE ACTUALLY TOLD
PEOPLE AND THE MEDIA BOUGHT IT,
THAT THE WHITE SHOES CAME FROM
WHITE KANGAROOS IN AUSTRALIA.
THAT'S WHERE THE LEATHER CAME
FROM.
SCOTT: THAT WOULD NOT BE A GOOD
LOOK NOWADAYS.
TOM: NOWADAYS, THERE WOULD BE
FACT CHECKING GOING ON WITH
THAT.
SCOTT: GOOGLE IT.
SLICES THAT ONE FOUL.
TOM: DID YOU EVER SEE A WHITE
KANGAROO FROM AUSTRALIA?
SCOTT: CAN'T SAY I HAVE.
TOM: NO.
BUT PEOPLE RAN WITH IT.
SCOTT: YOU KNOW WHO I THINK DOES
HAVE AN ADVANTAGE FROM WEARING
WHITE CLEATS?
TYLER ROGERS OF THE GIANTS.
APPARENTLY, ONE OF HIS TEAMMATES
--
TOM: HE THROWS OFF OF THE
GROUND.
SCOTT: SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
MAYBE IT HELPS.
THE BALL IS COMING FROM THE
WHITE CLEATS.
HE'S A SUBMARINER.
TWO STRIKES ON CANHA.
PULLS ONE TO MAYFIELD.
BEAT HIM BY ABOUT A STEP AND A
HALF.
GETS THE JOB DONE.
OLSON IS STRANDED.
A'S STILL HANGING ON BY A RUN.
THE BULLPEN HAS TO SHUT THINGS
DOWN.
♪
>> BASEBALL IS A HARD GAME.
I GIVE CREDIT TO THE HITTERS, OF
COURSE.
AT THE SAME TIME, WHEN YOU ARE
FACING ME, I'M GOING TO TREAT
YOU LIKE I TREAT ANYBODY ELSE.
I DON'T CARE HOW BIG YOU ARE OR
HOW STRONG YOU ARE.
I'M GOING TO COME AT YOU WITH MY
BEST STUFF.
IF YOU GET A HIT, I WILL TO MY
CAP TO YOU.
I'M GOING TO COME AT YOU.
AS LONG AS YOU ARE IN THE BOX, I
WILL COME AT YOU AND BE
COMPETITIVE.
>> SWING AND A MISS.
>> SINKING FASTBALL.
OUTSIDE CORNER.
THAT >> >> IS STRIKE THREE.
THIS WHOLE BIG-LEAGUE EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN A GREAT, FUN, GREAT
ATMOSPHERE.
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF LEARNING.
THERE'S A LOT OF PARTS TO THE
GAME THAT I MISSED OUT FROM TWO
YEARS OF REHAB.
I'M STARTING TO LEARN NOW.
LUCKILY I HAVE A LOT OF VETERAN
GUYS HERE WHO HAVE TAKEN ME IN.
THEY HAVE HELPED ME OUT SO MUCH.
THEY TELL ME WHAT THEY SAY AND
WHAT THEY DON'T LIKE.
I NEED THAT.
YOU NEED CRITICISM.
YOU NEED GUYS TO REALLY COME TO
YOU AND TELL YOU WHAT THEY
THINK.
YOU BUILD OFF OF THAT.
>> MLB ORIGINAL SEASON TO HIS
LIVE ON YOUTUBE WITH NEW
EPISODES EVERY WEEK.
SEE YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS A
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE.
MLB CELEBRATES HISPANIC CARE TO
MONTH BY RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE TO OUR GAME
BY THE LATINO BASEBALL COMMUNITY
PAST AND PRESENT.
VISIT THE WEBSITE FOR FULL
COVERAGE.
GORGEOUS BALLPARK.
ADMITTEDLY, MY FIRST TIME HERE.
TOM: WHAT TOOK YOU SO LONG?
SCOTT: HADN'T HAD AGAIN HERE.
I DID SOME ANGELS.
TOM: IT'S A GREAT PLACE TO WATCH
A GAME.
YOU TO FULL.
RALLY MONKEYS ARE OUT.
SCOTT: ONE RUN GAME.
ALL SHAPES AND SIZES.
THOSE RALLY MONKEYS ARE GETTING
OLD.
TOM: THAT WAS A REAL THING IN
2002.
YOU FELT THE ENERGY IN THE
BALLPARK.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS HERE
AGAINST THE OAKLAND BULLPEN.
SCOTT: TRIVINO TAKES OVER.
FIRES THE FASTBALL.
96.
TRIVINO IS 30 YEARS OLD.
HE WAS THERE GUY IN THE NINTH
FOR A WHILE THIS YEAR.
AND THEN HE HAS FALLEN OFF
LATELY.
HE HAD SOME BACK ISSUES.
TOM: EXACTLY.
IN THIS CASE, HE'S THEIR GUY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ANGELS
LINEUP, YOU ARE AT 4, 5, 6 RIGHT
HERE.
THIS IS THE INNING YOU HAVE TO
CONTROL.
ESPECIALLY THE WALSH AT-BAT.
I WANT MY BEST ARM IN THE GAME
NOW, FACING THE BOTTOM THREE OF
THE ORDER IN THE NINTH.
SERGIO ROMO IS PROBABLY BEHIND
TRIVINO.
PLENTY OF EXPERIENCE CLOSING.
YOU TRUST HIM JUST AS MUCH.
THIS IS THE INNING YOU HAVE TO
CONTROL.
DECISIONS MADE MORE BECAUSE OF
WHERE YOU ARE IN THE BATTING
ORDER THAN THE INNING.
SCOTT: HE'S GOING UP AGAINST THE
32-YEAR-OLD JOURNEYMAN.
SCOTT: MAKES CONTACT, RIGHT SIDE
FOR CAMP.
HE'S GOT HIM.
BOB MELVIN AND THE OAKLAND A'S
HAVE HAD A STANDOUT BULLPEN FOR
YEARS.
THAT WAS THE CASE AGAIN UP UNTIL
THE MIDDLE OF AUGUST.
AND THEN THE WHEELS FELL OFF.
THE TEAM IS 11-17 SINCE THEN.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE ON THE
OUTSIDE LOOKING IN FOR A PLAYOFF
SPOT.
TOM: PARTLY BECAUSE IT DOVETAILS
WITH LOSING CHRIS BASSITT.
GETTING HIT BY THE LINE DRIVE.
HE IS PITCHING A GAME TOMORROW.
OF COURSE, EVERYONE IN BASEBALL
WISHES HIM THE BEST OF LUCK ON
HIS JOURNEY BACK FROM THAT
INJURY.
LOOK AT THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
BOB MELVIN DOES A GOOD JOB WITH
BULLPENS.
THE LAST FOUR YEARS, THEY ARE
PLAYING OVER 600 BASEBALL IN
SEPTEMBER.
THIS IS MORE THE ANOMALY WHERE
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN PLAYING WELL
AND PITCHING WELL IN SEPTEMBER.
SCOTT: JARED WALSH.
MATT CHAPMAN THERE.
DIDN'T HAVE TO MOVE MUCH.
GREAT ARM.
TWO DOWN.
TOM: ONE OF THE REASONS THEY
HAVE BEEN SUCH A CLOSING TEAM IS
BECAUSE BOB DOES SUCH A GOOD JOB
IN THE BULLPEN.
GETTING GUYS TO SEPTEMBER OR NOT
WORN OUT, STILL GAS IN THE TANK.
65-42 IN SEPTEMBER SINCE 2017.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING BY
ACCIDENT.
SCOTT: SCOTT: TWO TEAMS I THINK
ABOUT IN SEPTEMBER IN THE LAST
SEVERAL SEASON FEAR GIVES THE
A'S AND THE BREWERS.
THE WAY CRAIG CANCEL -- COUNCIL
MANAGES HIS TEAM IN A TIGHT
RACE.
THAT'S IN TIGHT TO SUZUKI.
THE BREWERS HAVE MORE FIRE IN
THEIR BULLPEN IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
THE A'S HAVE TO DO IT WITH
SOFTER STUFF, AT LEAST SOME OF
THEM.
TOM: THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
LOOK AT THE BULLPEN.
THERE'S NOT A BIG POWER ARM
SWING AND MISS GUY THAT WE SEE
MULTIPLE ARMS LIKE THAT AND MOST
MAJORLY BULLPENS.
THIS IS MORE A FINESSE BULLPEN
IF YOU WILL.
THEY DON'T WANT PEOPLE WHICH IS
GREAT.
THEY ARE GOING TO RELY ON THE
BALL IN PLAY FOR THE MOST PART.
THAT'S WHY THE DEFENSE IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR OAKLAND.
SCOTT: THE CURLS WITH SHAVEN.
ROMO SQUATTING DOWN.
HE COULD BE THE NINTH.
THAT'S A FAIR BALL.
CHAPMAN WITH THE ARM.
WAY OFF THE MARK.
SUZUKI WILL REACH.
TOM: SUCH A DANGEROUS PLAY FOR
THE FIRST BASEMAN.
WHEN THE THROW TAKES YOU INTO
THE RUNNER, YOU SAW CHAPMAN WHO
WAS SMART NOT TO THROW THE
GLOVED HAND OUT INTO THE BASE
PATH.
I THINK HE REALIZED, HE PROBABLY
DIDN'T HAVE SUZUKI.
YOU ARE CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
STICK THE ARM INTO THE WAY OF
THE RUNNER RIGHT THERE.
YEARS AGO, IT HAPPENED TO CLIFF
FLOYD.
I REMEMBER THAT ONE.
EXACTLY THE SAME KIND OF PLAY.
REALLY WASN'T THE SAME KIND OF
HITTER AFTER THAT, SUFFERING A
REALLY BATTING -- WRIST INJURY.
SCOTT: ANGELS ARE GOING TO PINCH
RUN.
THEY ARE CHECKING ON HIM.
HAD A BIG YEAR IN AAA.
SMART BASE RUNNER.
TOM: TRY TO PICK A BREAKING BALL
COUNT.
THERE WAS ONE RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: THESE ARE THE MONEY
BASES.
IF YOU CAN GET A STOLEN BASE, IT
IS MOST NEEDED.
TWO OUTS.
IT'S HARD TO SCORE IN A DOUBLE
BECAUSE THE OUTFIELD IS PLAYING
SO DEEP, YOU ARE DEFENDING THE
TYING RUN AT HOME BASE FROM
SCORING.
SCOTT: FALL START AT FIRST BUT
HE HAD A PRETTY GOOD JUMP OVER
THERE.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE'S STARTING TO
TIME TRIVINO.
IT'S HARD TO PLAY FOR THREE
CONSECUTIVE HITS WITH TWO OUTS,
BASES EMPTY.
STOLEN BASE.
OF COURSE, IT'S RISKY.
BUT NOT A BAD IDEA RIGHT HERE.
THERE'S NOT MUCH OF A LEAD
THOUGH.
JUST A STEP.
IF HE CAN GET MORE.
I LIKE RUNNERS, EVEN IF THEY ARE
NOT GOING, TO PUT PRESSURE ON
THE PITCHER BY EXPANDING THE
LEAD.
FORCING THE PITCHER TO BE A
LITTLE QUICKER TO THE PLATE,
LEAVE THE BALL UP.
TO CENTER.
STARLING MARTE RACING IN AND IT
WILL DROP.
JUAN KNEW IT.
HE'S HEADING FOR THROW -- THIRD.
THE THROW IS THERE.
STARLING MARTE MAKES A STANDOUT
PLAY.
PICKS UP THE OUTFIELD ASSIST.
INNING OVER.
THE OAKLAND A'S OUR MONEY ON
DEFENSE TO ESCAPE THE INNING.
TOM: GREAT PLAY BY MARTE.
HE TIMES THIS PERFECTLY.
YOU SEE HIM THROW UP TO MAKE
SURE HE GETS IT.
A BE A YOUNGER OUTFIELDER TRIES
TO MAKE A SHOW STRING CATCH.
PLACE IN FRONT OF THEM.
HE KNEW HE HAD WONG LINED UP IN
HIS SIGHTS.
>> WHY CAN'T YOU TRUST
GEOGRAPHERS?
THEY TRAVEL TOO MUCH.
THEY ARE ALL OVER THE MAP.
>> WHAT SOUND DOES A GIRAFFE
MAKE?
THAT'S A GOOD SOUND.
>> I'M SWEATING.
>> WHAT DOES A SIEGEL MAKE WHEN
HE EATS A BAD FISH?
[LAUGHTER]
>> HE'S CHOKING ON A FISH.
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
HOW BIG IS THE FISH?
>> A REALLY BAD MINNOW.
[LAUGHTER]
>> A WALRUS WITH A BAD TUMMY.
>> I CAN'T DO THAT.
I'M DONE.
WALRUS IS NOT MY FORTE.
♪
SCOTT: TYLAN TONIGHT.
THIS HAS NOT BEEN THE CLEANEST
GAME FOR THE ANGELS THIS SEASON.
ONLY DOWN A RUN.
TOM: YEAH.
THEY SURVIVE SO MANY
BASES-LOADED JAMS.
ALL NIGHT LONG, OAKLAND HAD THE
BASES LOADED.
HERE'S A DOUBLE PLAY.
AND THE INNING WITH THE BASES
LOADED.
IT IS SO HARD TO BELIEVE.
IT IS JUST A ONE RUN GAME WITH
AS MANY CHANCES AS OAKLAND HAS
HAD TO REALLY PUT THIS GAME OUT
OF REACH.
THERE'S THE NUMBERS RIGHT THERE.
ONE FOR SIX WITH THE BASES
LOADED.
SCOTT: SHOWED YOU EIGHT RUNNERS
LEFT IN THE ENTIRE GAME.
11 LEFT ON BASE FOR OAKLAND.
ONE FOR EIGHT WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
IT IS STEVE CISHEK TIME.
A BALL AND A STRIKE TO SETH
BROWN.
CHAPMAN ON DECK.
GOMES WILL FOLLOW.
TOM: THIS IS GAME NUMBER 68.
CISHEK IS THE TYPE OF PITCHER
WHERE HIS STUFF GETS BETTER.
WITH REGULAR WORK.
THAT'S THE MANAGER STREAM,
ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR.
-- MANAGERS DREAM, ESPECIALLY
THIS YEAR.
ONE THING HE HAS DONE, HE WILL
RUN FAST UP AND IN.
THAT CREATES A VERY UNUSUAL
ANGLE ON A PITCH THAT MOST
LEFT-HANDERS DON'T SEE BECAUSE
HE HAS THAT LOW RELEASE POINT.
SLIDER RIGHT THERE.
HE WILL THROW A TWO-SEAM
FASTBALL UP AND INTO LEFTIES.
IT CAN TIE HIM UP.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
MOST EVERYTHING HE THROWS, IT IS
GOING TO BE ARM SIDE.
OUTSIDE THE LEFTIES.
SCOTT: THIS IS A GREAT STORY ON
THE MOUND.
FOR THE ROUND, TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN OUT OF DIVISION II.
HE SAID HE KEPT LOWERING FROM
HIGH SCHOOL.
BROWN OFF THE GLOVE.
CISHEK.
STAYS WITH IT.
TOM: CHAPMAN IS COMING UP NEXT.
HE'S HAD A VERY DIFFICULT YEAR.
MORE FASTBALLS THAN ANY HITTER
IN THE BIG-LEAGUE.
LAST YEAR, FULLY HEALTHY.
HE IS NOT THE SAME HITTER.
THEY ATTENTION TO HIS HIPS.
HE IS FULLY OPEN IN 2020 BUT HE
IS NOT FULLY TURNED.
SAME PITCH, UP AND AWAY.
JUST A LITTLE BIT LATE OPENING
THOSE HIPS.
BETTER LATELY BUT DEFINITELY THE
FIRST HALF OF THE SEASON, COMING
OFF OF THE HIP SURGERY.
JUST PHYSICALLY LIMITED IN TERMS
OF HOW FAST HE CAN GET THOSE
HIPS WORKING.
MELVIN WAS TELLING US BEFORE THE
GAME, YOU SEE IT DEFENSIVELY.
HE WAS NOT HIMSELF THE SEASON.
YOU AREN'T SURE HOW THE BODY IS
GOING TO RESPOND.
SOME OF IT IS MENTAL BUT SOME OF
IT IS PHYSICAL.
USUALLY, YOU START TO SEE HE'S A
LITTLE BIT BETTER.
HIS FASTBALLS ARE WAY DOWN.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME SPEED
IN HIS HIPS.
SLIGHTLY LATE ON FASTBALLS.
THERE'S MAYFIELD.
TWO DOWN.
SCOTT: MAX STASSI, THERE HE IS
FINE THE PLATE.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE HOW MUCH HIPS
MATTER, WATCH SHOHEI OHTANI
SWING A BAT WITH HIS TORQUE.
WATCH HIM TURN ON A BASEBALL.
TOM: WATCH THE GREAT HITTERS IN
THE GAME.
PAY ATTENTION TO A GUYS ARMS AND
HANDS.
IT'S GREAT.
REALLY, POWER COMES FROM THE
GROUND UP.
GENERATING BAT SPEED, A LOT OF
TIMES MOST IF IT COMES FROM THE
HIPS AND HOW FAST YOU TURN YOUR
HIPS.
IF YOU WATCH THE OLYMPICS AND
YOU SEE SKATERS, WHEN THEY WANT
TO TURN FAST, THEY PULL THEIR
ARMS IN AND THE HIPS ROTATE
FAST.
WHEN THEY WANT TO SLOW DOWN, THE
ARMS GET AWAY FROM THE BODY AND
THE HIPS SLOW DOWN.
SCOTT: MORE WORK FOR JACK
MAYFIELD.
COOL, CALM, COLLECTED.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN.
NO EXTRA RUNS FOR THE A'S.
IN THE NINTH, WE GO TO THE LAST
CHANCE FOR THE ANGELS.
SERGIO ROMO TAKING OVER TO TRY
TO SHUT THE DOOR.
♪
>> THAT'S OUT.
>> YOU CAN TELL HIS TALENT LEVEL
WAS ABOVE THE REST OF THE PEOPLE
ON THE FIELD.
HE WAS DESTINED FOR SOMETHING
GREAT ON THE BASEBALL DIAMOND.
>> I THOUGHT I WAS AN OK PLAYER
UNTIL YOU MEET A GUY LIKE TROUT.
>> WHAT A CATCH BY MIKE TROUT.
>> CAN HIT FOR POWER, HIT FOR
AVERAGE.
THE WAY HE RUNS.
I SAID, YOU HAVE A LITTLE SOUL
AND YOU.
THAT'S PRETTY FAST.
>> HE'S VERY STRONG.
HE HAS A FOOTBALL TYPE OF BODY.
IT'S ABLE TO LOOK STILL GRACEFUL
ON A BASEBALL DIAMOND, WHETHER
IT IS STEALING BASES, TRACKING
DOWN FLY BALLS.
>> HE IS THE BEST PLAYER I'VE
EVERY -- EVER SEEN.
>> HE'S GOING TO BE SPECIAL.
HE ALREADY IS.
>> IT IS SO PAINFUL.
AS A FAN, HE IS JUST SUCH A
MARVEL TO WATCH.
>> THIS KID IS A STUD.
STU D.
♪
SCOTT: BOTTOM NINE.
LAST CHANCE FOR THE ANGELS.
IT'S THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK,
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
STARLING MARTE.
94.4 ON THE OUTFIELD ASSIST.
FIRST TO THIRD.
I DON'T THINK SO.
SECOND HARDEST THROW FROM
STARLING MARTE ON THE SEASON.
HE WAS LOCKED AND LOADED.
TOM: THAT WAS VELO PLUS COMMAND.
YOU WON'T SEE 94 THIS GUY.
SERGIO ROMO.
YOU ALL KNOW ABOUT HIS SLIDER.
SLIDER SAME CHANGEUPS.
YOU SEE A LOT OF THEM HERE.
VARIED THE BREAK ON THAT SLIDER.
TWO STRIKES.
HE'S GOING TO. THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
THE LEFTIES AND RIGHTIES.
SCOTT: 38 YEARS OLD.
SEASON NUMBER 14 FOR ROMO AND A
SAVE CHANCE.
THE A'S ENTER THE DAY THREE
GAMES AWAY FROM PLAYOFF SPOTS.
WE WILL UPDATE STANDINGS FOR
YOU.
POST GAME SHOW COMING UP.
IF OAKLAND CAN CLOSE THIS OUT.
TOM: ROMO WILL THROW ENOUGH
TWO-SEAMERS INTO RIGHTIES TO
OPEN UP THE OUTSIDE PART OF THE
PLATE WITH THE SLIDER.
SCOTT: JACK MAYFIELD HAD A LOT
OF ACTION IN THE TOP.
THERE'S 86.
TOM: THAT'S THE FASTBALL.
SCOTT: THE DAY FOR JACK.
TOM: THAT'S A GOOD TAKE BY
MAYFIELD.
EXACTLY THE PITCH ROMO WANTS YOU
TO BITE ON.
THAT SLIDER STARTS ON THE PLATE,
MOOSE OFF.
-- MOVE SOFT.
LET THE BALL TRAVEL.
DON'T GET ANXIOUS.
SCOTT: THE A'S HAVE EXPERIENCED
REALLY DEVASTATING LOSSES OVER
THE PAST TWO WEEKS.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN THE ISSUE.
THE OFFENSE HAS BEEN PUTTING UP
BIG NUMBERS THIS MONTH.
THERE'S THIS SWING AND MISS FROM
ROMO.
THEY DID RECOVER WELL THIS WEEK.
JUST A SIX RUN LEAD IN THE THIRD
INNING ON TUESDAY AGAINST KANSAS
CITY.
IT TURNED INTO A 10-SEVEN LOSS.
THAT CAN REALLY DEFLATE A
BALLCLUB.
THEY WON THE NEXT TWO AND HERE
THEY ARE ON A FRIDAY NIGHT.
STRIKEOUT.
SERGIO ROMO WITH A BIG START TO
THE NINTH.
TOM: YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT A GOOD
PITCH WHEN YOU CAN THROW IT FOUR
TIMES IN A ROW, LEAVE THIS ONE
OVER THE PLATE, AND STILL GET
THE SWING AND MISS FOR STRIKE
THREE.
THE SPIN ON THAT.
REALLY GETS TO THE SIDE OF THE
BASEBALL.
REALLY LONG FINGAL'S -- FINGERS
ENABLES HIM TO DO THAT.
THE BALL WAS ALMOST SPINNING.
SCOTT: HERE'S JOSÉ ROJAS,
PINCHHITTING FOR LAGARES.
CALLED STRIKE.
TOM: WE'VE SEEN THAT PITCH
CALLED A STRIKE TONIGHT.
IT'S A CREDIT AGAIN TO THE JOB
GOMES DOES BACK THERE WITH VERY
QUIET HANDS.
SCOTT: YOU MIGHT AS WELL TEST
IT.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSÉ ROJAS HOMERED YESTERDAY, BY
THE WAY.
A WIN FOR THE ANGELS OVER THE
WHITE SOX.
THREE HOME RUNS IN HIS LAST FIVE
BIG LEAGUE GAMES.
THAT'S WRAPPED AROUND A TWO
MONTH STINT IN THE MINORS.
TOM: IT'S INTERESTING THAT THE
A'S HAVE CHAPMAN REMAINING UP AT
THIRD BASE.
MOST CASES, ONCE THERE'S ONE
STRIKE ON A BATTER, THEY DO NOT
HONOR THE BUNT ATTEMPT.
RIGHT HERE, THEY ARE STILL
DEFENDING THE BUNT ATTEMPT.
ONE STRIKE ON ROJAS.
SCOTT: GOING TO THE RIGHT SIDE.
IT'S A FOUL BALL.
TOM: JUST AMAZING HOW ROMO
CONTINUES TO GIVE HITTERS OUT IN
FRONT OF HIS SLIDER.
SCOTT: NOW CHAPMAN IS FAR AWAY.
THE ANGELS HAD TO SAD BUNTS IN
THE SECOND.
THAT WAS THE BEGINNING.
FOR RUNS.
RIGHT SIDE.
EATS UP KEMP.
PINCH HITTER JOSÉ ROJAS IS A
BOARD.
TOM: LET'S SEE WHERE THIS BALL
HIT.
IT MIGHT HAVE HIT THE LIP OF THE
GRASS WHERE THE DIRT MEETS THE
GRASS.
WOW.
YOU DON'T SUE TOO MANY -- SEE
TOO MANY BAD HOPS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
RIGHT WHERE THE DIRT MEETS THE
GRASS.
THE BALL CAME UP.
NOTHING THAT HE COULD TWO.
SCOTT: 109.8 MILES PER HOUR OFF
OF THE BAT.
KNOCKED HIM DOWN MATRIX STYLE.
TOM: HE GOT KNOCKED OVER BY A
GROUNDBALL.
SCOTT: IN THE OUTFIELD.
THAT IS SERIOUS EXIT VELOCITY.
THAT'S A BASE HIT FOR JOSÉ
ROJAS.
HERE'S BRANDON MARSH.
FIRST, CHECK.
THE ANGELS DON'T HAVE ANOTHER
POSITION PLAYER TO RUN.
THIS IS IT.
TOM: THE BENCH IS EMPTY.
TOM:THEY LOADED UP ON RELIEF
PITCHERS.
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY
WHEN IT COMES TO POSITION
PLAYERS.
SCOTT: I KNOW HE LOOKS LIKE A
GRIZZLED VET BUT HE'S A ROOKIE.
24-YEAR-OLD BRANDON MARSH.
BOB MELVIN.
TOM: COUNTING THE SPOTS TO
SHOHEI OHTANI.
SCOTT: IT'S GETTING CLOSE.
MARCH NOW.
FLETCHER ON DECK.
OHTANI WOULD FOLLOW.
SOLID CONTACT.
THE CENTRAL.
STARLING MARTE RUNS IT DOWN.
TOM: HAVE A NIGHT, STARLING
MARTE.
HE WAS PLAYING ALL THE WAY OVER
TO THE LEFT GAP.
SEE WHERE HE SAID IT UP?
THAT WAS A GREAT REACTION.
MADE IT LOOK EASY.
ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE TRACK.
HE HAD THAT ONE LINED UP ALL THE
WAY, STRUCK WELL.
SCOTT: MARTE WAS MOVING BACK.
HE IS SO SMOOTH OUT THERE.
ACCORDING TO STATCAST, THAT
WOULD BE 50% HIT PROBABILITY.
NOT TONIGHT.
HERE'S FLETCHER.
FIRST PITCH STRIKE.
OHTANI ON DECK.
A'S UP A RUN.
FLETCHER REACHES.
-- IF FLETCHER REACHES.
FLETCHER IN THE AIR.
THAT SHOULD BE NO PROBLEM FOR
CAMP.
GAME OVER.
A'S HANG ON.
THEY WIN IT 5-4.
IT'S WIN NUMBER 80 ON THE SEASON
FOR OAKLAND.
SERGIO ROMO GETS THE JOB DONE.
JUST BARELY AVOIDS FACING SHOHEI
OHTANI WITH THE GAME ON THE
LINE.
WHO IS TONIGHT'S YOUTUBE PLAYER
OF THE GAME?
THE POLL IS OPEN.
THERE YOUR CHOICES.
LET US KNOW.
VOTING BEGINS NOW.
WE WILL HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE WINNING BALLCLUB, A COUPLE
OAKLAND A'S PLAYERS WILL JOIN US
ON THE POSTGAME SHOW WHICH
STARTS RIGHT NOW.
♪
LET'S BEGIN THE POSTGAME SHOW.
WE ARE STILL LIVE ON YOUTUBE FOR
ANOTHER 30 MINUTES.
ALL THINGS OAKLAND A'S.
A 5-4 NAILBITER FOR OAKLAND
WHERE THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN
TESTED OFTEN LATELY AND FAILED
QUITE A BIT.
NOT TONIGHT.
TOM: THEY'VE BEEN WORKED A LOT
LATELY.
DIEKMAN TO TRIVINO TO ROMO GOT
THE JOB DONE.
SCOTT: LET'S TALK THROUGH WITH
JOSH HARRISON.
I KNOW THAT THE PEN HAS BEEN
THROUGH A LOT LATELY.
HOW MUCH CAN THIS MEAN FOR THE
TEAM GOING FORWARD WHEN YOU KNOW
YOUR TEAM WILL HAVE TO?
?
GO ON A SERIOUS RUN >> EVERY WIN
IS PRECIOUS.
WE HAVE TO TAKE IT ONE GAME AT A
TIME.
WE HAVE TO CONTROL OUR OWN
DESTINY.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN TESTED BUT
NOT JUST THE BULLPEN.
THAT'S BASEBALL.
THERE WILL BE ABSENT FLOWS AND
WE HAVE TO FIGHT THROUGH.
TOM: YOU HAD THREE CONSECUTIVE
PLATE APPEARANCES WITH THE BASES
LOADED.
HAS THAT HAPPENED TO YOU BEFORE?
WHAT IS YOUR APPROACH?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
ANY TIME THAT SITUATION, THE
LAST THING YOU WANT TO DO IS HIT
A DOUBLE PLAY.
YOU GET PRESENTED THREE TIMES IN
A ROW, I WILL TAKE WHAT I GOT.
A BASE HIT, A SAC FLY, A DOUBLE
PLAY.
I'M STILL SATISFIED WITH THE
APPROACH THAT I HAD.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO GET THE RUN
ACROSS ANY WAY THAT I COULD.
EVERY RUN IS PRECIOUS IN THESE
MOMENTS.
SCOTT: THERE WERE ERRORS EARLY,
WHICH DOESN'T HAPPEN VERY OFTEN.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, THERE WERE
OUTSTANDING PLAYS.
MATT OLSON DOES IT QUIETLY
SOMETIMES.
MATT CHAPMAN.
FANTASTIC PLACE TONIGHT AS WELL.
WHAT'S IT LIKE WITH THE FIRST
ROW SEATS, TO SEE HER FRIENDS
GETTING?
THE JOB DONE?
-- SEEING YOUR FRIENDS GETTING
THE JOBS DONE?
>> I DIDN'T GET TO SEE THEM
UNTIL I PLAYED WITH THEM.
THEY ARE THE BEST COMBO IN THE
LEAGUE.
I PUT THAT UP AGAINST ANYBODY.
TOM: YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
STARLING MARTE.
HOW ABOUT THAT THROW HE MADE TO
THIRD BASE?
CUTS DOWN THE RUNNER AT THIRD
BASE FOR THE THIRD OUT OF THE
INNING.
DESCRIBE THAT PLAY AS YOU SAW
HIM LINEUP THE THROW TO THIRD
BASE.
>> BIG-TIME PLAY.
MARTE, THAT ISN'T ANYTHING I
HAVEN'T SEEN FROM HIM.
FOR MOST PEOPLE, THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF OFFENSIVE STUFF THAT HE'S
DONE.
IT SHOWS HE'S A COMPLETE PLAYER.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A HIT TONIGHT.
HE MADE SOME GOOD PLAYS WHEN
THEY COUNTED.
THAT HAS -- THAT'S HOW IT IS.
SCOTT: WE APPRECIATE THE TIME.
CONGRATS ON THE W TONIGHT.
A BIG WEEKEND FOR THE ANGELS.
WE WILL CHAT AGAIN SOON.
>> THANK YOU.
SCOTT: WE WILL STEP ASIDE FOR A
MOMENT AND SHOW YOU HIGHLIGHTS
FROM THIS ONE.
I FEEL LIKE WE HAD A LITTLE BIT
OF EVERYTHING TONIGHT.
IN THE FIRST FEW INNINGS ALONE,
IT WAS ACTION-PACKED.
YES, MATT OLSON AND THE OAKLAND
A'S ARE VICTORIOUS TONIGHT.
THEY ARE HANGING AROUND FOR THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
WRAP YOUR HOTDOGS.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
GOOD BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT ONE WILL GO.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> TALK ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
♪
SCOTT: THE OAKLAND A'S HAVE WON
THREE IN A ROW.
RIDE THE WAVES.
UPS, DOWNS AND IT'S WORKING
AGAIN FOR OAKLAND.
THEY ARE 2.5 GAMES OUT OF THE
WILD-CARD SEED WITH THE BLUE
JAYS FALLING TONIGHT.
HOW DID IT ALL HAPPEN?
LET'S RUN THROUGH IT.
FLETCHER, FIVE FOR NINE LIFETIME
AGAINST THE A'S.
NEXT CONTACT.
CHIP SHOT TO RIGHT FIELD.
CLASSIC FROM FLETCHER.
ONE OUT BASE RUNNER FOR THE
ANGELS.
TOM: THERE'S THE TRAFFIC.
>> [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
TOM: HARRISON GOT HIT BY A PITCH
TO START THE GAME.
DIAZ HAS BEEN PITCHING OUT OF
THE STRETCH.
SCOTT: THAT'S A GROUND BALL
THROUGH THE INFIELD.
HE'S OFF TO A GOOD START AGAIN.
JOSH HARRISON WITH THE R.B.I.
KNOCK.
1-0 OAKLAND.
THE BAGS FULL OF A'S.
OLSON CONNECTS.
MARSH TRACKING BACK, GIVING IT A
LOOK.
HE'S GOT IT.
THIS TIME, GOOD ENOUGH TO SCORE
A RUN.
HERE COMES DAVIS.
2-0 OAKLAND ON THE SAC FLY.
TOM: HE GREW UP 10 MILES AWAY
FROM HERE.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
SCOTT: SUZUKI CLOCKS ONE.
IT'S GONE.
THE ANGELS ARE ON THE BOARD.
A SOLO SHOT FOR KURT SUZUKI TO
LIGHTED UP.
NOBODY DOWN IN THE SECOND.
A CHANCE FOR LAGARES.
IT'S DOWN.
HERE COMES WHEN HE FOR.
SMALL BALL CITY.
THAT WILL SHOCK EVERYONE.
THAT CREATES A FUMBLE.
TOM: PERFECTLY EXECUTED.
SCOTT: FLETCHER WITH OHTANI ON
DECK.
OPEN SPACE, LEFT.
THE ANGELS WILL GRAB THE LEAD.
LAGARES, COME ON DOWN.
4-2.
TOM: I BELIEVE THIS IS AT-BAT
NUMBER SIX FOR THE OAKLAND A'S.
WE ARE ONLY IN THE THIRD INNING.
SCOTT: HARRISON CONNECTS IN THE
AIR.
LAGARES IS GOING TO MAKE THE
CATCH.
CHAPMAN ON THE RUN.
HE'S IN THERE.
A'S GET A RUN, MAKE IT 4-3
OAKLAND.
MATT CHAPMAN CHARGING
BAREHANDED.
WE GOT HIM.
SHOWING OFF.
OLSON WITH THE PICK.
SIDE RETIRED.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THAT WAS DISGUSTING.
SCOTT: THERE WAS AN EARTHQUAKE
REGISTERED ABOUT 25 MILES FROM
ANGEL STADIUM, MAGNITUDE 4.3.
CARSON, CALIFORNIA.
I DIDN'T FEEL A THING.
THIS IS GOING TO BRING UP ROB.
VERY PRODUCTIVE GROUND OUT FOR
SETH BROWN.
THE A'S HAVE CAUGHT OUT.
MCKENNA AT THIRD.
THAT IS PAST SUZUKI.
THE A'S GRAB THE LEAD.
TOM: TOUGHENING.
REALLY GOOD DEFENSE OF CATCHING.
SCOTT: THE THROW IS IN THERE.
TOUGHENING FOR KURT SUZUKI.
THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO HEAD BACK
TO THE DUGOUT.
LET'S HEAD INTO THE HOME EIGHT.
THE ANGELS HAVE ONE ON.
LUIS RENGIFO.
STARLING MARTE HAS AN ARM.
TOM: YEAH.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS THE KEY PLAY
FOR THE GAME.
YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF ARM
STARLING MARTE HAS.
IT WAS THROW 94 MILES PER HOUR
ON TARGET.
INSTEAD OF FIRST AND SECOND
RALLY IN PLACE, TYING RUN ON
SECOND.
THE A'S ARE BACK IN THE DUGOUT
WITH THE LEAD PRESERVED.
HUGE PLAY IN THE GAME.
STARLING MARTE.
SCOTT: AND THE CELEBRATION.
SERGIO ROMO IN THE NINTH.
ROMO AGAINST ROJAS.
THAT WAS A TOUGH SHOT.
WE ARE BOUNCE.
HARD OFF OF THE BAT OF TONY
KEMP.
TOM: HE GOT KNOCKED OVER BY A
GROUND BALL, FOLKS.
THAT DIDN'T BOTHER SERGIO ROMO.
RIGHT BACK TO WORK AGAIN.
RUNNING THE BALL DOWN ON THE
TRACK FOR THE SECOND OUT.
SCOTT: THAT WAS HARD TO.
BRANDON MARSH AND SERGIO ROMO
KNOWS HE HAS A.
DAVID FLETCHER FLIES OUT.
THEY AVOID SHOHEI OHTANI WHO WAS
LOOMING ON TACK.
A'S TAKE IT 5-4.
THEY ENTER THE DAY WITH A 4.4%
PLAYOFF CHANCE.
TO ME, THAT FEELS LOW.
TOM: THAT IS TOO LOW.
SCOTT: OAKLAND IS ONLY 2.5 GAMES
OUT.
THE BLUE JAYS FELL TONIGHT.
THE YANKEES AND RED SOX
CURRENTLY HOLD THE WILD-CARD
SEATS.
THEY WILL HAVE TO GO ON A RUN
BUT THIS COULD BE THE KEY
WEEKEND TO JUMPSTART IT.
THEY'VE WON THREE IN A ROW.
FOR THE ANGELS, THAT'S FIVE IN A
ROW HEADING INTO THE MARINERS
AND ASTROS.
THOSE ARE NOT EASY TASKS.
THE MARINERS ARE STILL FIGHTING
FOR A WILD-CARD SEAT EVEN THOUGH
IT WILL BE A TOUGH ROAD AHEAD
FOR THEM.
THE THING I WILL SAY ABOUT
HOUSTON, THEY ARE GEARING UP AT
THIS POINT FOR THE PLAYOFFS.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY WILL BE A
PUSHOVER.
THE LINEUP IS NOT EASY TO
HANDLE.
THEY ARE NOT FIGHTING FOR THEIR
PLAYOFF LIVES AT THE MOMENT.
TOM: IT'S A TOUGH DRAW.
OAKLAND HAS TO GO 12-4 TO GET
THE 91, THE NUMBER FOR THE
WILD-CARD.
THAT WON'T BE EASY AGAINST TWO
TEAMS THEY'VE HAD TROUBLE WITH.
SEATTLE AND HOUSTON.
SCOTT: THEY ARE AFFORDED FOR
LOSSES, ACCORDING TO YOU.
TOM: EVERY WIN, IT BECOMES MORE
AND MORE POSSIBLE.
THE 4% CHANCE KEEPS GOING UP
WITH EACH WIN.
SCOTT: OAKLAND WAS SITTING
PRETTY OF YOU WEEKS BACK.
THE OFFENSE HAS BEEN CONSISTENT.
ESPECIALLY IN THE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER.
THE MAN LEADING THE CHARGE THIS
YEAR HAS BEEN MATT OLSON.
CRAIG NOLAN HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH THE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
THE TROPHY IS ALL YOURS.
IT MAKES SENSE.
IF WE COULD GIVE A YOUTUBE SHOW
TROPHY PLAYER OF THE YEAR FOR
THIS BALLCLUB, IT WOULD BE THIS
GUY.
TOM: HE HAS M.V.P. NUMBERS.
HE HITS FOR POWER.
THE DEFENSE AS WELL.
WE SAW THAT AGAIN TONIGHT.
MATT CHAPMAN GETS IT DONE ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BALL.
SCOTT: 35%.
EVERYONE WAS 20 PLUS.
A COMPETITIVE VOTE.
EVERYONE SAYS MATT OLSON DOES
ENOUGH.
SAC FLY, A WALK, A COUPLE HITS.
A GREAT CONVERSATION WITH BRETT
DOLAN.
TAKE IT AWAY.
BRETT: HE'S UP TO 102 R.B.I.S ON
THE SEASON.
ABOUT THE GREAT CAMPAIGNS WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
THIS YEAR.
WE TALKED ABOUT OHTANI AND
STARLING MARTE.
VLADDY MIGHT WIN THE TRIPLE
CROWN.
SALVADOR PEREZ HAS BEEN
FANTASTIC.
102 R.B.I.S.
HE'S DOING HIS PART TO PUSH
OAKLAND TOWARDS THE POSTSEASON
RUN.
I HAD A CHANCE TO CATCH UP TO
HIM MOMENTS AGO.
TO HIT SEND IN R.B.I. TODAY.
EVERY TIME WE LOOKED UP, THERE
WERE RUNNERS ON BASE.
YOU PUT A LOT OF PRESSURE ON THE
ANGELS TONIGHT.
>> WE DID.
WE LEFT A LOT OUT THERE.
IT WAS GOOD TO GET THE WIN.
ERVIN GAVE THOSE RUNS UP EARLY.
A GREAT START FOR HIM, A GOOD
WIN FOR US.
BRETT: THIS MONTH HASN'T GONE
PERFECTLY BUT THE OFFENSE IS
EXTREMELY CONSISTENT.
>> WE'VE BEEN BACK AND FORTH ALL
YEAR.
HOPEFULLY THESE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS, EVERYTHING SINKS UP AND
WE CAN MAKE A RUN.
WE ARE STILL IN A SPOT TO DO
SOME DAMAGE IN THE PLAYOFFS.
WHEN SOME GAMES HERE AT THE END.
BRETT: IT WAS FUN WATCHING YOUR
DUGOUT.
THEY WERE EXCITED TO BE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS.
DOES THAT COME FROM HAVING BEEN
IN SO MANY BIG GAMES THE LAST
FEW YEARS?
>> YES.
EVERYBODY IS FOCUSED ON WINNING.
WE ARE JUST BETTER WHEN WE ARE
LOOSE.
WHEN WE GET HOT, WE STAY HOT.
WE PLAY LOOSE.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
DOWN THE STRETCH.
BRETT: WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO GET
THE SECOND WILD-CARD?
>> WE'VE GOT TO WIN AND SHOW UP
EVERY DAY.
BRETT: THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THEY'VE GOT TO WIN, FACING ALL
AMERICAN LEAGUE WEST COMPETITION
THE REMAINDER OF THE WAY.
I BELIEVE THIS WAS OUR FIRST
LOCKER ROOM PRESENTATION OF OUR
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
I THOUGHT ABOUT RUNNING IN THERE
TO PRESENT IT MYSELF.
I COULD HAVE BEEN THE FIRST
MEDIA MEMBER IN THE LOCKER ROOM
INTO YEARS.
HE WILL GET THE TROPHY AND THE
A'S GET THE WIN.
A BIG DISAPPOINTING GAME ON
TUESDAY WHEN THEY BLEW THEIR
LEAVE.
IF THEY KEEP WINNING, THEY ARE
STILL VERY MUCH ALIVE FORGETTING
THE SECOND WILD-CARD ONCE AGAIN.
SCOTT: IT IS 2.5.
THIS IS UPDATED FOR YOU.
ALL THE GAMES ARE DONE TONIGHT.
BOSTON IS A HALF GAME UP.
THEY HAVE THE FIRST WILD-CARD
SPOT.
IF THE SEASON ENDED TODAY, IT
WOULD BE YANKEES RED SOX, MAYBE
AT FENWAY.
THE BLUE JAYS ARE SAYING, DON'T
FORGET ABOUT US.
DYNAMIC OFFENSE.
STARTING PITCHING HAS BEEN
SUPREME FOR THEM.
OAKLAND IS 2.5 GAMES AWAY.
THEY ARE THE QUIET UNDERDOG AT
THIS POINT IN THE STANDINGS.
THEY AREN'T OUT OF IT.
TOM: THEIR OFFENSE IS CLICKING
ON ALSO WONDERS.
I'M NOT RULING OUT A POTENTIAL
GAME FOR THE 163.
HOW GREAT WOULD THAT BE?
MORE GAMES, MORE CHAOS.
SCOTT: I WILL MAKE ANOTHER BOLD
CALLED.
I'M THING ABOUT THE M.V.P.
CONVERSATION.
SHOHEI OHTANI TOOK IT BY A
LANDSLIDE.
83% OF THE PIE SAID OHTANI
VERSUS VLADDY JR..
OHTANI, VLADDY JR., SALVADOR
PEREZ, AND MATT OLSON.
I THINK YOU COULD TAKE THOSE
FOR, PUT THEM IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE, AND I COULD SEE ANY OF
THEM WINNING THE M.V.P. OVER THE
GUY WHO TAKES IT IN THE NL.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
TOM: WHOEVER THAT MAY BE.
MATT OLSON HAD A TOUGH YEAR LAST
YEAR.
I REMEMBER TALKING TO HIM IN
SPRING TRAINING.
HE WENT BACK TO THE DRAWING
BOARD AND FIXED A FLAW IN HIS
SWING.
HE CHANGE THE ANGLE OF HIS BAT
GOING INTO THIS ON.
HE HAD A BAD HABIT OF CUTTING
UPHILL.
HE TORE UP THE CACTUS LEAGUE.
USUALLY THAT MEANS NOTHING.
THE BALL TRAVELS THERE.
IT'S NOT REGULAR SEASON
BASKETBALL.
IN THIS CASE, IT FORESHADOWED
THE SEASON THAT HE HAD.
HE CRUSHED IT.
THAT GOT HIM BACK ON TRACK.
SCOTT: TOO MUCH LAUNCH ANGLE.
HE'S THE FLY BALL MAN.
HE HAS CUT HIS STRIKEOUT RATE IN
HALF.
BIGGEST DECREASE IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
THAT'S A GREAT THING FOR HIM.
STILL MAKING STRONG CONTACT.
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST IN THE
BUSINESS.
HE'S TOP THREE IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE IN OPS AND OAKLAND IS NOT
A HITTER'S BALLPARK.
THE REGULAR OPS DOES NOT FACTOR
IN WHERE YOU ARE PLAYING.
OAKLAND HAS A TON OF EXTRA FOUL
GROUND AND MATT HAS BEEN AWESOME
FOR OAKLAND.
HE'S YOUR YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
OAKLAND FIVE, ANGELS FOUR.
GORGEOUS NIGHT HERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
WE WILL HANG OUT WITH YOU ALL
NIGHT LONG.
ONE MORE SEGMENT TO GO.
BACK.
FIVE OR 10 MINUTES TO TALK ABOUT
THESE TWO AND WHAT'S NEXT FOR US
ON YOUTUBE NEXT WEEK.
♪
>> HOW GREAT WAS IT?
THAT PROLONGED MY LIFE SIX OR
SEVEN YEARS BECAUSE HE WAS THE
CLOSER.
HE WOULD COME OUT THERE AND GO
10 PITCHES AND YOU ARE SHAKING
HANDS.
>> THE GAME IS OVER THAT
QUICKLY.
>> I COULD NOT REMEMBER SEEING A
PITCHER BE ABLE TO THROW STRIKES
WHEREVER HE WANTED TO THROW
THEM.
>> LOOK AT THAT LOCATION.
>> HE WAS LIKE A MUSKETEER, A
MARKSMAN.
>> HE'S ALWAYS AHEAD IN THE
COUNT.
HE IS JUST AMAZING.
>> LOOKS LIKE A DEMON.
PAINS LIKE A MAN SHOW.
>> HE IS HANDSOME.
HE IS SHOOTING THEM DOWN.
THERE WAS HARD FEELINGS AND HE
DIDN'T CARE.
IT'S LIKE, TOO BAD.
GET A HIT NEXT TIME.
>> THE HITTERS CAN SENSE A
PITCHER WHEN HE'S NOT CONFIDENT.
I TRY TO PLAY THE PART.
>> YOU HAD TO PLAY THE PART.
I PLAYED THIS CONFIDENT GUY.
DEEP DOWN INSIDE, THAT WASN'T ME
AT ALL.
♪
>> HI SEAN.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M DOING GREAT.
>> HI JAMES.
I LOVE JAMES.
BEST UMPIRE IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
>> WHAT?
WHAT?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THAT WAS DISGUSTING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> PROBABLY WHAT SHOHEI FEELS
LIKE EVERY DAY.
COAL SWERVING, OCTOBER 16TH,
DROPPING.
THE KID IS NASTY.
HE COULD BE ON THE SAME
BATTLEFIELD AS COAL SWERVING
IRVING.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE YOU'RE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD LIKE US.
THE OAKLAND A'S.
MATT OLSON BOMB, 2-0, HANGING
SLIDER.
FOR LATE JOHNSON.
NICE.
DO SOMETHING FOR YOUTUBE.
>> THAT'S BACK-TO-BACK DAYS,
BABY.
>> YEAH!
THAT WAS NASTY!
>> ONE MORE TIME.
>> YEAH.
IF YOU WANT TO GET REALLY GOOD
AT SOMETHING, LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
BASEBALL, YOU CAN WATCH YOUTUBE
VIDEOS ALL DAY LONG OF YOUR
FAVORITE PLAYERS.
THE ONLY REASON I CAN GIVE THIS
ADVICE IS BECAUSE I DID IT
MYSELF.
I WOULD WATCH JOHAN SANTANA, TIM
LINCECUM, STEPHEN STRASBURG.
MAN.
THESE BOYS.
WATCH THEM, RE-CREATE WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO.
HELL YEAH.
GOOD ONE EVERYONE.
GOOD BOY.
NICE.
SCOTT: SEAN MANAEA, A PLUS.
HAD SOME GREAT CALLS.
GENUINE CALLS.
AND JUST LOVING IT ON HIS
YOUTUBE VIDEOS.
GENUINELY TELLING HIS STORY.
HE WATCHED SOME OF HIS FAVORITES
ON YOUTUBE AND LOOK WHERE HE IS
NOW.
TOM: NOW I WANT TO SEAN MANAEA
YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
I WOULD WATCH.
SCOTT: YOU HAVE TO GO TO COLE
IRVIN'S PAGE WHICH OPENS UP
SOON.
THE A'S HOPE TO BE PLAYING DEEP
INTO OCTOBER BUT THEY NEED TO
GET THROUGH SEPTEMBER 1.
THIS IS WHAT THEY HAVE LEFT.
TWO MORE AGAINST THE ANGELS AND
THEN MARINERS AND ASTROS.
THAT'S IT.
THAT'S NOT FUN.
THOSE ARE THE OTHER TWO STRONG
TEAMS IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
WEST.
INCLUDING A SEATTLE BALLCLUB
THAT MATHEMATICALLY IS IN A
CHALLENGING SPOT.
THEY'VE PLAYED REALLY
COMPETITIVE BASEBALL THE ENTIRE
SEASON.
YOU AREN'T LOOKING AT ANY OF
THOSE SERIES AND THINKING ABOUT
HOW OAKLAND WILL SWEEP THROUGH.
I KNOW STRENGTH OF SCHEDULE CAN
BE A CONTROVERSIAL TOPIC.
SOMETIMES TEAMS GET HOT LATE IN
THE YEAR.
ME, I WOULD RATHER PLAY A TEAM
LIKE BALTIMORE THAN A TEAM LIKE
SEATTLE TOM: OR HOUSTON.
THEY ARE DIVISION RIVALS.
THERE ARE NO SECRETS AT THIS
POINT.
LET'S NOT GET TOO FAR AHEAD.
TWO MORE GAMES HERE AGAINST THE
ANGELS INCLUDING, THEY ARE GOING
TO SEE SHOHEI OHTANI WHO IS
RETURNING TO THE MOUND ON
SUNDAY.
FIRST THINGS FIRST, THERE IS NO
LOOKING FORWARD.
THE ONLY WAY THE A'S THINK ABOUT
POSTSEASON, THEY DO WHAT THEY
DID TONIGHT.
TAKE CARE OF BUSINESS WITH THE
GAME THAT IS RIGHT IN FRONT OF
YOU.
OHTANI BACK ON THE MOUND IS GOOD
FOR ANYBODY WHO'S A BASEBALL
FAN.
SCOTT: WE DIDN'T KNOW IF WE
WOULD SEE HIM AGAIN.
THERE WAS A CHANCE THAT HE WOULD
PITCH TODAY AFTER ALEX COBB CAME
BACK.
WE SAID, IT'S OHTANI'S TERM.
HE HAD ARM SORENESS.
IT WILL ONLY PUSH HIM BACK A
COUPLE DAYS.
HE IS SCHEDULED FOR SUNDAY.
THE HALOS ARE FULL OF
SUPERSTARS.
THIS IS LIKELY GOING TO BE A
SIXTH CONSECUTIVE SEASON OF SUB
500 BASEBALL, THREE GAMES UNDER
THE .500 MARK AT THE MOMENT.
THEY HAVE THE TWO BEST PLAYERS
IN THE SPORT.
MIKE TROUT HAS BEEN THE BEST
PLAYER IN THE SPORT FOR THE PAST
DECADE.
SHOHEI OHTANI IS TAKING OVER.
FOR TROUT, THIS IS REALLY THE
ONE LOST SEASON FOR HIM.
HE WILL END UP MISSING WELL OVER
TOM: TOM: 100 GAMES THIS YEAR.
-- OVER 100 GAMES THIS YEAR.
TOM: HE'S LOSING TOO MUCH OF THE
PRIME OF HIS CAREER.
WE THOUGHT THAT CALF INJURY WAS
A MATTER OF A MONTH OR TWO.
IT HAS BECOME A FOUR-MONTH
ISSUE.
WE PROBABLY WON'T SEE HIM AGAIN
THIS YEAR.
EVERY TIME I COULD GET OUT THERE
AND DO BASEBALL ACTIVITIES, HE
WOULD FEEL OK.
THE NEXT DAY, THE SORENESS WAS
THERE AGAIN.
NEVER GOT TO THE POINT WHERE HE
COULD GET BACK ON THE FIELD THIS
YEAR.
SCOTT: THREE CAREER POSTSEASON
GAMES, ALL IN 2014 AGAINST THE
ROYALS.
LOOK AT ALL THE HARDWARE.
MIKE TROUT'S TROPHY ROOM.
CAN'T BELIEVE WE HAD ACCESS LIKE
THIS.
THERE'S THE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR
IN 2012.
ALL-STAR GAME M.V.P..
WOW.
EIGHT SILVER SLUGGERS.
MULTIPLE.
M.V.P.'S, THREE OF THEM.
MIKE TROUT IS THE BEST PLAYER OF
THE PAST DECADE.
TOM: YEAH.
HE IS THE STANDARD.
YOU CAN TALK TODAY ABOUT GUYS
LIKE FERNANDO TATIS.
OHTANI IS IN THAT DISCUSSION.
HE IS THE CHAMP WHEN IT COMES TO
THE BEST PLAYER IN THE GAME.
RIGHT NOW, HE'S NOT.
HE HASN'T BEEN ON THE FIELD.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF LACK OF
PRODUCTION.
SCOTT: HOW DO YOU THINK THE
SEASON WOULD LOOK FOR THE ANGELS
IF THEY HAD A FULL YEAR FROM
TROUT AND A FULL YEAR FROM
RUNDOWN?
WOULD IT BE PLAYOFF RELEVANCE OR
IS THE PITCHING JUST REALLY NOT
THERE?
THAT HAS BEEN THERE FOR A GOOD
PART OF THE PAST DECADE.
>> I DON'T THINK PITCHING IS UP
TO THE CALIBER OF BEING A
POSTSEASON TEAM.
YOU WOULD DEFTLY BETTER WITH
THOSE TWO GUYS ALONE IN THE
LINEUP.
STARTING ROTATION THE LAST TWO
YEARS, 29TH.
THIS YEAR, 22ND.
NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
SHOHEI OHTANI IS THE ONLY ONE
WHO HAS THROWN MORE THAN 100
INNINGS THIS YEAR.
YOU CAN'T BE A PLAYOFF TEAM WITH
THAT KIND OF STARTING PITCHING.
FOR ME, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE WHAT
HIS NUMBERS WOULD HAVE LOOKED
LIKE WITH RUNDOWN AND TROUT
SURROUNDING HIM IN THE LINEUP.
MY GOODNESS.
THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
SCOTT: THAT'S ONE OF THE KEYS
WITH THE CONVERSATION.
IF YOU ARE PUTTING HIM UP
AGAINST VLADDY JR., VLADDY JR.
HAS SOME HELP.
A LOT MORE SO THAN SHOHEI OHTANI
RIGHT NOW.
WHY ARE YOU PITCHING TO SHOW
HIGH?
MANY BASEBALL OUTSIDE THIS OWN.
HE'S BEEN GREAT IN THE SECOND
HALF ON THE MOUND.
HE WILL DO THAT AGAIN THIS
WEEKEND.
FIRST OFF, THE EAST IS HEATING
UP AGAIN.
THE PHILLIES HAVE SOME CUPCAKES
DOWN THE STRETCH.
JUST SAYING.
OUT WEST, THE GIANTS AND DODGERS
ARE IN A BATTLE.
ONE OF THOSE TWO BALLCLUBS --
THEY MIGHT FINISH AS THE TOP TWO
RECORDS IN THE SPORT.
ONE OF THOSE SEAMS IS GOING TO
HAVE THEIR SEASON ON THE LINE
AND A ONE-GAME WILD-CARD.
WHO IS THAT AGAINST?
THE CARDINALS, REDS, PADRES,
PHILLIES.
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE HAS A LOT
LEFT TO BE DECIDED.
THERE'S ONLY ONE THING WE KNOW.
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS ARE GOING
TO TAKE THE NATIONAL LEAGUE
CENTRAL CROWN.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO TRY
TO PLAY SPOILER AGAINST THE ST.
LOUIS CARDINALS WHO HAVE JUST
JUMPED RIGHT BACK INTO THE
WILD-CARD CONVERSATION.
LED BY SOME OF THE BEST.
YADI MOLINA, WAINWRIGHT.
HE WILL BE THERE, I WILL BE
THERE.
BRETT WILL BE THERE.
NEXT WEEK ON THURSDAY, IT'S OUR
LAST YOUTUBE GAME OF THE SEASON.
GOT A RATE ONE TO FINISH THINGS
OFF.
THERE'S A DECENT CHANCE IT WILL
BE SOMEWHAT LIKE CORBIN BURNES
OR FREDDY PERALTA.
THREE CY YOUNG CANDIDATES.
FOR THE COSMOS, THEY ARE IN A
BRAWL RIGHT NOW FOR A WILD-CARD.
TOM: THEY CAN BE AS DANGEROUS AS
ANYBODY.
WIECK?
THE PITCHERS THAT YOU MENTION.
POSTSEASON BASEBALL, YOU NEED TO
GET HITTERS OUT IN THE STRIKE
ZONE.
GUYS ARE MORE DISCIPLINED,
INTENSITY FOCUSED.
DIES LIKE WOODRUFF, PRADO, BURNS
IN THE BULLPEN.
THEY CAN GET HITTERS OUT.
THEIR STUFF IS SO GOOD.
I THINK THEY ARE A TOUGH MATCH
UP FOR THE GIANTS, DODGERS,
ANYBODY THEY MIGHT PLAY.
SCOTT: WORLD SERIES CONTENDER.
THAT'S AS GOOD AS IT GETS TO END
OUR YOUTUBE SLATE.
THIS WAS AN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE.
WHAT A DAY.
WHAT A GAME.
A LITTLE BIT OF EVERYTHING GOING
ON.
ONE MORE MATCH UP NEXT WEEK,
SEPTEMBER 20 THIRD.
PREGAME SHOW STARTING AT 1:30
EASTERN.
FOR OUR ENTIRE STUDIO, GREAT
JOB.
WE LOVE BEING HERE.
LOGGING OUT FOR NOW.
A IS WHEN IT BY FOUR.
SEE YOU NEXT [CAPTIONING
PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
--  [CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]